[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to round seven at the
tata steel tournament there has been a
change of guards in the commentary team
i'm still fiona anthony but i'm
delighted to be joined today by grand
master daniel narudicki dania how are
you today
fiona i am doing great good afternoon to
you and i am honored to be replacing uh
grandmaster has these are very very big
shoes to fill i'm not confident that i
will be able to fill them but i will do
my absolute best that it really is an
honor to be commentating uh the tata
steel tournament with you i have never
woken up so eagerly at 6 45 at least i
don't remember the last time that
happened so i'm doing great fiona i'm so
excited
today's round i am certainly glad to
have you here with me already i know
it's very early where you are but dania
without further ado
let's have a look at the results from
yesterday so yesterday we had three
decisive uh results with world champion
magnus carlson winning his game against
which are to report anish kevi got a big
a win with the black pieces after a
shocking move uh dania by
fabiano on move 40 this rook b6
yeah that was crazy i was watching at
that point the live coverage and i was
as shocked as everybody was i think uh
but to me it was even more shocking that
fabby jumped out to such an overwhelming
position earlier in the game
and i thought that but you know by the
time he blunted things had already
become very complicated what a resilient
performance by geary and of course
magnus
blowing through the gates in that
catalan i mean that wasn't even close
yeah it's a very nice game and then
something more quiet in sergey karjakin
felt like a
more of a positional master class
against jordan
van ferece the rest were draws some more
eventful
than others but let's look at the
standings after round six with a
three-way tie at the top there dania
carlson mamidyarov and vidit i think the
first name there is a name that most
people expect muhammad yarov also a
veteran of these kinds of events vidit
though he's been having an amazing
performance this could end up being a
breakthrough performance for him if he
can sustain this fiona but if we look at
the peloton there's two people three and
a half there's a ton of people with
three
uh the tournament standings are so
packed together anything can change with
every round indeed everything's so close
and with still seven rounds to play
anything could happen here we see the
matchups
for today i think the game that i'm
particularly looking forward to it's
between one of the leaders and one of
the pursuers i'm waiting for it to pop
up this one i'm also excited for jordan
wentworth against vidit uh niels
grandelius he's not had the best start
but now had two solid draws and this is
the one
dania that i'm so excited for richard
report against shakhim amirov
two incredibly explosive players and
that promises to be a very competitive
game and of course we're always excited
to watch magnus carlsen the pressure is
on him
to to win this game but prague with the
white pieces is a force to be reckoned
with uh not somebody that you can mess
with and and certainly somebody that can
that can sting if you over press indeed
and well there's also a special flavor
to that game because it is their first
classical encounter so the first time
that pragnanda and magnus are squaring
it off at a classical time control and
prague we saw yesterday some brilliant
preparation uh to hold sam shanklin to
draw pretty much out of the opening and
today with the white pieces i'm very
curious to see what he's cooked up for
magnus
absolutely i am as well uh you know all
these raiding disparities they just add
more intrigue it may be eight degrees in
vikon say it's minus six here in
charlotte but there's gonna be a lot of
heat
on the board fiona that's for sure there
certainly will and well it's not just us
here and the players in the playing hall
but you two at home can get involved so
dania how did they do it
absolutely do not forget to vote on the
result of today's games go to chess.com
events navigate to the tournament select
the game click vote and select your
winner you you could win a a piece of
the 1 000 prize vote for best voters or
free diamond memberships voting ends
after the 10th move of each game so
don't miss out and remember to vote on
all the games do not procrastinate
you've got 10 moves so make sure to put
in your votes at chess.com
events fiona we hope everybody gets
involved indeed get involved always a
fun time
um and well now we're only two minutes
away here from the start of the round
andreas panko he is always nice and
early at the board but we see that sam
has arrived as well uh
dania one of the big intrigues during
the first six round is the chat has been
wondering when is that banana gonna be
eaten hasn't been touched just yet maybe
today will be the day
indeed maybe sam will go bananas today
um
and here he here he is taking off the
mess sitting down he's got the apple on
the banana i've known sam for so many
years he's of course also from the bay
area uh and he has his routine in these
tournaments he's got it worked out to a
tea he wakes up at the same time he eats
the same food he brings the same fruits
to the board
uh sam is a consummate professional a
man who has his routine down indeed
there we saw fabiano having a little
chit chat with vidit uh prior to the
round anish kiwi has also arrived for
his game
against daniel dubov in the background
we see there's always a bit more action
on the weekend well it used to be the
case pre-covert days that the weekends
were absolutely packed of course now
with the lockdown only very select
number of of press are allowed in the
playing hall and there we saw prague
arrive for his game against magnus and a
handshake there between nils grendelus
and sergey karyakin
indeed neil's in last place right now
he's got one and a half out of six but
nothing to be ashamed of he of course
has drawn magnus
and uh with over half you know the
tournament still to go
uh niels could end up toward the top
half of the standings things could very
well change for him
indeed and we see the place has have
received uh another official
communication we're not sure exactly
what it is but we saw two o'clock on the
dot fabiano starting
uh the clock and magnus we can see
as always fashionably late usually
late
he usually arrives within the first 30
seconds or so after the round has
started so i'm expecting him to
to come onto the stage any moment uh now
i don't know if we'll wait when we see
at the bottom there
our tournament he's both the tournament
arbiter and tournament dr alex so he's
got a
a busy busy few weeks here and i think
on the left-hand side i think that was
argenti we just saw arrive he's of
course uh currently not just leading the
challengers but absolutely crushing it
he's on fire arjun is such a beast and
you know
he's having a phenomenal performance but
i'm just not surprised and there he is
the man himself you know you don't want
that awkwardness of sitting at the board
for a minute having to chat to your
opponent this is the way to do it you
sit down you press your opponent's clock
all within five seconds and it's uh it's
incredible all the opponents i don't
know if this started as a trend and if
one player is copying the other or if
they all want to share that respect but
every day magnus or almost every day
it's been you know just that one minute
late but the opponent have pretty much
never
started the clock but magnus he came sat
down press the clock and uh prague has
just made the move one d4
a terrible blunder here by pregnant i
think he can basically resign i mean
this is this is a decisive mistake you
know there's really nothing else to
commentate
we see magnus i don't know if
it has even registered with him yet the
more a move has appeared on the board
yeah
what did he play
all right man i have to play chess today
all right all right i guess i'll figure
something out the players of course
still have two rounds to go until the
next rest day we saw magnus v the
communication he also is a man of
routine usually he comes and starts the
clark writes down the player's names and
then usually we'll see him adjust all
the pieces before making his first move
he's in absolutely no hurry there's a
very generous time control magnus is
really not known to get into severe time
pressure and even if he does it
never feels like he's particularly
perturbed
i am curious to see what kind of
approach he's going to take obviously
i think he's playing for the win uh you
know he's not going to play something
that even allows a either a fourth straw
or a line that really simplifies the
position
but to how extreme is he going to go is
he going to go king's indian benoni or
is he going to go
queen's gambit queen's gambit accepted
and he's gotten d5 yeah it's gone d5 so
a more solid approach on move one uh i
think that yeah he will not take any
crazy risks i think
very often what they say the youngsters
you want to i'd play them
in the end game but i don't know prague
he isn't just here you're run of the
mill a young kid who's clueless about
endgames
not at all i've had the pleasure of
training with prague uh for a couple of
sessions and
let me tell you he is a calculating
beast he's got
tons and tons of knowledge he's got a
vast memory of games and that bodes very
well for his positional understanding as
well he's got no clear weaknesses and
that of course is fiona the new
generation of young players whereas it
used to be yeah you could go into the
end game anything positional even
against grandmasters
not like that anymore they are so much
more well-rounded no but
danya it looks like magnus has rung the
first uh opening surprise here playing
at the accepted uh accepting the queen's
gambit he hasn't done it on move uh on
move two which we see sometimes we saw
it yeah was it yesterday or the day
before
i'm so terrible we saw one i think it
was karjakin who took on move two uh but
magnus he waited for prague to play
knight f3 and then took on c4
yeah and i'm not a big
queen's gamer except special is what i
can say though
uh is that this is quite likely to
transpose into
uh the main line of the queen's gamut
except i mean if frog plays e3
uh which i see is the main line black
usually goes knight f6 and then we get
you know mainline queen's gambit
accepted stuff after c5
uh alternatively
prague has a couple of other options he
can play queen a4 check in this position
it's more rare uh and he can also play
e4
and then generally black clings to the
pawn with with b5 and this leads to
tremendous complications after a4 my
guess is that product if he is surprised
he probably will revert to
uh the more standard move e3 and i think
he's quite clearly surprised we see him
there
on the camera he sort of had a moment
where he closed his eyes for a second i
actually i can
barely remember magnus again where
magnus played the accepted queen's
gambit i don't know if there's been a
trend lately i see in a question in the
chat um correct me if i'm wrong but
isn't the queen's gambit accepted quite
rare at the top level it's true daniel
that it's not
an opening we see all too often
yeah and i i remember discussing this
topic with yasser a couple of years ago
uh much like
fashion in close uh fashion and openings
doesn't always correspond with some
objective metric
uh and so
openings like the night or uh queen's
gambit accepted which one could say are
a little bit less popular in the last
few years it's not because they've been
refuted uh
openings like the sebastian cobb as well
and nobody really has found anything
against them it's just fashion it's just
what people play at the moment it's all
about the italian
and uh and the berlin these days
very true we talked about this with
robert a little bit as well i think
openings fashion so often influenced by
world championship match
matches which has just passed now so
we've seen the tremendous influence of
that but daniel let's move on from here
for now prague has decided to go e3 so
we're working back into the main lines
let's bring up the bird's eye view and
see
what is happening elsewhere
well there's a very interesting position
in the game between andreas panko and
sam shanklin so i vote we
uh visit that game for a couple of
moments wow there is a pawn
on g4 let's see how that got here
okay so this was a it's definitely
sicilian i'm getting major sicilian
vibes here what kind of a sicilian you
might ask well it was a
time on off knight c6 queen c7
andre going bishop e3 and then going g4
which is not the most common way of
playing
of course this is a very typical move in
general in the sicilian sam's striking
on the other side of the board we get a
trade on c6 andre going queen d2 and
there is the pawn sacrifice which sam
gladly accepts he goes b4 chasing away
the knight then he takes the pawn and
what does andre get in return for the
sacrifice fun well we can clearly see
the development advantage he's
threatening
a pin and now he's got three three
pieces developed if he goes bishop g2 to
sam zero currently it's two to zero i
mean it's kind of crazy to think that
we're on move 12 now 13 and only on move
13 does a p a black piece other than the
queen
come out crazy
daniel robert and i we've been talking
quite a bit about um
giving up material sacrificing upon
sometimes two for the initiative again
which is a more than just a trend i
think uh the engines and
alpha zero and co have really influenced
chest
chess and such
exactly players are taking a lot more
liberties with their material and here
well i was just gonna ask you what you
make of the the position knight uh h5
not a move i had on
on my radar but
immediately trying to put some pressure
on the black king side
yeah not a move i had on my radar either
and
as i can as far as i can see this has
not occurred before in tournament
practice but sam
has been playing instantly thus far and
andre hasn't taken enough time uh to
where
i think that he's uh out of his
preparation sam though again playing
instantly knight d5 now that maneuver
makes sense
andre's probably gonna go bishop d4 and
that i think is the idea of knight h5
he's going to put early pressure on the
g7 pawn and what might end up happening
fiona is that after bishop d4 black is
likely to go rook g8 and guess what that
means black is committed to not castling
kingside and here andre could consider
piling on the pressure with a move like
queen d3 hitting h7
i don't know what to make of this it
looks very exciting for white at first
sight i like it for for white i was
saying that in general i prefer the
material because uh what happened for
example didn't hap it happened in the
pragnanda game i think against rapport
uh just just was that just yesterday no
not yesterday two days ago where um
life looked good for him but richard
just defended
uh stuck to his extra pawn and converted
that the extra material in the end but
here i'm liking this for white you're
talking about queen d3 to put pressure
on h7 i was wondering what about queen
to g5 can we afford to get the queen out
there or are we
steering too far away from our own king
well let's have a look i think queen g5
the issue is that black will go h6
and i'm just not seeing a suitable
anchor point for the queen
around the k i mean you can go queen h4
here
but but then perhaps i can go g6 and
chase the knight away and andre he has
gone queen d3 here
and sam immediately responding with g6
so this position has been reached
it's crazy to see some two consecutive
days playing the moves instantly
yesterday with white against prague he
was so well prepared but prague although
he was spending a bit more time he was
no uh less well prepared and that ended
just uh in a more or less fourth draw
out of the opening today sam on the
black side once again both players
playing a very fast here
and um i'm curious the knight is being
kicked does the knight have to move
no and in fact i'm pretty confident that
uh zapanko is going to go bishop g2 here
and the point is that this is what i
would call a pseudo sacrifice it's not
really a sacrifice because after g takes
h5 you recover the knight immediately
and capturing this is unthinkable white
gives rookie one check
bishop e7 and now this is an interesting
moment fiona because bishop f6 is so
tempting it looks winning but black has
queen f4 check picking up the bishop
but
this is crushing i think
wow this is a really crazy line with
white giving up all the material but the
black king and just not finding
any shelter we can play this line out um
here here i mean this is all very
straightforward and now you know what
what you have to do fiona is you can't
go bishop f6 that's a crime you have to
go queen f8 first
because if you can sacrifice the queen
always do it this is exactly how the
game's going to end sam is definitely
falling for this
well it just might because jessie panko
has played bishop
g2
and uh well it's over over to sam uh now
he has
instantly captured on h5 dania
okay so that tells me that after bishop
takes d5 he is very likely to either
move his rook or play bishop b7 i'm
stunned that he's still playing
instantly where 17 moves deep into a
line that is far from common this just
showcases sam's
you know otherworldly level of opening
preparation that's what makes him so
scary even among super gm's yeah and i
mean it's it's crazy we we have the bar
and it also shows us once again how we
can
never trust the bar here in the opening
stages because it is operating at a much
lower depth remember the players at home
sam probably has spent hours looking at
this line
with maybe a variety of different
engines and at a much uh deeper depth
but from a human perspective dania what
do you make uh of this position
well
you know if i had to choose sides i
would definitely choose white because it
feels like white's got white's having
all of the fun here sacrifice the bees
the problem of course is that white is
down upon
uh and and the fact that sam is playing
instantly would be
true i've been in espanko's shoes i've
played sam before thinking okay i've
gotten him out of theory it's an
uncommon line and then he continues
blitzing out moves and it's one of the
most disconcerting feelings you could
experience particularly if the position
is sharp you know you've been out
prepared you know that sam has probably
and you don't even know how deep his
preparation goes what if it goes 25
moves
and and that nervousness often produces
irrational decisions you try to throw
your opponent off but in a position
that's this sharp
uh that could backfire so i think
concretely after bishop takes d5 the
likeliest is bishop b7
and my question is you know let's say
white just takes on b7
and at first i thought queen takes h7
looked very promising but i think the
idea here is rook takes g4 and let's not
forget that at the right moment black's
king can escape the center via the queen
side not that it's that safe there but
it might be safer than it is
in the center yeah this is a weird
position of course here white could as
well take uh on h5 then suddenly um we
would have even material but we will see
uh because andre he has captured on d5
and some of course instantly responding
immediately and and leaning back to he
was just
i mean it's just
you know like you know it's just playing
casual game just another day in the
office i'm still in prep on move 18.
yes i'm looking and nice and relaxed
they're
very likely though that andrey yasipanko
has also
seen this position before
so yeah this will
be an interesting theoretical battle
we'll see for how long can sam keep
blitzing at his moves we'll come back
here but shaping up to be
very exciting let's go back to the
bird's eye view
um well i see a lot of comments in the
chat of course we see yanish giri
against dubof duboff yet to make his
first move the default time here in
vaikansei is half an hour
so in 15 minutes we will know more as to
what is happening in that game
meanwhile elsewhere uh dania what is
catching europe uh uh uri
report mahmud yarov is delivering on its
promise of immediately creating
excitement let's get to rihard's game
and another sicilian and this time of
four nights sicilian so of course in the
um in the sam shanklin game you you had
knight c6 queen c7 here but mamidiaro
going knight f6 knight c3 knight c6
and now the move a3 which is one of
uh many viable sidelines in this
position the main line here the two main
lines are considered to be knight takes
c6 followed by e5 and knight d to b5
which sometimes transposes into this
fashion cup the point of a3 of course is
to prevent the move bishop before and
mom and dr responding with d5
wow this already uh
is gonna get very exciting now what's
going on in this position well uh the
main move here is bishop b5
and then after bishop d7 the queen no
longer makes contact with the d-pawn so
generally white takes on d5
and
fiona what i'm seeing here is that you
generally get this type of position
which at first sight does look very
pleasant for white because he's got
control of the square in front of the
isolated pawn which is very important
but again it's so important to emphasize
that concrete preparation and computer
analysis always transcends this
superficial
you know sort of look at the position
and saying oh white's just slightly
better that's that's not how these
people are preparing trust me indeed and
while we have a position here where
asharia would be playing with that
isolated pawn but i guess in return he
would be looking for
active piece play here and probably this
sort of position that suits his style
get the pieces out get active um and i'm
glad that this pairing didn't disappoint
because we saw richard report earlier in
the tournament uh player petrov which
was kind of
uncharacteristic of his style so
yesterday when i saw this match of
iphone please don't
don't disappoint in the opening don't
play something calm like a quick
theoretical line but here i think we're
in for
um a very interesting battle
we definitely are and rehard is taking
the first substance of think of the game
it's entirely possible that he didn't
expect d5
uh because the the most common move here
by a country mile is d6 uh reaching a a
common scheme
pawn structure and then you know why can
go bishop e2 or bishop c4
uh depending on depending on his taste
so
d5 played pretty quickly by chakriar
and it appears that rihard is already
out of his
out of his theoretical purview
and it will be interesting also to see
how he's recovered uh from the loss
against magnus yesterday shakira made an
interesting uh draw for
um have you seen any of robert's
runs
on the draw for i guess you're well well
familiar well versed with them
i've heard a few
they've reached they've reached even the
remotest parts of the globe that i
inhabit
well for sure for this spectator is
always disappointing but today i think
from what we've seen so far
plenty of action lined up everywhere and
well we'll come back here it could well
be
as you just said that
is going to take his his time here as
somewhat surprised by d5 so let's go
back to the overview one more time
and you know just speaking very
preliminarily here it's impossible to
say
as of yet which games are going to take
which type of arc but let's have a look
at van forest against vidit because of
course vidit is sharing the lead right
now he has the black pieces against a
struggling jordan
uh but if i had to make a prediction i
would guess that that game
might be the likeliest so far to end in
a quick draw judging by the opening
evidence they have a nimzo indian and
this particular variation of the nimzo
indian is known to produce a lot of
simplification and there's a lot of
lines uh that have a high potential for
perpetual check now you might ask why
that is
and essentially i'm just going to
quickly run through
the line itself so there was an im so
indian queen c2 variation considered to
be sort of the traditional main line the
most reputable system
and takes takes d5 knight f3 this should
be a familiar sequence to anybody who's
watched top tournaments for any length
of time
bishop comes out to g5 black fianchettos
to b7 and that already is
relatively rare the main move here is
bishop a6 i call this the hyper
fianchetto attacking the queen
but vitted choosing the traditional
fiance with bishop b7 jordan
centralizing his knight and it appears
that this is already a new position 95
does seem to be a novelty so maybe i
should take my words back
yeah so well maybe we can come back to
to what you were saying you said that
very often at this lead to some um
some very equal positions sometimes some
early uh
perpetuals or so where does the usual
how does that happen where does that
happen
yeah so so let's take a sample line
bishop a6 queen a4 i'm just going to
follow the most popular move splatco c5
we have a a trade on c5 what black is
basically saying is that white has a
hard time uh finding a safe haven for
the king so black is willing to make
some positional compromises in order to
go for the initiative
and i think one of the
you know earliest perpetuals rookie one
queen b6 now i can take on f6 i think
most people can already see how this can
end in a perpetual queen g4 followed by
queen h4 white has to defend b2 first
and foremost after knight c6 if white
wants he already has a draw check
then you can hit the pawn with quinn h4
and black has no choice but to defend it
and then we can give a check on g4 and
31 games have ended in this way a lot of
them
uh high level games so it's one of those
draws i don't know what to call those
but berlin draw you know there's a whole
category of those types of draws and
this would definitely fit in
but is vivid playing for a win with
bishop b7 is that what we are to
interpret from it i don't know or is he
just
you know deciding to play this move
because he thinks it's as good as bishop
basics yeah it's an interesting what
what are both players um i think in
general of course in those elite round
especially around robin events uh with
the black players uh
players in general tend to be happy to
play solidly draw is usually not a bad
result and then try with the white
pieces but here it's hard to say with it
he is one of the joint leaders he is
playing jordan who although he is the
title defender is one of the lower rated
players
in the field he's also coming off a a
tough loss yesterday so but it could be
sensing his son his chance here but also
jordan i wouldn't be surprised if jordan
with the white pieces he wants a fight
as well
indeed let's not forget that he is the
defending champion
of todd steele and he has really become
well known in the last year or two for
his incisive opening preparation he's
got a hour and 36 on his clock and
that's quite ambiguous it's hard to say
whether he's still in preparation most
likely he is
uh and a lot of people
you know they find it puzzling that if a
player is in preparation then why is he
spending any amount of time on on his
move and there can be a couple of
reasons for that the first is that these
players are not machines as much as we'd
like to believe that they are
um they have thousands and thousands of
moves and files to remember
and you know sometimes they're just
taking time to make sure that they're
not confusing anything sometimes they're
taking time to bluff their opponent and
to sow the seeds of doubt in their
opponent's mind right that feeling like
my opponent in preparation or or not and
that often changes your your approach so
this is totally normal to spend a
significant amount of time even if you
analyze this at some point in the past
indeed so uh well we'll see you uh
already we're on a new territory here
after the rare bishop b7 and now knight
e5 and we see jordan there
thinking
so
let's come back to uh the bird's eye and
the bird's eye view
we see that duboff has still not shown
up so we will know
more there in in five minutes that's not
a relay hour he is not here yet but in
five minutes we'll know more as that's
the default time
then what else
uh is happening there's a couple of
games we haven't looked at yet uh
maybe we can start with grandelia's
karyakin what do you think well let's
take a quick look at grindelius kuryakyn
for sure uh and
it is a petrov it is sort of a
traditional patch-up and you know we
were talking about opening fashion the
petrov is another fascinating opening in
this regard and fiona i think you very
correctly mentioned the world
championship that has such a bearing on
uh what people are playing nepo of
course uh ended up playing the the shrub
i think to everybody's surprise uh and
he didn't do poorly with it opening wise
no and he also had a certain sergey
karjakin on his team
i don't know
stop mentioning these weak players and
expecting me to know what that is
but uh around 2005 2006 boris gailfund
uh really pioneered uh this line of the
petrol because knight c3 used to be
considered very dangerous weapon against
it then it fell out of favor and just in
the last couple of months it's uh
rearing its head again i'm not going to
say rearing it's ugly head i'm not i'm
ambivalent on the petrov
so bishop b7 bishop b3 and then black
knight d7 queen d3
which is a common
way to play in this type of position
aiming at the h7 pawn in case black
castles and knight c5
this position has still occurred a
couple of times i see
and generally white drops the queen back
to d2 you don't normally want to take
this kind of knight and give up the two
bishop advantage black is totally fine
accepting the doubled pawns because
white also has double pawn so it's not a
big deal
yeah and well i'm curious here in in the
position on the board can you tell us a
little bit although i understand we're
on quite north almost normal territory
already uh in here what's one of the
things i'm always curious is the king
situation what's going to happen with
the king especially the white king can
that go
queenside can it go both sides what's
the usual and development approach for
white
that's a great question and that is the
reason why this opening is one of the
most fascinating because what's quite
rare about it is that both sides can go
either way in many different lines black
can go long side or short side white can
go alongside or short side and this is
true in a lot of openings like you can
find an example right of a sicilian game
where black goes queenside castle but
it's it's just not that common here it
really is common but the way they're
playing right now i'm expecting black to
castle short and then after white castle
is long there's a transposition to
a very popular line i'm seeing over 100
games here
and
you know in that sense it's a pretty
traditional case of opposite side
attacking you know white often goes h4
and knight g5 and black often pushes his
own pawns although it's not as simple as
that so for example the main move here
is to start with the flexible rookie
eight just getting the rook to a better
square and
you know there's a little bit of a
cat-and-mouse situation where both sides
are waiting for the other to come in so
i'm expecting
uh black castle black to castle
shortside and white's gas alongside but
we'll see and then it will be far from a
dull uh petrov of course with opposite
sides uh castling so we will see does
niels go back to d2 do we return to
familiar territory does he have a
surprise in mind we'll come back here
let's go back to the overview and i
think there's only one game we haven't
looked at if i'm not mistaken that's
duda against carrana so maybe we can go
there and then we'll take our first
quick break of the day absolutely that
sounds like a plan
let's have a look at jkd and for fabio
of course fiona it's going to be crucial
uh to bounce back and when you blunder
like that especially out of the position
that he had it hurts your confidence
doesn't matter who you are fabie magnus
how many tournament wins you have under
your belt when you blunder a piece
in one move it shakes you you begin to
doubt yourself is this the kind of form
that i'm in this tournament do i need to
double and triple check every minor
decision and fabi has to put those
demons out of his mind we have actually
a a london system
and interestingly fabi has opted for a
grunfeld type setup against the london
which is not the most popular way to
meet the london so just to run through
what happens there's d5 bishop f4 and
now the move g6
the reason that i think most people
don't necessarily play like this with
black is that this bishop is going to be
biting on granite after white plays c3
this pawn on d4 is white's biggest
stronghold
uh and developing the bishop to g7
is is quite a bold idea in that sense
c5 c3 b6 and now duda centralizing his
knight on e5 this is the position on the
board
yeah so interesting to see fabiano take
a different quite an unusual approach
against uh the london but both of these
players still chasing at their best form
here in vicanza both of them have
already qualified to the the candidates
tournament and yeah it'll be very
interesting uh to see
which mindset both players bring uh
dania can you maybe tell us a few words
about the plants here the knight has
just jumped into e5
does white again the same question i
guess here white just goes king side or
could we see some crazy pawn pushes
so the old school way of playing to
london is strictly king side castle
right but in in recent years there's
been a general chess wide push to play
h4 in every position and increasingly
earlier you know first it was move four
then it was move three and now we're
seeing g4 on move three of course in the
nimzo
chakra
but of course h4 yeah h4h5 is a
dangerous idea especially before white's
castle so that's one thing i would say
don't necessarily expect
uh castle short here but from black's
perspective i think it's important to
tackle this knight quickly so one move
we might see is knight f to d7 now you
might ask why this awkward looking move
why not knight b to d7 well knight bdd7
allows a very nasty knight c6
knight jump and
black is not losing or anything but this
could get annoying
uh knight fd7 prevents that and the
other thing that knight fd7 does is that
if there is a trade
then i think black's positioning of his
bishop is justified uh because black is
now ready to play the move e5 breaking
free in the center if black can get this
move in for instance if white castles
and black plays e5 then generally
speaking in such positions black has
solved all of his opening problems so if
judah wants to play like this it's
likely that he goes knight f3 and the
battle rages around whether black is
able to break free with e5 and then the
second question that i would monitor is
whether duda goes for h4 or the more
traditional short castle well i'll be
keeping my fingers crossed for h4 but
danya while we were talking about a game
we saw that duboff hadn't arrived it is
now half past so
there is an official
statement coming out here from the
tournament so
it says daniel dubov will not be playing
the seventh round of the tata steel
chess tournament today
due to a kovit 19 contamination in his
inner circle the tournament organization
after consultation with the chief
arbiter has asked duboff to play wearing
a face mask in order to protect his
opponent anishkiri and duboff did not
show for his match which means that he
has lost his game by forfeit dubose has
indicated that he refuses to play
wearing a face mask as a matter of
principle uh duboff himself tested
negative in a quiz a quick scan test he
has also undergone a pci test of which
the result is likely to come in at this
evening
so unfortunately we will not be seeing
that game here today
daniel dubov he is
expecting
his result from the the pci test of
course we hope
he is fine and that he can return to the
tournament but
anish giri winning the game today by
forfeit
indeed of course the most important
thing is that the players remain healthy
but this is definitely very very
unfortunate
um i know a lot of people like to see
dubaf play but
such uh such is the situation
um and i'm glad that we
have clarified that
so yeah anish with a very difficult day
i mean he really put
tremendous effort into that first movie
the alternative explanation is that you
know one d4 is just winning by force yes
i think we've determined that dania
let's i think we will go for our first
quick break of the day of course we
still have six other exciting games to
look forward to and we'll come back to
them in just a couple of minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we're back here with round seven at
the tata seal chess tournament there has
been an official statement come out ten
minutes ago uh duboff uh has forfeited
his game so that's not going to take
place today anish has gotten the full
point and dubois
awaiting the result of his pci test but
dania we've got six other exciting games
that we can focus on
we absolutely do fiona and i'll just
point out we don't have to uh go to that
game but andres penko is taking a very
long think against shanklin in that
critical position or he could take on h7
or he could take on h5 so we'll keep
tabs
on that uh niels grandilius has taken
that knight on c5 which i
really thought he wouldn't take so that
really makes that pawn structure a
little bit more symmetrical perhaps he's
trying to play more solidly but the real
game that i want to focus on is the game
of the world champion pragnanda against
magnus carlson so let's bring that very
exciting position yeah let's bring that
up we see that uh pragnanda
he's developed pretty much all his
pieces while magnus's king is still
firmly stuck in the center on the eighth
indeed magnus is more time but just by
the body language i'm not entirely sure
he's totally thrilled with how the game
has unfolded let's have a look at the
last couple of moves to see how this
pretty unusual position was reached so
uh as we expected prague went e3
and they went into pretty normal queens
gambit declined waters but the first
moment where one of them diverged from
the beaten path so c5 b3 is the move
it's not the most common move b6 also
has been played now prague going bishop
a3 a hyper fianchetto that is not a
particularly typical development for the
bishop in the queen's gamut accepted
magnus responding with ipd7 d5 and there
are still a couple of games in this
position fiona takes takes
and now rook b8 seems to be the new move
all three games had continued
knight takes d5 queen takes d5
and then rook eight seven this is very
scary though to keep
to allow this queen to d5 let me ask you
about that moment because at first sight
when there was such a beautiful
bishop in the center of the board and
you can take it with unite why would you
not want to do that
yeah that's a great question i mean
leaving this bishop alive is not
necessarily intuitive but
taking is also i mean also looks very
dangerous in this position
um in this position the the engine
suggests this nasty move bishop back to
b2
uh what is the idea of this move well it
prevents black from developing the dark
squared bishop
and if black tries to shoo away the
queen
with knight f6
then the end game is just not very good
for black the king is weak white's
bishop is a monster these queen side
pawns are pretty flimsy why can go
knight bd2 to knight c4 why it's got the
initiative here no doubt about that and
magnus he certainly doesn't want a a
worse end game out of the opening that's
for sure so
he goes through ba and he reserves the
possibility of taking the bishop at his
leisure
but prague's still going bishop b2 so he
plays the same move in preparation for
knight takes d5 and it might very well
be the case fiona that magnus will just
play bishop e7 and castle short
but i think he's slightly worse i i'm
not a big fan of how how this opening
has gone for him
yeah and uh well prague certainly should
be very happy with what he's gotten if
magnus goes for the natural developing
moves uh bishop e7
uh right now let's say
uh how is white going to proceed i guess
bringing the knight out to c3 is the
normal developing move or do you want to
try and hold on to the bishop from d5
no i think knight c3 is great because
now knight takes d5 can be met with
knight takes d5 and the queen no longer
has to remain on d1 in fact i think
it'll move to c2
uh then uh the rook will come to d1 and
x-ray black's queen and for instance
black could try queen c7 here
but i still think white's going to go
rook 81 and just notice the attacking
potential that white has knight g5 is
already a definite possibility you can't
really take this bishop where it's going
to recapture with the knight with tempo
black is having a hard time
even making moves i mean the engine
suggests b5 here but after night g5
there's a steady advantage there's
mating possibilities
and
this is this is terrifying and i mean
prank could basically not really have
hoped for much more out of the opening
than this let's remind everyone it's
their first classical encounter
and uh i think as you say he has to be
very very happy with what he's gotten
here if we go back to even just a
position on the board right now after
bishop um
b2 it's just i think white just has more
space uh the pieces are more active uh
black is a little bit more crammed a
little bit more passive and yeah
also looking at magnus i agree with you
he doesn't look too thrilled here
he seems peeved you know he he looks
like somebody who's
ordered a
hamburger at a restaurant without cheese
and it's just come with cheese like i'm
i'm not i'm not supposed to be
encountering these difficulties i mean
this this is supposed to be solid why is
this annoying why is this position so
annoying
and uh
this is you know i don't want to
overstate the case here and magnus is
so incredibly good at
uh at worming his way out of these
situations he rarely you know when he's
in a little bit of trouble he rarely
gets into big trouble he always finds a
way
to douse the flames
but uh
this is you know probably could not
could not have dreamed of a better
position oh and for sure magnus this is
not what he had had hoped for coming to
the playing hall today he was not hoping
to
have to go into maybe potentially damage
limitation mode here
against prague but we'll come back to to
this one definitely an opening success
for pragnanda
let's bring back the words i
view one of the games that springs to
maya dania is run for race against vidit
gujarati
um with the players moving fast some
active pieces
what else they say panko against
schenkling and has also
changed quite a bit some pieces have
come off at the board
where would you
do you want to start with the let's
start with a jordan game and then we'll
go from there to the shankling game sure
um because yeah that caught my eye as
well there were a couple of fast moves
and vidit definitely the one taking the
longer thanks here so
we last saw the position after
uh after knight e5
uh vivid going queen d6 getting the
queen out of the pin then forrest going
e3 and now that it's striking with the
typical c5 of course you can't take the
pawn because you dropped the knight the
bishop drops back to f4 creating an
x-ray against the queen and essentially
forcing a move like queen e7
and i think what jordan is saying here
is that he's going to grab on c5
and if it recaptures
white can even go bishop b2 in this
position and prepare a castle short
because
taking this pawn on
g2
fiona just looks too dangerous to me i
mean this g file is open bishop h6
is a possibility
so it's possible that after d takes c5
vidit might have to go rook c8 here and
try to recapture this pawn on better
terms
but he's got to be precise here i like
jordan's opening preparation i think
he's putting
he's asking some questions that's for
sure for sure and he's been playing uh
quite fast as well so not unlikely that
he might still be in familiar territory
one question i have in the the position
on the board after bishop
f4 do we have to move the queen uh or do
we run into some tactical trouble if we
were to take um i don't d4 if we played
a move like knight h5 uh looking down
at the bishop
i think knight h5 is interesting c takes
d4 i do think is refuted by knight g6
and the issue is is that you can't go e5
here if you go e5 the bishop's going to
capture and then i'm going to take the
rook otherwise i'm going to take the
rook straight away
um knight h5 is interesting because
here
if you go knight g6
then what's going to happen is knight
takes f4 and if you say oh i have an
extra exchange well your knight's not
getting out of f8 and black could even
just take on g2 and
white's going to lose the game
so
knight h5 is a viable candidate move and
i guess here van forest will probably
take on c5
and then
knight takes f7 by the way is a
possibility that needs to be calculated
but even a more peaceful move such as
rook d1
uh just seems to be quite quite pleasant
for white as well yeah i agree as black
i would ideally not want to find myself
with that isolated pawn on c5 so i liked
that the line we looked at earlier with
rook c8 but yeah witted
still thinking here he's already spent
quite a bit
of time
indeed he has he spent uh 35 minutes
actually that's no joke it's the game is
only 12 moves deep
and my guess
is indeed that he is deciding between
queen e7 and knight h5 knight h5 being
a lot more concrete but potentially more
rewarding and queen e7 being the
you know the move that he's going to
play if
you know if there's something about
knight h5 that he doesn't like my guess
is that he's going to go queen e7 yeah
queen e7 seems like the safer option and
i think fitted on the black side having
been surprised out of the opening he's
probably happy here to to neutralize uh
jordan's threat so we'll come back to
this one um and let's go back to to sam
shankland and um
andrei yasipanko where things have
changed uh quite a bit
they have and
i'm this is not a typo sam has one hour
and 47 minutes after 21 moves can you
believe that
that means that he's up seven minutes
from his starting time he has basically
not invested any time at all and let's
go back we left things off
after was it bishop b7
yeah so it takes e5 this should be seven
and after well bishop b7 we had
envisioned but the exchange on b7 and
here we were curious what's going to
happen
uh in the end andre this decided to take
on h5 and the rooks came off on g1
right and i let me just quickly add that
i guess queen takes h7 allows rook takes
g4
so it looks tempting but it's nothing
special
yeah so uh andre took some time before
deciding on this line instead
but now after
queen d5 well
material
is even now
there is also no pawn i think at the
moment that white can take h7 of course
we cannot take that because the bishop
on d4
is
undefended but the question is how safe
is the the black king in the center
yeah this is a very messy position even
though there just aren't a lot of pieces
left on the board the pawn structure is
so unusual and indeed black's king is
very precarious i mean the move rook g8
is a viable candidate move in this
position and what's important to notice
is that if black escapes to the the
queen side that's simply not an option
because a6 is going to fall
so black is just going to have to roll
with it
and the engine was even at one point
suggesting king e7 in this position
in order to set up this vicious threat
of bishop h6 that's not out of the
question
what might happen is a transition to
some sort of an end game so here for
instance white can drop the bishop back
to e3 you're heading to g5 forcing black
to trade queens and even in the end game
black has
quite a few difficulties getting getting
himself untangled don't sleep on this
age pawn because if white goes around
and takes h7 he's going to have a very
far advanced passer so
rook g8 i'm sure is one of us panko's
candidate moves
maybe
he he said i mean if he plays king b1
here just to defend
a2 i feel like this is too slow although
that might also be an option
here sam could take on h5 or he could
activate his rook
man this is such a
unclear weird messy position he's made a
move he has made a move indeed and it's
b3 not a move we were
looking at
so
b3 what's the idea behind that move is
it to give some retreating space to the
bishop closing the diagonal yeah of the
queen that was looking down actually
that was a threat that i hadn't even
that was a threat
yeah queen takes a2 was
was was maybe not not a decisive threat
but but definitely not something white
wanted to allow and
i guess the knee-jerk reaction well sam
has a main main question to answer which
is does he take on h5 here
or
does he
use this hook on b3 and go a5 a4 and
wow he he looks like he's in that kind
of posture where he's about to make a
move
yeah e3 really also in his preparation
that would be insane
that would be crazy but indeed it looks
like he isn't really
calculating uh who what his next movie
that's more posture of memorization
remembering yeah he's got the
remembering posture
and he's got the one hand on the table
which oh okay so
it's hard to say i think it depends on
how long he spends and he's about to
make a move
is it a5 is he gonna snap off that pawn
on h5
let's wait and see
yeah i think a5 looks more tempting
to me but i say that based purely on my
my gut
feeling i thought it was interesting
what you said about king b1 because even
earlier in this game there were some
lines that didn't work tactically
because of i think it was some queen f4
jack or queen g5 jack so in general uh
getting that king out of that dark
square diagonal at some point definitely
a good idea
yeah there's no question that bishop h6
queen g5 is always
something to be reckoned with and sam
looking up the universal sign of
remembering trying to remember the file
that he
and dribbling his fingers on the table
it's all of those
all of those ticks that we all
uh experience
he's really going through some emotional
torture here it seems before making the
move
was it a5 or was that in another line
wait a second am i supposed to take that
pawn or am i do i take it on the next
move
and there is nothing more infuriating
than a move being in the tip of your
tongue and what always happens is that
you start by
thinking that you remember and then
there's that one voice in your head that
says wait a second wasn't that in a
different line
oh wow
okay
f5 f5
neither a5 nor queen takes h5
and f5 i mean that's a okay now we're at
least 100 percent uh sure that sam is
still following his preparation
because f5 is not a move you make after
just staring at the ceiling for a couple
of minutes
right drawing inspiration
from the chessboard on the on the
ceiling beth harmon style
but the move makes sense i think because
well first of all he's preventing queen
takes h7
second of all he's creating luft for the
king on f7 and you might wonder why
that's important well if white goes rook
g8 we've already discussed that castling
long is not an option in this position
black very well might play king f7 in
fact he will
and now the threat of bishop h6
essentially forces the rook backwards so
one could consider f5 as prophylaxis
against the rook coming to g8 now the
drawback of the move is that it creates
weaknesses right i mean you're also
weakening the king's side
it's a very double-sided
sword but i love what sam is doing here
and it's fully backed up by the engine
which gives approximate equality here
yeah very interesting i would love to
get my
queen somehow closer to the king but it
all seems quite slow i mean currently
there are no squares that i can
infiltrate g6 is covered f7 is covered
uh i wish i could open up h5 but i don't
really see how i'm going to do that i
can never really
give up h6 at least not right now when
it could be captured uh with a check
and uh then there is this annoying pin
along the along the default one question
i have for you dania is what if the
white bishop moves now and we queens get
traded how is that are you making me
evaluate that end game fiona
man i
look at the the what makes it so hard to
evaluate is the pawn structure i guess
black's pawn structure is simply better
i mean white's got all these weaknesses
across the board they're not easy to
attack
one thing i can tell you is that black
is not worse here
and and the question to me isn't whether
black's better it's how you know what to
what extent is why [ __ ] better but this
is not what a cepeka wants again he's
got weak pawns sam will have this
really nice structure in in the center
and later on he can push his pawns the
rook comes to c8 my guess is that andre
is going to move his queen i i feel like
andre is going to go queen e3
just because he wants to preserve
chances of winning the game
and and he wants this bishop to at least
have free movement along the long
diagonal
yeah and um
another question i have is how safe is
the white king i was a little bit
surprised when b3 appeared on the board
because i just did not expect for there
to suddenly be so many holes and
weaknesses on the the dark squares
around the king
it's a tremendously committal move and
one might wonder well why did andre not
go king do you want it's also it's
possible that he was worried about the
back rank the problem with king b1 is
that now you can never go rook g8
because of queen h1 and that's simply
checkmate so maybe he figured that it
was worth creating these holes
uh and he was orienting himself around
going rook g8 i guess is that he missed
f5 i mean that is just not a move that a
curse occurs to you and now he realizes
oh no i can't get my rook to g8 so
he might be regretting his previous move
just about now and he's below an hour on
the clock guess what if he takes another
20 minutes uh we're gonna start talking
about time pressure yeah and i mean what
incredible preparation
by sam i think jesse panko is going to
take at least a little bit of time here
and i wouldn't be surprised if very soon
we see him already with a one hour
deficit on the clock let's go back to
the bird's eye
view
and see what is happening elsewhere i'm
so disappointed daniel to see the queens
have come off in grand daley's career
find something to cheer me up elsewhere
what's happening okay okay yeah
kuryakyn we see a symmetrical pawn
structure uh sergey with two bishops but
kneels with uh
you know more peace activity my guess is
that you know that game is definitely
uh likely to end in a drama we'll keep
an eye on it
uh well report mommy diaries has really
opened up
so let's have a a quick look at how how
that's going down
uh so the report memory arb is the
sicilian game
that is the game let's just maybe go
back to where we we left off we left off
after d5 uh in the opening which as you
were saying quite a rare move and the
richard started thinking here uh in the
end decided to capture
now that's really interesting because we
were discussing bishop b5 and
you know i thought he would play this
move relatively quickly but no he's he
decided on he takes d5 knight takes d5
and now simply trading both pairs of
knights straight away and at this point
there's still one game in the database
goes bishop e3
i think what he's going for here is a
leading development
and he's also playing against this light
squared bishop which currently doesn't
have too many prospects we should also
notice of course the placement of the
queen and the king bishop b5 is always
something to worry about and so chakra
are going bishop d7 we heard going queen
d2 and bishop c5 castles long and this
is the current position on the board so
yeah to me it it's quite clear that
rehard is basically saying that his
position is
uh quite a bit more pleasant because
chakras bishop is really bad
and if we see something like bishop
takes e3 queen takes e3 castles i'm
almost certain that he's going to put
his bishop on d3 and perhaps even with
one minor piece uh you can still very
much uh get the queenside kingside
attack underway also he's threatening
bishop takes h7 and queen d3 yeah this
looks scary for sure we see shahia for a
second the hoodie
had come on the hoodie has gained many
many fans in the in the chat since the
start of the tournament but shahi are
uh i wouldn't say concerned just yet but
uh yeah i think richard definitely uh
gotten the better end of of this opening
here
oh for sure now white's better there's
no doubt that white's better
uh and and black has to be very accurate
here i think the position that we were
just discussing where black castles is
really unpleasant so one way the black
could try to modify that approach is
after bishop e3 queen e3
black could throw in and chucker is
about to take that bishop there it is so
he couldn't play rook c8 here and after
bishop d3 he could try to go for an
early queen trade with queen c5
uh rehard does not have to oblige and
white's likely to go queen g3 but
hereafter castle short
black does have now the possibility of
going bishop e5 so the question to me is
is quite simple can black solve the
problem
of his light squared bishop in a timely
manner if the answer to that is no white
is very likely to develop long-term
attacking chances on the king side and
he's also going to have
uh you know quite likely positional
nomination
yeah
a few uh problems here to solve for
shakia mamedyarov
well he has just captured on e3 we will
see does he castle king side can richard
report drum up an attack we'll find out
after a short break during the break our
producer vic will be updating you about
some of the action that's taking place
in the challenges tournament and we'll
see you in just a few minutes
yes welcome back we're checking in with
the challenges my name is about the big
i'm the esports producer for chess.com
i'm the producer now for white gonza so
if you know anything goes wrong see
everything goes wrong
you know to blame now and we're here
today checking in with the challenges
every day next to the master section we
also have the challenger section and the
winner of the challenger section will be
playing in the master section in the
tata steel chess tournament in 2023 so
another light and every day we take a
little peek into the challenges section
see if there are some interesting moves
interesting ideas and today
boy do you have a surprise for you
ladies and gentlemen uh this is the game
between daniel darva against uh jonas
bier we've seen him a lot he's uh he's
always in these encounters he always
gets
messed up with these kind of positions
usually on the losing end but maybe
today we'll see how that works out and
after a very simple knife alright the
things are going to get heated up really
really fast let me just give you guys
some more space you can really look at
it
after b5 a4 has been played
they've taken and after bishop to e2
uh
he doesn't take immediately he doesn't
really need to there's no way to defend
the pawn
and after
bishop b7 rook takes a4 black was good
well i'm going to throw the knight in
with a tempo and white says
that's fine i'm going to go queen b4
rook b4 and after queen a5 it looks like
this rook is trapped
and you'd be right but that was exactly
the idea
because we're going to sacrifice this
rook
on b7 taking away the light square
bishop
an exchange sacrifice and you already
see that white is in a little bit of the
lead here
and then after a short castle
g6 which is normal in the night or
white jumps in with b4 now the idea of
before that
if you take her on before there is the
incredible
move queen to a1 it defends this knight
and it makes sure this rook on b1 is
gonna have a feast there
and if you think you're funny
you're gonna play knight c5 just to get
out of dodge think again
bishop to b5 check uh-oh what's going to
happen you cannot take obviously because
you lose the rook
if you try to defend with the knight
there we're going to jump in
knight to d5 attacking this queen and
you're actually losing the queen
disrupter so there's a lot going on
there if you think well i'm just gonna
step aside move aside
knight c6 check you're still going to
lose that queen so already insane
tactics on the boards just out of the
opening after
b4 uh the queen did not take
retreated and i think that white got uh
got his preparation a little mixed up
because he went for queen a1 so he did
notice that idea for sure the idea was
there queen won't be played here but
the absolute bonkers of a move
absolutely crazy
is knight d
the b5
jumping in and this is actually the
exact same position of the knights that
essa essepenko played in carlson last
year and he beat him was also the killer
move was knight
d the b5
and you cannot take that pawn or you
cannot pick a knight because if you do
take that knight you want to take with
the knight back because that's the most
sensible move but you actually play with
the bishop jumping in with a check and
after king d8 we are gonna go bishop to
d4 these are all engine lines these are
all crazy engine move with the idea if
you play something simple let's say
bishop g7 you're gonna pounce in with e5
breaking over that structure that king
is uh in the center has nowhere to go as
you can see this is absolute mayhem this
is the quick
route after knight to d7 knight to d5
queen to b8 we're gonna go back and this
is just absolute mayhem on the board so
absolutely beautiful play
right here so what happens if you don't
take let's say we're going to we're
going to move back we're going to go
queen to b8
you're still going to jump in with
knight to d5 like i said this is an
absolutely crazy position
uh and if you take knight on d5
you take it with the queen well it might
be time to take that knight
well you'd be wrong because if the queen
c6 check
uh king d8 bishop b6 check
we're going to have a mate on their hand
after queen takes
queens c7 and this will be
a
checkmate schagmatt as they would say
here in the london so absolutely
beautiful opening beautiful ideas
in this opening and
i don't know i don't know what else to
do i don't know what to tell you
it's absolutely beautiful if you're
trying to be something fun of a bishop
g7 in this position we're going to jump
in we're going to grab that rook
and there's not really a place that you
can go to that's going to be my rook
fascinating game uh however this did not
happen after b4
queen a1
uh unfortunately he missed a few moves
and it all fizzled down and actually
they're still playing at this very
moment you can see the clock ticking
down it's a bishop and rook versus uruk
i know he's going to win but i do know
that the opening was absolutely
fantastic i had a lot of fun looking at
that
but the real shining star
is arjun eric icee who is now in the
lead five and a half out of six
uh for round six i don't know how he's
doing right now during this the time
we're watching this but i'm sure daniel
neroditsky and fiona are going to tell
us how things going on so we're going to
throw it back to them
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to round seven at
the tata steel chess tournament first
things first on the bottom right corner
i need to give you against daniel duboff
uh anishkiri won that game
by forfeit you will be able to find the
official statement on our official
twitter page
so that game not taking place today with
daniel
waiting for the result of his pcr test
but elsewhere there's plenty of action
dania
there is indeed and we will in just a
second focus on the duty game but just a
couple of quick updates before we do
that now we see that mamidarov has
indeed done rook c8 we see that andre
sepenko has moved that queen from under
the pin he's done queen e3
uh and we we see also that prague and
carlson are following a line that we
kind of analyzed where prague has gone
queen c2 preparing rook id1 and
we see on camera there i think that's
magnus right yeah that
magnus
his hands all over his head he's not
happy and he's got no reason to be happy
he's in a little bit of trouble
um
yeah kudos to prague who um
really like i don't know exactly how
he's done it if it is partly
self-inflicted by magnus
but
prague played all natural moves and just
got a very nice very nice position but
danny i believe you wanted to start with
the duda game
yeah yeah let's have a look at the duda
game
uh because we've had pretty interesting
developments now i mentioned previously
that one of the key questions and fabi
did indeed go knight fd7 is whether duda
would castle short or orient himself
toward h4 and he answered that question
right away he went h4 in this position
and fabi takes on e5 bishop takes e5 and
he's not keeping his intentions a secret
now in this situation it's tempting to
take on e5 because one might think that
the pawn on e5 is a weakness but
in fact it's really not and after knight
c6 white can play f4 and
you know this type of pawn structure can
make it very difficult for black to uh
to untangle himself and so fabi
insisting on trading bishops in a
slightly different version he goes
knight c6 in this position
and we are very likely to see a trade on
g7
and then the question for jkd is gonna
be does he go h5
or does he play a move like bishop to b5
uh trying to chase this knight a win
clamping down on the e5 square my guess
is he's gonna go h5 and one thing i just
want to point out fiona it's not like
he's going to
he's not harboring the illusion of
checkmating fabi in five moves that's
not the point of playing like this the
point is to create long-term pressure on
the king side which is going to distract
black's attention
and combine that with positional play in
the center moves like bishop b5 knight
f3 maybe queen d2 and castle long that's
not out of the question
and white is going to play on both sides
of the board both in the center and on
the king's side i like what jan is doing
i like it too i don't know if you caught
it just a second ago on the camera we
saw him
have a big yawn
which is
it's funny i mean we see this position
h4 is on the road you know there's some
potential of
some king side something happening maybe
but jan he's not
he's not fazed um he's seen it all
before but i'm
surprised that he's taking his time here
i thought that the
the exchange on g7 would be more or less
automatic but can he drop the bishop
back as well
i i'm really not seeing uh the logic
behind that
is especially because this allows the
movie five we were discussing that this
is generally a good development for
black and he's made a move and he has
taken the bishop and it's entirely
possible that he was really thinking
about the moment after that even though
we're taught to move first and make the
forced moves first and think later uh i
think he's thinking about this moment
deciding whether to play h5 or to delay
that move
again i don't see a reason to delay it
especially because if you do if you
procrastinate black himself might go h5
and then you might regret uh not going
for it when you had the chance
and uh well we see that
the eval bar
is quite uh liking the position as well
you said you like what he has done um
how worried does fabiano have to be here
already
pretty worried i mean again it's very
important to put this against the
backdrop of what happened yesterday it's
not like fappy hasn't had disappointing
results before and i just want to
mention in the u.s championship
uh fabby was having a disastrous
tournament as we see on indeed playing
h5 he lost to some amateur commentator
she'll go unnamed then he lost to sam
sebian uh he was on minus one
with half the tournament uh already over
and he bounced back to such an extent
that he almost won the tournament he he
played wesley so
in a tiebreaker for first place so fabby
is tremendously resilient that's one of
the things that makes him so scary he's
always objective so
i'm worried about the position i'm
worried about white's pressure
what i'm not worried about is i don't
think abby's going to start tilting or
do something drastic here i think he's
going to play the position and he's just
interestingly enough he's made a very
fast move after h5 uh queen d6 so
bringing the the queen out and i'm very
curious to see which of the the right
approaches
uh jan schistov is going to go for you
talked about bishop b5 i'm curious is
the king on a castle
uh queenside
what will the next few moves be um well
we will find out
we will and you know the engine suggests
a very interesting idea to take on c5
looks very anti-position why are we
giving up the center and after bc5
the queen swings out to a4
uh and the point is that the queen can
swing trampoline all the way to h4 and
that's not a joking matter bear black
can actually get checkmated the
secondary idea could be to castle
queenside and then because the d-file is
now open white has direct access to this
d5 pawn which white can attack in
several different ways uh after castling
the knight can jump out to e4 white can
play pawn e4
i mean this is a very dynamic rich
position and it just seems to me like
white is having more fun than black
white's not the one in danger of getting
checkmated a lot more fun and i really
like that suggestion of taking on c5 and
sort of opening up everything bringing
out the queen swinging it over to the
uh to the king's side and go for the
throat but we will come back here let's
bring back the overview
see what's going on uh elsewhere
it looks like sham is finally taking his
first think of the game after queen to
e3
um i swear
jordan against vidic that's still
looking very interesting where do you
want to go back to
yeah let's have a look at the van forest
game because it appears to me that that
has a very high potential of simplifying
something's about to happen there the
center is wide open
uh so let's have a look
at that position so first of all vinit
47 minutes now on the clock he's burned
over half his clock with 16 moves played
that's definitely concerning
now the last moment we looked at was
bishop f4 and as we discussed fiona
queen e7 dc5 and rook c8 did happen
uh jordan going bishop b2 developing the
bishop stepping out with queen d4 and
once again it's important to point out
that bishop takes g2 in these positions
is unthinkable just opening the g file
like that looks way too scary so bit of
centralizing his knight jordan calmly
dropping the bishop back to g3 this is
the current position now white's got the
two bishops white has better place
pieces in the center the rook on c5 can
be chased away with b4
uh vivid has to be very careful here and
even though the eval bar is giving
equality
black definitely is the one who has to
be precise
yeah and i like this for jordan jordan
he is a player last year he was so solid
on route to winning the event he didn't
lose a game but there were also previous
years i remember where he he lost some
games but he also won a very big amount
of games so he's always a big candidate
for decisive results he lost yesterday
is he gonna bounce back straight away
with a win uh well
i don't know but we certainly like
white's position
yeah and as vinit i think he played f6
f6
definitely committal but understandable
getting that knight
out of e5 that knight's probably going
to jump back to d3 the engine did not
like that move by the way never play f6
then yeah
exactly no that is one of the
nothing truer has ever been spoken
uh so knight d3 is very likely here and
then i suppose that vivid could play
knight c6 with tempo but then the rook's
going to be in massive trouble after
something like queen h4
try this line on for size rook c2 and
then
oh and then bishop d1 or even queen a4
and the rook is simply trapped that's
kind of cool we've got we have queens
swinging from a4 to h4 in two different
games wow
so yeah knight c6 might just not be an
option with the the rook getting into
too much trouble then that means
probably you have to drop back
but here i mean let's say castles knight
c6 queen h4 i mean if you just look at
black structure right these spawns are
weak
going e5 does not solve all of black's
problems now the knight on d5 becomes a
serious vulnerability it can be targeted
with a rook the other one comes to c1
notice how natural whites plays this
bishop can come to g4
i am pretty concerned here for vette's
position i i wouldn't necessarily call
f6 a mistake just yet i think that
depends on the way the next three or
four moves unfolds but
uh
this is this is a
definite opportunity for jordan uh to
put a lot of pressure yeah for sure
jordan who might be happy to see f6
appearing uh on the board we'll come
back here uh but potentially one of our
leaders in a little bit of trouble
actually maybe all three today not too
happy with what they got if we bring
back the bird's eye view who's in the
lead magnus carlsen he's certainly not
happy with the position that he's got on
the board against pragnanda right now
this one we just came from definitely uh
you're you're then the one
who's better if anything and then
finally
um
i've lost my
my screen of my media also we came from
there maybe we can quickly go back to
mamadiarov actually
um and see how is he trying to solve
these problems that you talked about uh
of his bishop being inferior to rap
archbishop
and it is interesting
as we transition to that game that all
three leaders are playing black and
all three leaders have failed to solve
all of their opening problems and yeah
as we said mahmud yarov is probably the
closest of the three to equalizing
so we have this position where indeed
chakri are going rook c8 and then queen
c5 as we discussed reports saying no no
no no
you are we are not trading queens just
yet queen g3 again why cannot castle so
chakri are forced to make this weakening
move and bishop comes out to d3 so first
of all black still can't really castle
because if bishop takes g6 and white
wins a pawn
so what comes to mind here logically
speaking is moving this bishop away
and white black could move it to a4
i mean dania can i ask a question
i understand that castling doesn't work
for the tactical reason of bishop g6 but
even if that wasn't the case
would you not be i would be terrified of
canceling uh king side i can already see
the next h pawn running up the board
exactly and i think this is precisely
what uh shakur is probably worried about
if he can play bishop a4 and fix the
tactical problem but not the long-term
problem of getting attacked i agree
after h4 white is so close to just going
h5 and blasting through the gates and
guess what if black plays h5
he has to reckon with this very nasty
bishop sacrifice on g6 now
it doesn't seem like black is losing
here after f takes queen takes king h8
but you know it's so demoralizing
because white has a perpetual in his
pocket
and shakur has to consider all sorts of
things like queen h6 and rook h3 imagine
having this position without knowing
where the eval bar stands i would be
terrified this looks losing rook is
coming to g3
but somehow black survives queen e5 and
if rook g3 check
you oh this is beautiful
queen takes g3
oh wow yeah
and that is why black put the bishop on
a4 just to have this combination
and black has to see this all the way
back without this idea black would be
losing i mean how does white even
survive because after queen g3 no there
it was too late no it's a queen it's
over and
queen e6 jack the king goes to age seven
and you know what's even more amazing if
white gives a check on e7 the queen
drops back to g7
and black is up 800 pieces
so
but this is not human i mean you cannot
calculate this i don't think chakra is
going to castle i think he is going to
play bishop
but look at the statue
he's just he's not amused he's not
amused
i don't know what to call his face this
is the like
i woke up too early today i am under
caffeinated i have a nasty position and
i really wish this i didn't play what i
played
yeah
he also said in an interview a few days
ago he was battling a bit of a flu
earlier in the tournament we hope he's
feeling better already but sometimes
these coals can drag on especially in a
place like bike which is a lovely
seaside uh town but it is known to be
quite windy
yeah i i have had i have had the unique
experience of having a cold and viking i
never played todd of steel
but i played a qualifying tournament
there many years ago and i did indeed
catch
the catch either cold or flu and there's
no worse feeling than having a sore
throat and then walking out
and experiencing that icy cold dutch
wind
uh just further exacerbating the
situation yeah and we see well there uh
the hoodie is up and
the head
is in the the hands
not looking thrilled i mean it's
understandable if we we look at the
position the problem is
you already talked about the bishop from
d7 we've just seen some tactical um
some tactical things he could be afraid
of and i think the big question is where
does the king go because as long as the
king is in the center you are playing
without the rook uh from
h8
but
yeah you really are a little bit scared
i guess of of castling kingside with all
the danger looming
indeed where does the king go and where
does the bishop goes another question
bishop c6 is not out of the question and
king e7 is also not out of the question
this is not an ideal placement for the
king but it's better than keeping it on
e8 at least here the rooks are
coordinated but you know after something
like rook hd1 white has
uh rookie five potential idea bishop e4
and what's what makes this
deflating to play is that white's really
not risking him when report report has
no targets uh he basically has a free
attack
and and that
that is so much harder to play than a
situation where objectively you might be
getting attacked but you know that you
have some some counter play
uh but this is a big big decision for
shotcare i guess i think that he's going
to spend a good amount of time here
contemplating all the candidate moves
yeah i think we'll move on uh for now
it's somewhat even tough to to see
like that really not looking
uh happy at all
with uh what he's gotten or or with life
what do we know we're just speculating
but let's bring back the words i uh view
and
my question fiona though is if i put my
hood on am i going to be as good as
chakra see i just did that
only one way to find out done yet
right exactly
so um
here we go yeah
shall we check in
oh
well for commentary maybe you're gonna
start seeing even more lines now i'm
liking
we coordinated with chakra earlier this
morning you know but the deal was that
he was supposed to win his game and make
me look better
um but that's that doesn't seem to be
happening so he hasn't upheld his end of
the bargain i want to pull
see
mine
the power of the hoodie can do for
shakia well we looked at two of our
co-leaders with it mamadira shall we
quickly go back to to prague and magnus
all right that sounds great and uh
particularly because of how concerning
the situation is
uh so let's revisit it all right so we
discussed this exact sequence of moves
when prague had the bishop on d5 and he
went bishop b2 carlson going bishop e7
that bishop remaining on d5 uh neither
side there's kind of a standoff going on
again knight takes d5 allows the knight
to swoop into the center
and magnus after a
uh quite a sizable thing deciding on the
move b5
expanding on the queen side the
immediate threat is before dislodging
the knight and winning the piece so
the most natural response to that is
rook a to d1 intending to meet before
with a move like knight e4
in this case i don't think black is
going to go before i think prague is
going to go rook 81 that's so natural
and it's very very hard to resist rock
81 looks like the natural move and not
just defending the bishop but also
x-raying uh down to the the queen on d8
and i guess b4 we saw that the bar
didn't like it uh too much it
went up in white's favor i guess the
problem would be with playing b4 here if
you're black if there's no concrete
reason to do so you may be just
weakening the the light squares a little
bit too much
you're weakening the light screws and
you're helping white activated species
94 opening up the dark squared bishop
this knight can swing to g5 i mean black
just cannot afford black could get mated
here in a matter of moves i i think that
in this position black probably needs to
get the queen out of the d file
um a move like queen c7 but as i had
indicated earlier i'm very concerned
about the move knight g5 just again look
at the attacking potential on the king
side this one knight on f6 is holding
the world on its shoulders and there's
going to be all sorts of deflection
tactics in the air with knight e4 or a
knight appearing on d5 for instance
let's say black goes bishop b7 looks
pretty innocuous right let's trade the
bishops looks logical
bishop takes b7 queen takes b7 and now a
beautiful tactic look at this rook takes
d7
okay well that seems to make sense at
the start but wait a second isn't that a
blunder the queen just takes
knight d5 again looks logical to
deflection no that's a blunder right
queen takes d5 but no it's not because
now the bishop comes into f6 threatening
checkmate on h7 black is forced to go g6
and white has not only two pieces for a
rook but just a totally winning position
after even the move 94. uh the knight's
journey to f6 is unstoppable that's an
incredible line fiona and it showcases
the attacking potential that prague has
built up for himself here i mean that
really is a stunning stunning uh line
incredible stuff i think it's
it's also nice to show because sometimes
after a move like knight g5 to the eye
it looks like okay but the attack is
still far away there are some defenders
tonight which there's such a great
defender of that square
on h7 and the other knight uh defending
it and prague has made a move by the way
uh it wasn't rook a to d1 but work after
d1 and dany i'm gonna have to ask you
because it's something that robert and i
talked about quite a bit
sometimes it's not easy to decide which
of the rooks so what do you think was
the the thought process here
and i don't exaggerate when i say that a
book can probably be written on this
very question alone which rook do i put
on a square it everybody agonizes over
it beginners grandmasters alike
uh i think the question is always well
where does the other rook belong
and what prague has decided is that he's
going to
delegate the other rook to c1 where of
course it you know
the rook on c1 is perfectly viable
the concern could be
that maybe that rook on f1 would somehow
have contributed to the attack in in an
indirect way there's just something
about rook fd1 that looks a tiny bit
awkward and i can't really put my finger
on it i don't know what it is i really
don't know what it is but from a logical
perspective yeah it makes sense because
the other rook's going to go to c1 and
all of white's pieces in that case are
going to be perfectly coordinated what i
think prague really needs to do is step
on the gas pedal in terms of the attack
when you're playing magnus not that i
know i've never played him in a
classical game but i imagine it can be
very difficult to go straight for the
throat right because it's so hard to
believe that you can actually check mate
magnus i think prague has to be fearless
here and if magnus gives him the
opportunity i think he's got to go
knight g5 yeah and i i hope that prague
seizes that chance we saw it happen a
couple of days ago i think in his game
against richard report where he was
playing on on the black side and we
really liked his position but then he
played a couple of slow moves starting
with this king f1 for those who remember
the game and sort of slowly losing the
thread of the position and i think
that's exactly what you're saying here
things are in his favor but you have to
capitalize every single move like
there's no time um
for like a slow for a waiting move
because magnus he will never let uh
those go unpunished
indeed and to that end the move h6 here
uh is a serious possibility for black
just to stop knight g5 because knight
shoot five is
with every passing second that i look at
this position it occurs to me that
knight five is a very serious tactical
threat
um and
the move a4 here is possible striking at
striking at the queen side as we see
magnus returning to the board
this is a big moment
for sure
this is a big moment i like your
suggestion of h6 because i'm also very
worried we'll have to see does magnus is
he as concerned as we are uh
about the position after knight g5 will
come back and find out for now let's go
back to the bird's-eye vien
dania i'm gonna look at one last game
before going for a quick break so i'll
let you choose one
okay well um
it's been a while since we since we
looked at the grendelius karjakin game
it's definitely not the most interesting
game but i do want to update everybody
on this end game
uh and and just you know figure out
who's better who's pushing for the win
so let's have a quick look at that end
game
okay so let's bring it up last time we
were here the queens were still on the
board so let's uh go back to that moment
also
i think we left it just before niels
decided to take on c5 which came as a
little bit of a surprise to you
yeah i mean this just discharges all of
the tension and the position and he
trades queens and black doesn't even
lose castling rights so we have we do
have opposite side castling so i guess
they delivered on their promise
the problem is that the queen's board so
it doesn't carry the same
effect rookie eight rookie one we have
another trade
uh karjakin defending against me
and neil's going h4 so it looks like
white is going for the king side attack
in reality he's just trying to
orchestrate a trade of the dark squared
bishop
and
you know if black does trade perhaps
niels is claiming that his pawn on g5 is
going to hold down it's going to deep
freeze
all of black's king's side pawns and so
for sergey
there is a very interesting move b5 in
this position chasing away the bishop
and the point is that you can't take on
f7 due to bishop takes g5 and if you
play bishop d5 i go c6 and of course you
can't drop back to b3 because the bishop
gets trapped so the upshot of that is
that the bishop has to leave this
diagonal and that in turn gives black
the opportunity to chase the knight away
with h6 i like sergey's position here
nils is also quite a bit down on the
clock almost an hour
so i don't think sergey is going to be
offering or taking a draw here i think
he's going to be pushing yeah and well i
like this because especially now after
age 6 the knight i think has to retreat
to f3 to keep an eye on the pawn
on h4 and suddenly the two bishops uh
are coming to life here
they are as well as black's queenside
pawns don't sleep on a pawn storm c4a5b4
with the bishops
being on good squares
white i'm not going to say white is
clearly worse but niels will have to be
very cautious here not to slip further
into a nasty position we all know how
good sergey is at pushing
uh these kinds of positions
yeah i expect b5 here and for sergey to
make
the most out of this little chance maybe
that he's being given here but we will
return
to this game and all the others after
just a quick break so don't go anywhere
we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
fantastic
[Applause]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
i remember coming here uh first time was
2015 i was playing the b section i had a
fantastic result i made plus five but
weiyu was an absolute terminator
i played him with white in round one and
it was a draw and it was just i never
had a chance again if i had known that
he was going to go nuts maybe i would
have uh pushed a little harder
i remember at first it was chorus chess
before it was taught to steal and i
always remembered this was like the the
most important tournament of the year
the biggest best one
tata steel chest room and you know they
call it the wimbledon of trust and i
think they've earned that name uh it's
just the best term in the world
obviously you know with magnus in the
field and i'm in the bottom half
the odds are against me but you know if
the best player always won chess will be
a very boring game i'm just going to
play my best and if the points come that
way they will
so i use technology for opening
preparation for sure but that's more or
less the only thing i use it for i think
i'm more scared in terms of the future
of trust of computers just processing
faster and then if they've become a
little bit stronger i worry that one day
chess can be weakly solved
luckily i still think that day is very
very far away and i think it will be
after i'm retired many many years in the
future
it was a very memorable tournament for
me both with positive and negative
attributes last time but i'm really
looking forward to playing again this
year
welcome back here to round seven
and always good to hear from sam
shankland and dania sam he's impressed
us with our preparation here today uh
but for the first time we see him not
just looking at the ceiling but actively
at the position
indeed he's looking at the board and
he's definitely out of his preparation
still with plenty of time on the clock
and he's just made another move so let's
have a look at what has happened in the
last
um last couple of moves here
so
uh we joined or we were looking at the
moment when sam played f5
and then after queen e3 which is end up
playing sam insisting on a queen trade
um andre saying no i don't want that
queen straight of yours
sam getting the rook involved to c8 and
andre still ending up going king b1
which is totally understandable because
now bishop h6 has actually become a very
serious threat
uh and after king b1 sam going f4
locking in white's queen i think that's
very logical and very strong move
and they've reached this very messy
position
very messy yet uh the engine once again
i mean i've been so shocked every time
every time we have some wild
some wild or messy positions the engine
just says zero zero zero
uh in this case i wonder is it seeing
something long term or could we have is
there is some way
that black could immediately or white
could force
some kind of perpetual here
yeah it's very very hard to say and you
know the move rook g8 always has to be
tested in these positions fiona but once
again i think
i think after king f7 oh there's a very
cool line king f7
and if white tucks the rook on h8
then the engine was indicating
the move e5 and now the line bishop
takes c5
d7 is hanging queen takes c5 queen takes
d7
king f6 and just like everything in
chess where does this lead he will never
believe it to a perpetual check queenie
one check king b2 and now not queen c3
check because white screen controls that
square but queen back to e5
and this is a classic situation if white
tries to cover up the check with c3 he
exposes the second rank and this is
still a perpetual is this exactly what's
gonna happen it's not entirely unlikely
because andre
could very well go for rook g8 rook had
although that takes uh a lot of bravery
that rook on h8 does look
uh to be in serious trouble and that
means you're allowing back rank checks
so we'll see
yeah i agreed but i would also not be
surprised if
andre finds a way here to bail bailout
there is already a big
time disparity between the two players
and i think he just came up against some
massive
preparation from
sam and if i were white here i don't
know how safe i would feel
playing with this king on b1 but of
course if he can find something
good on him um yeah rook g8 is one
option
you were talking about not bringing that
workout what about if i try and exchange
uh bishops
mr g summon
yeah bishop g7 the engine likes this
move and it's a very logical move it's
not so easy to find another move now of
course in the event of a trade white
stroke gets to g7 and then
that's just not something black wants to
do
i would imagine that black will refrain
from the trade with bishop b7
and now there's a crazy idea by the
computer f3 this just shows you how
irrational these positions are fiona f3
queen takes f3 bishop e5 how are you
supposed to find the idea of this is
that you're threatening rook g8 and
you're going after the f4 pawn as the
position opens up as the king side opens
up white gets more attacking chances
rook g8 becomes stronger
and black is supposed to play queen e3
here and we have total pandemonium which
once again results in some sort of a
perpetual here's how the line goes
rookie check
bishop f8 queen up to d6 obviously
exploiting the pin attacking the bishop
and once again a perpetual queen e1
checking b2
rook takes c2 check
king takes c2 queenie to check and white
has to acquiesce to the drop because if
you block with a queen black will take
the bishop and black will have 833 pawns
for the exchange white's king will
remain vulnerable so a lot of potential
for this game to end in some sort of a
perpetual check largely because of the
amount of weaknesses near white's king
that allows for these types of uh
sequences with checks on c3 and e5 and
e1
yeah i mean we've just seen a few crazy
crazy lines but i agree with you i think
it's not unlikely that one of them will
appear on the board with both kings
being cried out
in the open um
for now we
will we will return here
in a sec let's bring back uh
the bird's eye view where we see that
one game is over that's an ishghiri uh
duboff he forfeited the game and someone
in his inner circle tested positive you
can use the command x clem duboff to
find out more about that but yeah anish
getting the full point today and
elsewhere well i see we don't have to go
back there but that karjakin did indeed
play
uh b5 so nina's under some
small pressure there
i can guarantee you nils must be five
yeah
and now
he's struggling in this tournament these
are the moments which really define
imperfect form
and there's something else there's
another b5 move catching my attention
danya maybe we can go there richard
reporting against shakira mamidyarov
what's happening
absolutely very interesting decision
made there by chakriar now just to uh
remind everybody what was chakriar's
problem in that position well after
rehard played bishop d3 black had
simultaneously two different problems
the first at bishop on d7 uh is always
seems to be in the way the second main
problem is that black is nowhere good to
put his king if you castle short i mean
there were tactics and bishop takes g6
those were solved by bishop a4 rook d2
but as we discussed the second problem
was that white's just going to check
mate black by going h4 h5 and so shakur
are deciding on the move b5 which
anchors the bishop on a4 the bishop is
not really in any trouble white's not
going to be able to play b3 anytime soon
because of the amount of weaknesses that
that creates
but
you know the ultimate problem still is
where is black going to keep his king
and rehard going with the move queen f4
very flexible improving the queen
position aiming for f6
and
you know he might want to go rookie one
later he might want to go h4
preemptively
and chakrier has to be so so precise
here
it's possible that he'll bite the bullet
in castle
and then maybe meet h4 with h5 but fiona
i'd be so worried here i mean g4 h5 this
this just looks
you know
patently unappealing if i were black i
wouldn't be cancelling anytime soon i
also wouldn't be happy with my king in
the center but this just looks
too scary although once again the engine
the bar isn't phased yeah interesting a5
a5 king b1 b4
let's go
well actually a5 is the move that i
wanted to suggest in the live position
instead of castling uh can i get away
with keeping my king in the center for
just a little longer
yeah and the hilarious thing is the
engine light is still h4
b4 and now very cold blob of king
russian school chess and the point is
that if the pawn can't take on c3
because queen takes a4 is check
and so we might transpose into the line
we just analyzed if black castle's here
uh and white plays h5 well h5 is not
possible because black strikes first
with b takes c3 now this is definitely
if you don't know what black has to do
shocker has to get things started on the
queen side i agree i think a5 is the
move he hasn't played
it good on shock
i think it makes sense
i think shaq is saying i am not
interested in castling
king's side and letting you have all the
fun attacking my own king let's see how
you deal with this uh first well let's
both have let's both have some fun
and another possibility for rehearty
here is to play queen f6 i mean this
essentially forces short castles
uh because i mean if if black moves the
rook then he's never going to be able to
castle and that's too much of a price to
pay
then after h4
we have a just the most typical attack
on both sides that i've ever seen and
after h5 here's what's amazing if black
plays b takes c3 guess what white can
simply play h6
and after c takes d2 king takes d2 take
a good hard look at this position black
simply has no checks the queen on f6
guards f2 and black has to give up his
queen to prevent uh the lobster pins are
made on g7 so this is just one example
of how sharp these positions are and how
easy it is to get checkmated uh if
you're either side but especially if
you're black
yeah and you know i i actually i was
with you earlier i really liked
richard's position and suddenly
i feel a lot more torn about this game
i think shakia will be a lot happier now
than he was a few moves ago suddenly he
has some play as well as you said
not the only one having all the fun here
yeah he's 60 i mean this bishop a4 b5 a5
very creative and very strong
uh and it's really hard to say what the
objective evaluation is that the eval
bar still preferring light by a little
bit
i think queen f6 is uh
probably quite likely this queen f6 h4
idea especially if rehard realizes that
he can just leave the rook on d2 in that
line uh we might see that on the board
and then things are going to get really
exciting indeed some wild stuff on the
horizon here for now let's go back to
the bird's eye view as uh rehearse
debating his next
move um i see that magnus has not played
h6
no he has not what has he played he's
played queen c7
and this is a huge moment fiona i think
if pragmata plays knight g5 and he's
about to make a move and it's not knight
g5
i also see another game that we'll have
to go back to i see in the
bottom right corner second from the
right neil scuandelius has captured upon
on age seven
we need to look at that like let's take
a look at that right now because that's
very concrete let's figure out what's
going on there
and then perhaps we can swing to the
magnesium after that so nine scandals we
left this one off just a few moves ago
when sergey karyakin played b5 yeah and
i thought that you had shown us none of
these bonds could be taken yeah i just
assumed well bishop f7 is easily
repeated knight takes h7 and i just kind
of assumed that tonight's gonna get
trapped bishop takes h4 the knight is no
way out
but what niels is saying okay he goes g3
he goes f4 and he is creating an
evacuation point for his knight on g5 he
also has 26 minutes by the way now 26
yeah what happens after f6
that eval bar swinging back and forth
such a complicated end game here i guess
white plays bishop g6
and buries black's king
and it's an amazing situation neither
side can really untangle here
although
i suppose sergey can go rook b8 and then
try to go rook b6 rookie 6 but
this is quite risky for black as well
white's got a lot of activity here
and this night i guess can both be a
blessing and a curse it stops the king
from escaping but it's also trapped so
i really don't know what to make of what
to make of this i think that nils is
largely going for this intuitively
there's he simply doesn't have the time
to calculate it out fully he trusts that
the activity of his pieces
is going to give him enough to at least
make a draw
yeah it's such a weird position playing
basically a piece down but that piece is
restricting the enemy king um
i would be surprised if if sergey
doesn't go for f6 if i were black i
would say okay well i'll
entomb that knight on h7 and we'll see
what happens rather than wanting to find
out or letting the knight get out via g5
if not f6 are there any other tempting
uh options i guess if we play c4 and try
and hit the bishop we can never get that
bishop away from the defense of the of
the knight
but i still think c4 is a viable
candidate move and the reason why is
that now at least the e-file is closed
down and what sergey might say is okay
i'm going to let you get your knife back
then i'm going to take it
and then i'm gonna pin your bishop with
rookie eight and this is probably closer
to a draw than to anything else
but perhaps these pawns are a matter of
concern for white
and this just seems to be a less risky
option for sergey
but this is always such a hard judgment
call to make f6 is without question the
principled move right if you
probably the best winning attempt but it
also is associated with a certain risk
of losing the game and weighing that
balance i mean that really depends
that's where you look at the tournament
standing tons of variables factor into
that equation not just the position on
the board
yeah and uh sergey well as you mentioned
he has plenty of time on the clock 50
minutes more than oh yeah niels
guendelius so
i think this is a moment uh we talked a
little bit about identifying what
critical moments are in a game and i
think that is such a moment and sergey
will probably take a fair amount of time
here
absolutely and let's quickly swing back
to our bird's eye view
and perhaps switch over to the magnus
game just quickly scanning for any
other quick developments yeah definitely
the fabi uh duda game is also very
interesting but i want to start with the
magnus game because prague
fiona did not go to knight g5
rather he's gone for a4 which we did
also mention
a4 was also tempting i have to admit i'm
a little bit disappointed with it i am
i'm no i'm definitely disappointed
94 you had convinced me dania with all
these especially that one crazy line
with the rook sacking it with all the
sacrifices to
eventually well either win the queen or
the liver check mate on h7 i like that a
lot
after a4
i guess the the game is taking a
slightly more uh positional turn
i'm going to be completely honest here
i'm shocked that prague didn't go knight
g5 and i understand that you know i'm
not the one facing magnus over the board
i'm the one who sits here with the
engine and
you know claims that everything is easy
but this isn't about you know nigeria
five being the top engine move i just
feel like it creates such tremendous
attacking potential
uh that it's it's worth going for it
even if you you can't work out all of
the details
but of course you're playing magnus yeah
i was just gonna ask do you think the
fact that the opponent was magnus
carlsen had a role to play in the
decision
i think it it has a role to play
subconsciously i don't think prague is
sitting there saying i want to play
knight g5 and check made him but because
it's magnus carlsen he must have seen it
so i'm not going to go to h5 and
checkmate him that's not literally what
he's thinking but that's you know the
insidious thing about playing
magnus it's just that you're
it's always in the back of your head
that he probably sees more than you do
uh and and so perhaps subconsciously
you're
rejecting moves that you would otherwise
play automatically now
specifically here
b4 is the first move that comes to mind
right just pushing the pawn forward
and if white goes knight e4
then one possible continuation here is
knight takes d5
rook takes d5 and bishop b7
fianchettoing and attacking the rook and
this could still be incredibly tactical
make no mistake
the only issue fiona is that after a
move like g6 this pawn on b4 is actually
a tremendous strength because it
prevents the white queen from lifting up
to c3 and building a battery and without
that just not sure how white's going to
get to black's king but i mean playing a
move like g6 and i see that var agrees
with you
to my human eye it looks so incredibly
scary there is a bishop on v2 and you
just open that diagonal
but it looks like everything is under
control
i mean i'm sure that this position is so
much better for black
and but there's also a concrete reason
after the rook goes back to h3 and i
have the benefit of the engine here
black has this move c4
and it's a very weird line that doesn't
seem like anything impressive so b takes
c4 okay and now all of a sudden bishop
takes e4 looks very counterintuitive why
would you give up the strong mission
i think there's two things to remember
here the first is that this rook on h3
yes it's a good attacking piece but it's
also out of the game
and when black opens up the center white
really misses the stroke white wishes it
would have been on d1 the second thing
is that this pawn on b4 is a
tremendously strong passer
virtually any end game is going to be
good for black and the third thing to
remember is that black just has very
active squares for his pieces the bishop
can come out to f6 the knight to c5
and in the absence of concrete tactical
ideas
uh white's attack starts to evaporate
and black takes over the initiative so
it just seems to me that magnus is a
little bit puzzled by the movie for i
think he's gonna go b4 and i think he's
grabbing that bishop after that i wonder
danya if i just saw a little smile there
on magnus's face
he has a weird facial expression like
partly surprised partly happy to see a4
what are you reading into
into that
magnus phase it's
it's so hard to tell he can go through
six or seven emotions in the span of
three seconds and he leans back and then
he leans forward again
and then you know and and him sitting
back doesn't necessarily mean that he's
relaxed sometimes he does that when he's
disappointed in himself or in his
position
i feel like he's relieved i i what i
would if i had to quantify this in one
word i would say he's relieved
and i can bet you a you know a silver
dollar that in the press conference he's
going to admit to being scared of knight
g5
yeah i i i agree rudy i think magnus
definitely he still doesn't look super
thrilled with his position no he's not
like he's more quicker than he was a
minute ago
but still i mean okay knight g4 wasn't
played
but
white of course not worse here by any
means but i think
this missing knight g5 and i think
that's what you were saying like um
it's one of those moments
they don't come around too often
especially not when you play magnus so
you have to absolutely grab them when
you get the chance and again the
disclaimer easier said than done for us
sitting here in the comfort of our warm
homes and studios indeed
and this would be a very interesting
position to investigate with an engine
at a very high depth that's definitely
something i'll be doing
afterward and many analysts will be
doing that but my intuition tells me
that if anything uh at a higher depth
this is just going to end up being
better and better for white so
again i'm not trying to to suggest that
the game is over or anything like that
magnus is still walking on hot coals
here
but
if he goes before if he takes that
bishop uh it does seem to me like he's
on the road to recovery yeah and well
we'll come back to we'll come back to
this one as magnus continues to to
ponder the position
um what was the other one that we wanted
to come back to oh the duda against
carrana that is uh coming to life let's
go back there
let's indeed okay
so we we last saw the position after
queen d6
and i mentioned the idea of taking on c5
and swinging the queen to h4
due to going for queen a4 immediately
and fabby says okay you're not going to
take on c5 i'm going to take on d4 and
i'm going to block the queen's pathway
to h4 on the other hand you know white
gets a very nice little pawn chain here
in the center so i still think white's
in good shape here fabi develops and
duda repositioning his knight knight f1
getting this knight more centralized
knight e3 bishop d7 throwing in h6 check
pushing the king back and this is the
position on the board no question in my
mind fiona that white is better the
question really is what is the extent of
white's advantage because blacks have a
lot of weaknesses the king
the pawn black's position is just flimsy
and i would like to ask you to rewind a
couple of moves because i'm i was
curious about fabi's decision
to to go g5 so i was wondering if we
could stop here for a second uh why did
he go decide to go g5 um is that leaving
two too many holes i think a very
committal decision
it is definitely committal it it creates
a hole on f5 it creates you know hole on
g7 and it is possible that fabi was just
fed up with with this cat mouse game
constantly having to worry about h takes
g6 and yes
the queen cannot swing to h4 anytime
soon but that doesn't mean h takes g6
isn't going to be an issue so perhaps
fabi said look i'm going to create a
couple weaknesses but at least i'm never
going to have to worry about you know i
don't have to worry about getting mated
in in the near future so
it's it's a logical decision it's a
risky decision
and
john stepping away from the
x-ray going queen b3 we're probably
going to see e6 there it is has just
appeared
and i guess well one question i have we
were talking about the king earlier is
it now finally time for the king to
castle queenside or
and i
answered my question and he answered it
with a resounding no rook d1 meaning
that that king is not gonna go queenside
any longer
and i think a great example of where you
know the engine and human minds diverge
the engine says that after castle's long
this is the best move and white is
clearly better look when i look at
white's king i am far from comforted
even a move like b5
i mean guess what black is going to play
before the engine says yeah take the
spawn no big deal well again for a human
you look at this position this is a big
deal queen a4
a6 and white's just supposed to bishop
take on c6 and drop the queen back to c2
it's so much harder to make these
assessments again when you're not
sitting in a warm cabinet staring at the
email bar so john deciding on rook d1
and fabi has a very interesting
possibility of pushing that f-pawn
forward and trying to play for the
initiative himself this is
i still think white's in good shape but
it's also very double-edged position
yeah for sure uh what do we make of that
white pawn which is now made all the way
to to h6 and the black king on h8 is
that king safe one thing i'm wondering
about the white knight can we somehow
re-route that to somewhere where it's
going to to create a bit more threat so
or what are the the plans for both sides
yeah i mean he's just rerouted it from
d2 to e3 and i agree i think he fabi has
done this nice thing he's dropped the
bishop back and gone e6 and his
uh rob you know some dude named robert
hess likes to point out whenever the
pawn and the knight are on the same file
and there's two squares between them
then the pawn completely limits the
knight the knights forward mobility i
mean look at this all of these squares
are taken
g4 is neither here nor there it can be
punished with f5
so i agree this knight is
it's a little bit awkward and i feel
like fabi especially given that he lost
yesterday and he has an aggressive
mindset
i think we could expect f5
yeah i i'm with you because i
this is one of these positions where a
few moves ago i felt i really like white
and suddenly a couple moves oh same i've
been playing and i'm i'm not sure
i still like the look of
white's position
uh but i'm not exactly sure where should
my pieces go what's my next plan
while for black it seems like the king
for now is quite safe on h8 the white
king we haven't talked about that but
still stuck in the center and yeah i
feel the tide could be turning here
and and that's part of the reason i like
f5 the thing is that if white castles
king side that's not out of the question
but uh it may be out of the question
here because black goes rook f6 and
picks up the pawn so it's important for
white to keep that rook on h1 to
supervise h6 but yeah that means the
king is stuck in the center it can't
kill queenside now
uh and i agree with you it just seems
like yon's pieces have
they were looking really really nice
just a couple moves ago but
uh he hasn't made a lot out of the
position maybe white should go c4 here
and try to open up the center push d5
i mean this leads to tremendous
complications and i think we can
definitely expect time pressure in this
game as well
yeah for sure i mean we're uh only on
move 19 here so for now
still enough time for the players but
that is a position where you tend to
invest a lot of time so we will leave
fabiano to it i hope to see f5 i think
this one shaping up i think a lot of
games started a little bit slowly today
but uh shaping up for some big action
towards the first time control
absolutely i mean even the event forest
video game which started as a
very trash nimzo indian lion has
sharpened up and
you know jordan with with great great a
great position here and certainly far
from
symmetrical really every single game
fiona
uh is is full of complications we've got
tactical positions uh we've got
complex positional battles we have a
really interesting end game even the
karjakin game has sharpened up so i'm
loving it we've also got world champion
magnus carlsen who has played h6 and
saying you've had your chance had to
play knight g5 now it's too late and
well the one game maybe we can go back
there one more time i will go off on a
short break after that but there's the
game between uh rapport
and ma media where i think we're going
down one of the lines that we were
looking at earlier
we're going down the main line that we
were considering indeed as reheart going
queen f6
forcing black to castle and going h4 and
i can guarantee you uh he was elated
when he calculated this b4 h5 line just
to re reiterate b4 h5
and the move b takes c3 loses the game
amazingly black can stay alive with the
move h6
this looks crazy looks h takes g6 and
it's mate but black strikes back just in
time b takes c3
and after g takes f7 check the line
becomes very forced rick takes f7 white
has to give this check
rook g7 and amazingly after queen takes
e6 for cap7 according to the engine
white has nothing better than
perpetual and i mean that makes sense
because look at white's king i mean if
you make a single move that's not a
check uh at this point you're busted so
i
feel like it's crazy
but seeing h6 or just playing this move
and allowing h takes g6 requires not
only nerves of steel but tremendous
calculation you also have to reckon with
moves like c4
which kind of lock up the queen side in
preparation for hg6 the last thing i'll
say here is that chakra r doesn't have
to go before
and the other candidate move here is h5
but as we already discussed ah but here
bishop takes g6 might actually be
winning for light unlike in that other
line let's so let's figure out what's
the difference between this line and the
previous line where it didn't work
so in the previous line black's queen
was on um i think it was on either e5 it
was a slightly different version but the
upshot is that white didn't have the
move rook d7 and hero white has rookies
for one reason or another there there
wasn't this move because we were looking
at h3 instead
right and probably rook h3 is also
winning in this position but rook d7
wins on the spot just because it
it's just checkmate
uh so i guess h5 is is not an option but
that needs to be calculated as well
this is still a lot scarier for black
than for white
but
if shock finds b4 or the other option is
to go rook fe-8
h5 and then dial the queen back to e7
and dislodge white's queen from f6 both
of these options according to the engine
yield
reasonable position for black yeah
plenty to calculate here i think shah
will try and make b4 work i think if he
can calculate this into a line where
uh he can find a perpetual or where
white has nothing better than a
perpetual i think shakira will be happy
here with the draw
for sure
but yeah both kings still
far from safe and we will find out what
happens here and in all the other
remaining games in just a few minutes
plenty of action to look forward to so
we'll see you shortly
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i think the first time
i heard about the tournament here was um
probably sometime in 1999 uh but the
first tournament that i actually
followed was the one in in 2000
so i would say that's my like first firm
memory of the tournament here
probably my best memory from the village
here uh
was the year that i i won and
people of baikon say song sang a nice
little song for for me i i really
appreciated that
i think there are people in
my team who are better than me at
working with
with engines so i would say
i'm not so
good at finding ideas with it so i
generally prefer thinking on my own
solving chess is way way out there and
frankly i hope that it won't be in a
very very long time
my goal for this tournament
is to have 13 days of good preparation
and
[Music]
a good mindset when coming to the board
hopefully i'll i can get back to to my
best after a couple of
let's say frustrating performances the
last couple of years
[Music]
back to our coverage of round seven of
the tata steel chess tournament
and dania well magnus's
magnus's name tag is about to fall off
hopefully he will do a better job of
holding on here today
it's giving me massive ocd i need to
stop looking at that let me look at the
board instead
and especially because prague has just
made a move now
magnus did not go before but he made
another move that we had been discussing
at length which is h6 and perhaps prague
started regretting not going knight g5
h6 means that magnus was afraid of it he
doesn't even have to admit it in the
press conference
he admitted it over the board he just
played h6 and fiona i was over the break
i was thinking of this insane idea of
going queen g6 in this position
uh and it's actually not entirely
terrible the point is that if black
plays knight takes d5 there's an amazing
move here queen takes you
and then knight takes d5 and you reclaim
the queen and you'll be up upon
but
but magnus would certainly not have
fallen for that and black has this nasty
move knight don't look at the screen
right now by the way dania
oh look at that oh no
all right big what are you doing
oh man twisting the knife and i see how
it is i see how they treat how they how
you treat commentators
a warm welcome on your first day
get it out of my face get it out of my
face
i can't i cannot take this
i need to like
now i'm looking at my desk and i'm
detecting imperfections
i need a stack of paper to like
stack right now or something like that
but magnus he's sitting nice and upright
and sorry i interrupted you so after
queen g6
um
not taking the bishop on d5 but instead
knight e5 here just suggesting
and the point is after takes takes now
black is threatening to take on d5 and
even though the queen is being x-rayed
it's also doing some x-raying of its own
and the computer was indicating a crazy
line rook a7 now rook b7 again remember
the bishop can never leave this diagonal
so the move makes sense
and there's some sort of a liquidation
the position remains approximately equal
i think that that was just a very
interesting option uh that pr probably
did explore
but ultimately settling on the move
queen e2 hitting
the b5 pawn this of course also makes
sense and magnus he could defend that by
going queen b6
uh and of course he can still
contemplate the move before
um dania tell me do i have to give up
any hopes of a kingside attack or could
there still
be something on the horizon i hate to be
the bearer of bad tidings i i think
there's one possibility
of this game sharp there's one pathway
through which this game could still
sharp enough and that is if white starts
pushing his e pawn so for instance if
magnus goes queen b6 there's this move
e4
and even though the king side itself
might not might not open up the center
might open up i mean if white goes e5
and e6 uh we might have a zoo on the
board pretty quickly here as well and
make no mistake i still think that
practically speaking white's position is
more fun to play i just think that this
is incomparably safer for black
than
you know i don't mean to sound like a
broken record but you know then if white
had got knight g5
and man
maybe we can just very quickly go back
to that moment for people who might have
joined us just to put knight g5 on the
board there was this moment here after
queen c7 where daniel was really hoping
the move knight g5 would be played he
had convinced me as well
but prague not taking that opportunity
there was some crazy potential lines
here um i don't know if you want to show
some of them again or if we should move
on but
yeah i mean
i can show another line if black has
gone h6 here i was looking at this over
the break then here white has a similar
deflection tactic bishop takes f7 and
now why give away this bishop not to
take the rook here but in order to clear
away the d5 square for the knight
and after i mean if you take on d5 you
get checkmated queen h7 and queen h8 and
if you don't take on d5
then white is going to take on f6 as
many times as it takes to clear away the
h7 square for the queen bishop takes f6
then you play knight takes f6 black has
to take with the pawn
but now white transitions to a direct
attack on the king knight takes f7 queen
h7 and
you don't really need to calculate just
to see how nasty this position is white
wins the pawn on h6 the attack rages on
and this was a golden opportunity for
prague
so
he might still win this game i mean all
three
results are possible but if he doesn't
then you know he's going to regret this
moment no question yeah i think this is
a moment he will be coming back to uh
even when going over the game afterwards
knight g5 wasn't played and on the very
next move magnus shot the the
opportunity down by playing h6 himself
so queenie two
this could still sharpen up as daniel
just said but for now um
things look pretty much in the balance
and magnus probably breathing a sigh of
relief
meanwhile what's happening elsewhere
um it's been a while since we checked
the event forest game but before we do
that uh just notice the position in a
report mahmoud yar of shock going before
and in this position he has to find the
move h6 that is absolutely crucial and
if he does the game is very likely to
end in that perpetual which we showed
but if he takes on c3 then he loses the
game i don't think he's gonna do that
yeah so this game well one way or
another very likely to be over soon
either black finds the correct femur a
few moves that lead into a perpetual
or he doesn't and gets checkmated but
just as you say that h6 appears on the
board
indeed and we also have quite a few
developments in nessupenko shanklin a
couple of moves have been played
fabi has also gone for f5 and sergey has
taken up the gauntlet and gone f6 so
everybody seems to be going for the most
principled options
but uh fiona unless you prefer another
game we can have a brief look at uh the
state of van forest vinit absolutely
let's start there
okay so a lot has happened first again
an update on vivid's clock he's got
30
after 19 moves that is just insane time
pressure he's got he basically has to
spend less than a minute per move
yeah i mean for me this is always
for me this is always the critical
moment when my time drops under
when the amount of minutes drops under
the amount of moves i have to make
that's when the
the panic starts kicking in in my case
and here also we're still so far away
dania from the the first time control
we're only on move 19
yes but having said that i'm not
entirely a fan of
how
jordan has handled this position i i
thought that knight d3 was the most
natural playing with him he went for a
knight c4 i mean he's still threatening
bishop d6 but vintage shuts it down with
a very savvy move bishop a6 now it might
seem like a blunder wait a second bishop
d6 but no white has black has rook takes
c4 it's not hard to establish that black
is going to get two pieces for the rook
uh and a significant material advantage
so
that doesn't work maybe jordan
overlooked this detail
but he was forced to support his knight
with b3 that tempo gave black time to
finish his development and now lock in
the bishop with the move e5 and this is
what we have on the board still look
look at black stroke it's very flimsy it
could get trapped but the move b4 is not
possible at the moment and if vidic can
consolidate
i think objectively speaking he should
be fine and the last thing i'll say here
is that he has the possibility of going
knight to a5
uh and trying to force a mass trade of
pieces so castle's knight a5
knight takes a5
and now after bishop takes c2 a lot of
white's initiative has evaporated
because he's just left with this bad
bishop
yeah that's definitely something jordan
will want to avoid if he can i like that
you just made the move castles because i
was gonna ask you
um it's been 19 moves usually we tell
people try and get castle as soon as
possible jordan he's been delaying it uh
for a bit can he get away with staying
in the center any longer or is castling
called for now
well there was an idea that got my eye
this bishop on a6 is undefended so
knight takes e5 has to be considered
unfortunately it fails and it fails
because white's king is so weak so
bishop takes c2 knight takes c6 and the
problem is not that black somehow keeps
the extra piece the problem is this very
cold-blooded move queen e4 now what is
black doing well you can't take the
bishop with the king because you get
forked uh and if you take with the queen
you run into queen take [ __ ] too
and quite simply white is under a
tremendous attack of queen f1 then the
queen just drops back to e4
and if you try to keep the extra piece
black continues to pile on with rook c8
and these threats against white's king
are totally unstoppable here just look
at that
assembly of black pieces on in the
center white's queen can't move away so
this tactic is unthinkable jordan is not
going to do that
with that in mind fiona i feel like
i feel like he has to bite the bullet
and it's sad to castle yeah
we actually we saw you and then we see
the close-up there uh on his face jordan
not looking too happy just a second ago
he was a little bit huffing and puffing
uh and i think the
uh the state of not being super
satisfied all comes down to that piece
you've been highlighting the bishop on
g3 and that's not the piece you want to
find yourself left with if a mass
exchange happens on the on the queen
side
certainly not and i think he he has just
gotten wind of this move knight a5 which
you know essentially forces the trade of
at least one pair of miners and if you
can trade both miners then we're going
to be talking about an advantage for
black so
not what jordan was looking for forward
to when vinit played f6 it looked like
white is on the cusp of overtaking a big
advantage and
all of a sudden now it looks like fitted
is fine the time situation
perhaps is the greatest concern in
jordan he's not make a move not ready to
castle just yet rook do you want he's
gone
that makes i was going to mention this
move as well i mean this does make sense
uh of course it puts pressure on the
knight on d5 so it is a development move
and i still think vidit should seriously
contemplate knight a5 in fact i think he
has to do it i think he has to get rid
of this knight on c4 as quickly as
possible maybe you can play queen e6
here and support the knight
but if knight a5 works out then
what black will also want to do here is
get a simplified position because
you know he's got 17 minutes and with
all of these pieces on the board
it's incredibly hard to handle this
without making a mistake
and well
with it he's going to have to speed up
he will be looking to exchange some of
the pieces
to simplify the position we'll come back
here let's bring back the bird's eye
view one more time
and
well we talked about oh and look at the
the karjakin game we don't see that so
often the other day robert and i had a
very interesting pawn structure with two
isolated double ponds but now i think
this is what is referred to as the the
irish pond center and maybe
we can quickly update uh grand delias
against um
against sega karjakin
we got ourselves some irish funds let's
have a look at that game
and the way that it was reached first of
all sergey indeed taking up the gauntlet
going f6 preventing the knight from
escaping and niels obliging with bishop
g6 sergey going c6 just sort of i think
he's ultimately preparing to move his
bishop away and then activate his rook
neil's going c4 just trying to freeze
things sergey saying i'm taking that
pawn and now neil's freezing all three
pawns with a move c3
now the key question go ahead i just
have to ask you because well i think my
eye like so many of our viewers
goes to the bar when it drops when a
move appears and the bar drops so what
is there not to like about about
c3
i think there's a very concrete reason
which is that black can in fact go
bishop c7 and get his rook
uh opened up and
to an untrained eye it might seem like
rookie seven should win a piece but it
not only doesn't win a piece
white's pieces are kind of suspended
uh in this weird way and they're all
kind of hanging and i think sergey is
going to make this move let's see what
he just played yeah he has played bishop
c7 and on the next move black is already
prepared to play bishop d6 and chase the
rook away and if the rook ever lands on
f7
i mean take a look at this position
white's pieces are all trapped on the
king side and this cannot be sustained
they're not that easy to actually win
but bishop e8 becomes a threat bishop b6
potentially
with 11 minutes on the clock
10 minutes on the clock fiona for 18
moves or whatever this is
i just don't see neil surviving this
yeah and uh well niels he's had a rough
start to the event and things here is
certainly nothing not looking good 10
minutes on the clock is a huge problem
we're only on move at 23 so
17 moves to be made but also the
position
on the board i mean
we were just highlighting some of the
problems and it's just really tough to
even to find a move for nils here if not
rook e7 then what else do you do
i mean the engine is suggesting a move a
neutral move like a4 that's an
impossible move to play and sergey has a
bunch of ways that he can improve his
position rook d8 and one way or another
eventually i feel like black is going to
have some way of getting to white's
pieces i just don't see that way right
now
but it's so hard in such a position just
to sit around and wait i feel like niels
is going to be
sucked into the temptation of going
rookie 7
and now he's below 10 minutes this is if
he can pull this one out i'll be very
very impressed yeah i was very impressed
with the way he saved the position
against magnus but i think today is an
even tougher
task because this position here first of
all it's not completely clear
can it even be saved even with best play
or is it already past that point if it
can be saved it can only be saved
by white finding the best moves at every
turn and with less than 10 minutes on
the clock that is very near mission
impossible
yeah i mean soon you're going to be
playing on increment and that is just
unthinkable
needs has just made a move
rookie three
so yeah he's making a neutral move he's
just sort of making a waiting live
seeing
how sergey is going to improve his
position sergey is probably going to
throw in rook d8 just because that move
doesn't hurt he might also push his a
pawn to a5 and the challenge for sergey
here is going to be okay how does he
actually
attack any one of white's pieces and
perhaps this is a fortress maybe there
is no way uh to make any progress but
sergey is going to spend a long time
looking for it
yeah for sure it's hard to
uh hard to believe that this could be a
fortress but who knows we will come back
here for now let's go back
to the overview
and well i see that
i mean in the overview this glendale is
karayakian game just looks so funny with
the four pawns on the sea fine
it's really nice
the white piece is stuck on the king's
side um and i swear maybe we can go back
to jesse panko against sam shankland
because i was thinking the same thing i
thought it was very likely we were
headed for one of those
uh repetitions or perpetrators but it
doesn't seem like it any longer
and i'm afraid sam fans are in for some
bad news he he seems to be losing
control of the game
um let's rewind a little bit and see how
it all came to fruition so f4
was played we saw this you said thank
you going queen to d1 just sort of
dropping the queen back uh potentially
preparing this idea that you mentioned
fiona h6 queen h5 maybe trying to get
that
uh to become a reality sam going d6 the
computer not a huge fan of this move yes
ibenko going f3 that was another reason
behind queenie one dislodging black's
queen from its ideal square sam obliging
yes panko bringing his queen back to d3
this is where things start to get
unpleasant right white's attacking two
pawns and we've already seen the
situation before
but sam has also played the move d6 and
that's quite weakening
okay so rook c7
rook e1
attacking the new weakness by the way
maybe we can just get ricky for
back one second because i was wondering
for a second why can't i go e5 and try
and trade the queens and then sorry when
the rook was still on c8 and then i
realized the book was undefended on c8
here it's also a different problem
here here yeah here the problem is
bishop takes e5 queen takes d3
and white just all you can eat
in the center bishop takes f4 and then
the next move he recovers the queen with
two extra pawns
uh sam might have missed this detail and
he it seems like his big mistake was
rookie seven
the the engine was proposing the similar
move bishop e7
intending e5 on the next move the
problem with rookie seven is indeed
ricky iv
and here's what sam
might have overlooked it looks like e5
forces the queen trade no it doesn't
white takes on a6
and if black takes on d4
check on c8 check on f4 and it is simply
checkmate white's going to grab the
bishop on the next move with me
and if e5 cannot be played fiona
why black's position starts to come
apart a little bit at the seams here and
for instance if you play queen b5
a white can take
and then white just drops the bishop and
look at all of black's pawns why it's
just going to collect all of them yeah i
mean out of the opening it was white's
pawn structure that i was at least more
more concerned for with those isolated
pawns on the edge h file on the file but
right now things have completely uh
turned around and yeah it looks like
maybe rookie 4 is what was missed with
it upon hanging
on h
on a6 but
sam suddenly finding himself in a in a
tough position here
as you said i mean if
e5 doesn't work
can we try and play a5
uh we can yeah that's a possibility but
i think that y can get away with taking
on f4 and e5 is not an option
because of this move queen f5 pinning
the queen creating the threat of queen
takes f8 and queen c8 at the same time
so black's king being the center that's
really what kills sam here because that
king is just i mean there's so many
squares around it that are weak and so
white is constantly
gaining the upper hand
in these various tactics where it looks
like black wins a piece but then there's
something related to black's king
and yeah well some uh
suddenly in a lot of trouble i didn't
see
this one somehow when when one of the
players plays so fast in the opening
he's so well prepared what tends to
happen is you just trust them you think
they've got this they're so confident
but uh sergey sepenko he
very right not to to be too impressed
and he just kept looking for the the
best move now we see that sam is also
catching up on the clock and well and
the posture the hands over he said he
was leaning back he was vibing
he was playing fast
uh now
you can see the you can just see the
exasperation you can you can see
uh the seasons changing uh right
in front of us here and fiona nothing is
more frustrating
than putting together this incredibly
impressive preparation having it appear
on the board
gaining a huge time advantage feeling
like a king
and then three moves
from then asking what the heck happened
why am i in trouble incredible who does
panko the guy is an absolute beast he is
such a beast he had a
breakout performance here last year
beating magnus carlsen finishing in
joint third and he is once again having
a a brilliant event he is also looking
so he always impresses me with his calm
demeanor and yeah for sam
as some trouble brewing here
yeah he is a zen master
and uh let's not overstate the case i
think sam
he has time
and according to the the engine the
lesser evil is in fact to play a5 and
then follow it up with the move bishop
h6
the issue is that white just dips back
to e4 now space banker will be up a pawn
and black's king is going to be
permanently weak so there's big trouble
it's not completely lost
and we'll definitely keep an eye on this
game as sam tries to
figure out a way to recover
i have some great news for you dania if
we go back to the bird's eye view or
before going back to the birthday
oh man is that a screenshot from earlier
it must be i feel like it's probably
escalated further
probably every couple of seconds it it
leans
further i was lied to i was told the
sign had been fixed
oh you were told it had been fixed but
it isn't fixed the sign is straight the
rest is just
straight now the sign isn't straight at
all i mean it's literally leaping onto
the board that the sign is straight
everything else we're being lied to
i've been lied to
danny i've been deceived i got a message
from bigfoot tell dania i fixed the sign
it's strange i don't know if i can work
with a liar
bigfoot is making an argument that this
sign is straight but i think we might
have to send him to the optician
i think that this is disgraceful i i
simply cannot commentate with say some
person who lies all the time and uh
okay i will
quit i mean we can literally see the the
glue the sticky part behind the sign if
the sign was straight we wouldn't be
seeing that it's straight
that's like one of those you know that's
like one of those illusions like which
where you say where you show two
different lines and one of them looks
bigger than the other but in fact
they're straight but in fact they're the
same size
now i understand it was all a joke with
the camera being tilted
just well
okay well
let's go back to the bird's eye view
will that be tilted as well maybe
bigfoot wants to tilt the boards a
little bit diagonally oh my goodness oh
now he's stranding me
okay so um
what else is catching our
attention here
uh let's see
first of all just have a look at van
forest's game if it did go knight a5
he's traded on c4 and
i think he's kind of back in the
driver's seat as jordan decided to take
back with the pawn
uh we see isapenko taking that pawn on
a6 so that proceeds
as we thought it would sergey planting
the bishop on e5 shutting down the rook
i'm kind of torn between taking a closer
look at the duda game
and looking at the rapport mamidyarov
game which
transitioned into an end game maybe
let's start with rapport my media
because i think we've i was kind of
expecting almost a result there uh but
not just yet but uh
we're sort of out of the the crazy
complications at least we're we're out
of the crazy complications and i think
the game is still very likely to end at
a trust so what essentially happened
is that in this position we were
contemplating hg6 this is the fourth
draw instead of this uh report goes c4 i
had mentioned this move briefly
um and i didn't really explore it this
leads to a queen trade queen g5
we have a trade rapport takes on g6 and
we still have mutual attacks right black
is still attacking white's king white is
still attacking black's king and things
are likely to fizzle out and end up in
some sort of symmetrical rook end game
so for instance
one move that occurred to me was rook h7
and for instance bishop takes c4 i guess
there could we could envision a trade
okay that's a check so the king has to
move
f takes g6 and technically black is up
upon here uh but this should be a draw
and notice that rook d7 is
probably inaccurate due to rook takes f2
and there's no mate
so in this position white should
probably go rook e7
and black will end up having to give up
one of his pawns because you can't
really go rook f6 here to do the back
rank check
but the engine gives g4
rook takes e6 can you king g7 and
white's advantage is merely symbolic
black's pieces are active enough
the rook ties down white's rook to f2
i'm anticipating a draw in the next half
hour yeah it looks like shahid mahmoud
has done a great job
defending a slightly tricky position so
that's one of our three
leaders with the black pieces who seems
to be more or less out of trouble
what about the other two you talked
about the jordan against visit game
shall we go there next
absolutely let's have a look at the the
transformations in that game
okay so uh vid it to his credit quickly
going knight a5 and and trusting his
intuition there jordan castling knight
takes c4 and b takes before the point of
course is that you can't take on c4
again because the knight on d5 is going
to hang
after knight c7 jordan deciding to
defend the pawn on c4 and the reason
that the engine was not a very big fan
of the of this move is that black can
now go 96.
now why is that good well the reason
that's good is because
black is now discouraging white from
breaking open the position with f4 the
only way to jailbreak this bishop really
is to go f4 and now this move is a lot
less appealing with that knight sitting
on e6 jordan probably should have gone
f4 on the previous move
and black can't really take on c4 here
because the e5 pawn is going to hang at
the end of the line i think this was
jordan's last chance to get a a pleasant
position
after 96 i think if anybody's better
it's probably black yeah i mean somehow
this uh has developed
uh in a in a way that's not going to be
to jordan's liking we talked for a while
already about that bishop on g3 that
isn't uh really doing much as that it
prepares to make a move
but also the
the
the pawn on c4 not 96 interestingly
he has put a piece on e6 it's the queen
though i mean it makes sense he's
attacking c4
it does make sense i'm just always
concerned about f4 i'm still concerned
about f4
because what could happen here is okay
bishop c4 we might actually see this
bishop takes before queen takes c4 oh
this is maybe what vinit is going for an
end game that's
most likely going to be equal takes
takes takes takes
and black has to be careful here because
if you automatically take
white's rook is going to get to d7 and
white's got a lot of activity here so if
i'm jordan
i would consider just going f4 quickly
and you know using vidiq's time against
him
and well is your then even we're not
sure is he even at the board at the
moment he's not at the board yet
i think would he might be happy to see a
bit like magnus was happy to to see
knight g4 not appear on the board i
think in the same way uh jordan might be
happy to not appear as the knight e6 up
here and given
uh another opportunity and i i agree
with you i think he just has to do uh to
try and open up the position here to try
and bring that bishop back to life
you don't want to go rook c1 here going
to full pacific just one thing i wanted
to explain for the sake of completeness
how does 96 discourage f4 well the point
is that after e takes f4 you can't
really take with the bishop because then
white black takes and if you take with a
pawn then there's a simple tactic knight
takes f4 and then the bishop only two
hangs and the z4 pawn is going to hang
so white ends up dropping a bunch of
pawns here so
um i think queen e6 is not a mistake i
think it's
reasonable and
we are
quite likely to see that it's quite
likely going to be some sort of a
liquidation here if jordan plays f4
absolutely well we'll we'll see i think
a big moment here uh jordan is surely
going to invest wait
i4 is already on the board that sounds
so fast i didn't even see it i was like
he's gonna spend some time here
no
but that i think that's what i think he
just senses that if he doesn't play it
now he's going to be passive for the
rest of the game so there isn't he he
had to calculate the only thing he has
to calculate is bishop takes c4
he saw that that works out for him so
he's not really risking here
okay so well we'll see here if we get
the liquidation and maybe let's bring up
the bird's eye view pick one last game
and then we're going to go on a quick
break
so let's see
um
let's have a look at the grendelius game
maybe sure and then after the break
we'll take a look at the dude i think
the dude game requires uh we we have to
spend a good more time because it's so
complex so let's
you know in the interest of time let's
update everybody on
kneels against karjakin because it looks
like niels is actually
not doing badly at all
that is
incredible last time we we came from
this position we thought that sergey was
firmly in control so let's rewind a few
moves so what happened here so there was
the
the move c4
okay so neil's going rookie three
sergey going rook d and apparently that
was a mistake neil's pouncing on it with
f5 and that was the idea of rookie three
nils defending the pawn on g3 in order
to be able to go f5 and he managed to
anchor that bishop to g6 look at that
construction that construction is going
to survive a nuclear apocalypse
and i mean it's very solid uh
it's very solid dania but the question
is how can white possibly play with
without two pieces basically
and but basically yeah it's it's weird
but because the position is so closed
down and these pieces are actually
controlling a lot of squares i mean the
knight's controlling f8 so black is
playing without his king black is also
playing without his light squad bishop
which is now locked behind white's pawns
and the move bishop h3 it appears was
necessary to preserve winning chances or
to preserve an objective advantage of
course he still has many chances the
reason why is that if white plays f5 now
the bishop has made its way out of the
pawn chain
and it can ultimately park itself on d5
which is huge because if we compare this
to the position that's currently on the
board look at that bishop on c8 wouldn't
it just be dying to be on f3 in this
position that would be the key to the
kingdom now it's permanently stuck
and suddenly this uh these irish pawns
on the sea file
they are
blocking in their own bishop
unfortunately and it's hard to see
indeed how could sergey activate
the bishop here which just had another
move and needs playing a4
yeah and it's very important to indicate
that he should not take the pawn on c4
is working in his interest if he takes
it he allows the black bishop
to activate itself via a6 and d3 so
it's very important for niels to keep
that pawn
and maybe he just has a fortress here
maybe sergey has
no way to make progress he certainly can
move the dark squid bishop i don't see
where to put the light skirt bishop
maybe he can try work d3
so there's still some game left but if
niels is careful he should be able to
hold this one thing that means we're
certainly gonna have to be careful as
his uh clock management he's under five
minutes so sergey will definitely try to
apply maximum pressure especially now
during the next 10 moves because the
position very much feels like if niels
can survive up to the first time control
then with the extra time
it will become the task will become
easier so that will be the storyline
here
leading up to the the first time control
but dania we're going to take a very
quick break don't go anywhere the time
travel is looming and we'll be back in a
few minutes
bobby yeah robert
can you read devretsky's end game manual
to us one more time yeah now we got to
get up
[Applause]
[Laughter]
it was you like i was i was going to do
it without you
yeah yeah
he's different
um
you
ready what i said
i told you
let's do it all right
you know what they say though what
happens in salt lake
it stays in salt lake
exactly
cheers to my super gm friends it's been
good the world championship
on chess.com
let's do this
[Music]
chug the whole beer
yeah that was that was i was
yeah i'm great
round two
bobby
yes robert
can you read devoretsky's end game
manual to us one more time yeah
you guys have to go
[Laughter]
okay okay okay
i just actually didn't expect you to do
it that time because it's funnier like i
thought you was a one-time
yeah yeah please okay okay i'm just
trying to add live with what feels
natural yeah
of course it feels natural wait so we
should expect that next year
just so i'm mentally prepared yeah
okay
what is this
it's eggs
i want an omelet with brie just [ __ ]
eat it
you eat it
[Laughter]
i wasn't expecting that that wasn't
either it was sour
we could turn a little bit on the
shoulder there
um the uh
faster card and unibrow i just want to
thank my sponsors uh very much for all
they do to to promote chess
sounds like a great future credit card
faster card yeah wasn't it fast or hard
[Laughter]
no no
y'all are respecting the wood a little
too much
not fast or hard bobby oh boy i i can't
be with you two anymore
oh okay
i mean i think it's it's hilarious don't
you think people would would buy this i
don't think anyone's gonna buy that
hey that's the stupidest person in my
life
well okay
i guess that's it
all right that's it that was great keep
it rolling okay
same thing
i love that
yeah and we are danny
who is that guy who's that
he didn't come in with you guys
no
we're going to be right back
bobby yes robert
can you read deboretsky's end game
manual to us one more time yeah yeah
i'm sorry i just can't
[Music]
it's so funny
isn't it cool when i predict the moves
you're gonna say because we all see
things in the same way in the same speed
on this show
isn't that cool when we do that
it doesn't make me very happy
[Laughter]
and let's bring up the analysis board as
we do that so iphone can give us her
thoughts on the uh
on the pet shop go aheady fun
uh well yeah actually that's a very good
question because i was firstly trying to
yeah danny
my throat's still dry
you're like you've already you've had
five glasses of water okay you remember
what happened last time
my throat's still dry
you've already had five glasses of water
and you remember what happened last time
it was an accident you peed your bed
you're looking fresh man all six of them
again dude your haircut just looks great
wait did we start the bit yeah
you're not supposed to say
supposed to say that you start the bet
if black's a6 pawn was transported let's
say
good night guys
good night dad i've been fabi
[Laughter]
i said i said it should i not set it
i think it's funny if we both say good
night dad i mean bobby but we need to be
in sync
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to our coverage of round
seven here at the tata steel chess
tournament so as you can see we've had
our first result of the day the game
between anish and duboff was not played
daniel duboff still awaiting the result
of his pcr test
but we've had a draw between richard
report and shakira mamidyarov and dania
let's go and quickly see how that game
concluded before we come back to world
champion magnus carlson
indeed fiona and what a draw it it was a
very fighting game uh really from the
outset as as we had a pretty offbeat
sicilian line rihard jumping out onto
the initiative he was basically better
all game but shocker just told me to
interrupt you dania but did you see the
camera on magnus there like i don't know
what he did he must have touched
something he shouldn't touch her i don't
know what
yeah what happened i i was seeing it at
the corner of my eye yeah i i didn't
catch what exactly
he did something i don't know if he he
did he did the classic magnus i'm sorry
thing but did he knock something over
did he maybe touch another piece without
saying jadoo what's the what's the drama
here
but then prague would probably be sort
of trying to enforce it
yeah it's hard to i mean did he knock
something over as you say i don't know
um but he was very um
very apologetic
he wanted whatever it was it seems like
it's settled down now and we'll
definitely take a look at that that
position
uh and try to figure out what it could
have been yeah for now let's see how the
game ended and bigfoot is saying maybe
he wanted to adjust the name tag
oh yeah all that i mean but does he even
see that the name tag is up
no
maybe we'll get the yeah the var i see
the chat is screaming for the raw replay
i'm sure we'll we'll get some insights
at some point but for now let's see how
uh reparate against mum and dad have
concluded
yeah and what i was so impressed with
and you know it's no surprise that chuck
is leading the tournament because
he was in a lot of danger out of the
opening and and finding this b5 a5 idea
all this counter play i mean he played
that perfectly and the game ended
precisely how we kind of expected it so
after the queen trade things have
fizzled out bishop b3 i'm reheard going
for rook h5 which is one of several
possibilities bishop takes c4 forcing a
trait of bishops
and in this position the players agreed
to a draw why did they agree to draw
because after king g7 although black's
pawn structure is nominally worse it
cannot be successfully attacked i mean
white can pretend
to attack it but if anything this
actually backfires due to rook d8 check
and if white tries to do it from the
other side
uh then after rook takes f2 rook takes
c6 black has the simple move for cup six
and it's obviously a dead draw so a
totally justified draw agreement and a
great fighting game my madaravan report
let's go back to magnus and i'm reading
actually in the chat what has happened
is apparently magnus adjusted a piece
and then pressed the clock after
adjusting the piece oh my god without
making a move
so apparently that's what happened and i
i don't know if the moves count if the
clocks here count the moves i
i don't think they do because the time
only gets added after they run out of
time it doesn't automatically get added
so probably it doesn't matter too much
but hence all the the apologies um
because i don't know how they can
resolve the situation without both
magnus and
ram and prague getting an extra 30
seconds
but the thing is yeah first of all they
probably did and and second of all
what i don't understand is
yeah the time gets added when you hit
zero but you know how does the clock
distinguish between
you losing on time and you getting that
extra time it has to keep track of the
moves right
of the number of presses
yeah i thought it just puts a minus sign
but i i'm not i'm not exactly sure now
i'm being put on the spot here we will
try and get no i don't know either i
don't think anybody knows i just think
that
i just think that that's something to to
be careful about i mean the arbiters
have to keep an eye on that in case of a
time scramble for sure but very funny to
see
magnus i think it's so often that you
just have the instinct if you touch the
piece you want to press you press the
clock yeah you made a move right
you made a little made a little jadoo
boops
but uh yeah well let's let's uh update
the game for now we left this off a few
moves ago
well if magnus presses the clock here
without moving his queen then there's
going to be a bit of an issue
something tells me that he is going to
actually make a move and something else
tells me that it's going to be with the
queen i don't know how i know that
well uh
some divine intuition you must have
dania
indeed and what happened in the last
couple of moves prague so magnus went
queen b6 and prague did indeed go e4 as
we were discussing magnus going rook e8
x-raying the queen makes sense
probably stepping away from
uh from e2 which the computer didn't
like the the engine was proposing the
wild rook
a8 okay
that's not
not an easy move to play and magnus just
made a move we'll update you on that in
a second so queen d2
magnus dropping the bishop back to f8
stopping the pawn from hitting e5
activating his queen
there comes b4
and what's awkward about the queen
placement on f4 is black finally
eliminates the bishop on d5 and he does
so obviously by attacking the queen
forcing prague to recapture
and magnus repositioning the queen to e6
so
look if black can get bishop b7 white's
position starts to crumble fiona so i
actually think prague has to go knight
takes e5 here this is
really the only thing that he can do and
this leads to a mass liquidation so
bishop takes c5
rook takes c5 the point of course is
that the rook is going to hang but after
knight takes c5 queen takes b8 queen
takes b3 this is really scary and sorry
to interrupt you dania but we had a
result in nil scondelius against sergey
karjakin with nils in that indeed i mean
what a game that was what a save okay we
yeah well we'll definitely get to the
magnus game
in just a bit but let's uh just to
finish the thought i think magnus is
better i think magnus is better i think
i think uh prague is now in trouble
essentially
and that's exactly what happens we
talked about about it so many times
today you get an opportunity these
opportunities they are rare against
magnus if you don't grab them
instantly
then the tide turns very quickly and i
think that's exactly what's happening
here today let's go quickly see how the
game between niels and sergey concluded
and then we'll go back to the bird's eye
view
let's do it so we did we were discussing
that
perhaps sergey's critical mistake and
maybe in retrospect uh
he'll admit that he rushed this a little
bit
in at this moment neil's played this
mysterious looking rookie through why
did he play it he played it so that he
can go f5 shut down the light square
bishop and anchor his own bishop to g6
basically constructing a fortress sergei
it appears had to go bishop h3 and you
know this reminds me of those movie
scenes where
the character you know leaps at the gate
before right before it closes or the
garage right before it closes once the
garage closed black captioning not
available
[Music]
just moving his rook back and forth and
ultimately sergey acquiescing to
withdraw trading rooks and i mean this
is simply a fortress there's i mean this
is good
that's such a crazy final position
definitely it really is the most
intriguing fortress i have ever seen
what an interesting game and what is
saved by by neil scuandelius
that's a great it just shows you his
resilience and his
uh his verve you know he's in last place
he's got a nasty position low time
and uh kuda kudos to nils that's a big
result
and uh you know hopefully it sets sets a
good tone for the second half of the
tournament for him absolutely and dania
we were talking before the break we
needed some time to do a deep dive on
duda karana let's go back there and
see how that has changed
yeah i think now is the perfect time and
there's a lot of wow look at the time
situation 12 and a half for duda 18
minutes for fabby and they're only 23
moves into the game so this is going to
get
really exciting really fast now fabi
fiona did go f5
and duda did respond with the move c4
striking at him in the center
fabi moved his knight away from c6 to
open up the x-ray against the queen
due to move the queen up to c3 i think
the point is to discourage d take c4
because then there's going to be a
discovered check against the king baby
repositioning his knight preparing to
swing it to f4 and duda reinforcing the
pawn on c4
fabby dropping his queen back to e7 what
is the idea of this move i think he's
going to f6 i think what fabia's saying
is i'm going to put my queen on f6 i'm
going to put my knight on f4 i've got
all these improving moves if you play g3
then i'm going to strike at you with f4
and white's king is going to be caught
on the
crossfire i'm
quite concerned about white's position
here and again part of the reason for
that is that any time white castle short
the h6 pawn is going to end up a sitting
duck
yeah and 5v well after a tough loss
yesterday too and
geary will he be able to bounce back
immediately um duda has a tough question
to answer here as you just said he
doesn't want to to castle a
kingside
but then which of the pieces earlier we
talked about the knight on e3 um that
knight still
isn't doing
so much but
i can't think of a much better square
for it there's just no good squares
there's just no good squares in this box
g3 is not a move i expected
so
i guess the point is if fabby goes up
for immediately the knight does have a
good square on g4 but i would imagine
that fabi completes his maneuver with
queen f6 first
and f6 f4 is just always going to be
something that white has to reckon with
i don't like and the bishop can come out
to c6 and you know now that white's
played g3 he's also weak in the long
diagonal
whoops
and
no i think this is this is a very nasty
position
yeah and
well
fabiano
uh he could be bouncing back in style
here
it's still his move we expect the queen
to come to f6 and some big questions to
answer go do that let's quickly go back
to the birds iv because i see the chat
is going crazy i don't know if they are
justified in going crazy uh they want to
go back to your then and to yasipanko
what's happening there
rocket things okay so we'll
we promise we'll tackle all of the games
one at a time let's start with the
zepenko game because a lot has happened
there we also know that prague he did
not take on c5 he's he's gone for a
different move and yes it does appear
that magnus objectively speaking is
close to winning but we'll get to that
game in due time let's look at the
isapenko game what has happened here so
as we were discussing sam going e5
allowing queen takes a6
right in the point here is that you
cannot take the bishop due to queen c8
and what takes f4 sam moving the king
away is the dropping the bishop back sam
went for counter play in the center
pushing d5 but just look at how weak
plex king is don't be fooled by the
presence of what looks like an
impressive pawn phalanx in the center
that's not going anywhere you cannot
afford to push the pawns because of how
flimsy black's position is sam trying to
coordinate his pieces
but at cepenko very calmly
collecting everything and he's gone
queen b6
not a move approved up by the computer
according to the computer queen b5 was
the move hitting where it hurts
attacking the pawn on e5
this would have been a very difficult
pawn to defend but it's the pentagon
queen b6
and he's still in very good shape the
point is that if the rook moves away
from the seventh rank esapenko is going
to give this incredibly nasty check
fiona and look at how many directions
the queen can go to d5 h7 everything
seems to be hanging here
i wouldn't really trust the e-ball bar i
feel like sam's position is in in
critical shape yeah i mean this king is
just so naked with only the bishop to
help def help defend the queen on day on
d1 is completely on a different side of
the board and while the right rook on f2
is currently looking like it's quite
passive it is doing a very important job
of defending c2 and as soon as the black
king steps onto the g file then the rook
can join the game via g2 with a track so
although the bar has been swimming
swinging up and down a little bit don't
be fooled
this still looks like an overwhelming
advantage for um miyaza panko
and only four moves out of the time
control which is going to be very
welcome for andre in these types of
positions you often want a lot of time
to really work through all of the
candidate moves because there's usually
a lot of tempting possibilities
but that rook on f2 is a hero it's
defending c2 it's defending f3
you know it's not going to win any
beauty prizes for its placement but it's
doing yeoman's work just stopping all of
black's counter play andre does have to
be a little bit cautious about the move
d3
uh but the rook can always swing to d2
at the right moment and sam indeed
going for rook c3 and i'm fully
expecting queen b7 check here we'll keep
an eye
on this game yes panko looking france is
on the ceiling
okay so if i want to get windows 7
and now he's staring us down it's always
so intimidating though
it really is he's looking straight
straight into our soul that piercing
gaze i wouldn't say that sam is out of
the game here i think whenever you know
sam is active he's got this idea of d3
and andre has to give a series of very
accurate checks here so i wouldn't count
sam out here but objectively it's
definitely a dire situation
we'll come back to this one still very
exciting um let's quickly bring back the
overview a lot of people want to go back
to
the vivid game that has changed quite a
lot as well so let's uh briefly check in
with jordan van ferece and vidiq and
then we'll have to go back to magnus
because that bar has uh
come down all the way
indeed now jordan has done a very good
job of navigating a treacherous
situation after
uh squandering that uh early opening
advantage so he's got f4 and vidi didn't
end up taking on c4 he took on f4
uh and this finally allowed jordan to
liberate that bishop and guess what even
though he's got these two weak pawns i'm
sure he was absolutely thrilled to have
his bishop back in the game
and that bishop immediately repositioned
to f2 where yeah it looks passive but at
least it's doing something it's
defending e3 and it can always move back
to g3 then he connected his rooks vidit
was forced to bring his bishop back to
c8 in order to guard the d7 square and
look at how jordan brings the bishop
back to g3 gets the rook up to d5 and
vinit kind of bit the bullet allowed the
pawn to get to d5 and now we have this
position on the board a trait on g3 is
possible but
why this is a game for two results fiona
this pawn on d5 it's it's a scary pawn
it's going up to d6 very soon
and it's working perfectly with that
bishop on g3
that's guarding the d6 square otherwise
black would have put a knight on d6 in
an instant
jordan has finally at least somewhat
solved the problem uh problem of that
bishop and as you say the d4 pawn the d5
pawn sorry
is getting dangerously close also time
is still an issue here forwarded only
eight and a half minutes on the clock
still nine moves to make
and it's a it's a tough spot on one hand
you attempted to take that bishop on g3
on the other hand that bishop is for now
that knight is for now nicely placed
on e4 if we don't capture on g3 what are
the other options for for black
uh the engine prefers the comb bishop d7
and it only gives a slight advantage why
now this move is is sensible right i
mean if you can't blockade the pawn on
d6 at least you can block it on d7 and
if white pushes the pawn
to d6 something like knight takes g3 now
bishop c4 can always be parried with the
ship e6
after h takes g3 rook c8 trying to get
this rook to an anchor point on c5 and
preventing white's rook from
infiltrating to c7 and if black is very
careful he should be able to hold this
position white doesn't have a clear way
to make inroads but man with seven and a
half
on the clock for almost 10 moves
this is a very difficult task provided
and i think he's probably regretting
taking on f4 rather than on c4 maybe he
thought that end game was unpleasant and
you can't really blame him but one way
or another jordan
is in very very good shape he might also
be regretting not bringing his knight to
e6 as you had shown to to stop uh f4 and
jordan as soon as he uh was given that
chance he played the liberating f4 push
and he's really handled uh this
situation he was under pressuring
very well and now he is the one pressing
we will come back here let's bring back
the bird's eye view one more time
and uh i think we're just gonna have to
go back to magnus carlsen we are
and on the subject of f4 i can guarantee
jordan was praying to
uh to all of the gods please don't play
you know we all have this experience
where we see a very nasty move by our
opponent in that case knight e6 and
you're just mouthing please don't play
96 please don't play 96. and when he
sees a different move on the board
there's this relief that comes with it
but
let's have a look at what's going on now
one thing i want to point out
so it does appear that in this position
prague's last chance to keep something
resembling a feasible position was
knight takes c5
uh but can you really blame him for not
going for this line because take a look
at the position that occurs at the end
of it bishop c5 and i was showing this
earlier let me show this again just look
at this position the bishop is hanging
the pawn on e4 is hanging white's queen
is under an x-ray
i mean evaluating this position as only
minus 0.4 which the computer gives with
the insane move h3 is not human this
looks losing for white because black is
an extra passer can you blame prague for
not wanting to get a pawn down position
especially when he had such a promising
position out of the opening so instead
he goes for rook a to d1 which is
logical
and magnus going rook a8 and this is the
problem with rook 81 black has a totally
devastating threat of pawn c4 look at
that knight on a4 it looks perfectly
safe that knight itself is safe what's
not safe is the pawn on b3 because that
pawn is isolated c4 comes with
tremendous effect
white is totally powerless to stop it
because if white plays knight t2 fiona
white suffers severs the connection
between the rooks and black is able to
go bishop b7 previously that was
impossible because the knight would hang
so white's position is totally coming
apart at the seams i would not call rook
81 a blunder i disagree with that
i agree with you of course and the
position already looked very tough it's
a
mistake
it's crazy how quickly once again it
turned around i was all excited at the
prospect of knight g5 which wasn't
played but then after that it felt like
only a few moves and suddenly the things
have turned around completely and magnus
carlton
here in vikenzi it's such a familiar
story sometimes he might have a slightly
slow start that's not the case this year
but he won yesterday and sometimes
magnus he just
he gets on a roll and he starts winning
one game after another after another
after another
i mean he makes it look easy he's
winning in 23 moves against prague but
that's completely deceptive because had
prague played knight g5 we might we
might have been writing a completely
different storyline today
but and you might say well magnus just
gets lucky well no it's all part of the
same package right and we were talking
about this earlier when you play magnus
subconsciously you know there's a
tremendous amount of work you have to do
just to avoid feeling nervous and a lot
of decisions are subconsciously
influenced by who you're playing so
that's just the reward that you reap
from being world champion kasparov had
the exact same influence mikhail tall
had the same influence people talked
about that and and we see that quite
clearly here and with more experience
prague is still very young you can see
the promise not everybody can get this
kind of position against magnus 15 moves
in so
there's a bright spot for prague but
he's going to be really really
disappointed barring a miracle here for
sure i mean he is in so much trouble we
see the close-up he's about to make a
move but c4
is looming um and someone is it magnus
himself maybe who has just closed off
the view um but yeah prague
he is gonna be that's not what he wanted
of course from his first game against
magnus but i think it's also that
experience that you need and it's one of
the things you you brought up uh i think
it's just so great for prague to be able
to play here to play magnus and then
when you come back the next time maybe
it's a little bit less intimidating
yeah it definitely is with every i mean
the greatest fear
lies in anticipation once you get
through the experience of playing him
uh you know once you have that under
your belt and i have yet to have that
experience but i have had
plenty of
faster games though
and i remember you know the the nerves
you know when i played kramnik you're
just sitting there and he comes to the
board and you're looking at him and this
is this is the legend you're playing the
legend so it's like at the same time
it's an amazing experience you're having
a blast
and yet you're inside you're just
shaking so for outgoing queen c1 here
uh which is a totally reasonable move he
does find a way to stop c4 the issue of
course is that he leaves the e4 pawn to
the wolves
and if he plays rook takes d7
see the issue with this position is
black just plays for kda
and look at this very carefully white
has this knight on a4 it's doing nothing
white's back rank is in massive trouble
black is threatening queenie 2 and rook
d1
and minor pieces when they're not
supported by a rook
are totally powerless to stop these
types of ideas so
it may seem okay for white but in fact
it's just totally lost and magnus has to
decide on this but i think he will i
think i would be shocked if magnus
didn't take on e4
he still has a little bit of time but
both players actually quite low on the
clock so i think we're gonna very
quickly go back to the overview we'll
come back here once magnus makes a move
for now
should we go back to fabiano where do
should we go back to jordan things are
happening everywhere
things are happening everywhere i mean
it looks like essepenko's on the road to
winning let's go to fabiano's game we've
given it a little bit less attention and
it's it's moved along much more slowly
but it's entering the time scramble
phase
um and because 546 for duda for 13 moves
that's crazy and 13 minutes for 13 moves
also crazy a little less crazy but it
looks like fabi is is crushing it here
and you can see that yawn with his last
move dropping the knight to c2 this
greatly increases the temptation at
least to me to just play f4
and white's position fiona i just think
it's falling apart i mean just look at
the pressure down the f file white's
pieces are totally discombobulated all
over the place no counter play and if
the f-file opens the game it might just
end why can't castle either way he's
burned both of those bridges a long time
ago i was just gonna talk about that
because there were so many days where
robert and i talked about games where it
it's like it's so hard to explain them
to
newer viewers people who are new to just
because very often uh in these top elite
games
the opening principles don't get
respected the players don't necessarily
i just developed their pieces control
the center and get their kings into
safety but this here might just be a
good example as to why
uh in most of the time it is preferable
to get the king castle
because that's white king uh could be
under in a lot of trouble very soon
indeed and i just want to go back
through the two moments where duda moved
both of his rooks
because what's important to uh
plays that f4 and that's just automatic
is that it's not like duda doesn't know
about opening principles right or or
middle game principles he knows that
castling is the safest option but as i
was explaining
the computer wanted him to castle long
but just look at how dangerous this
looks black is already poised to play b5
b4 and my guess is that he rejected this
because of something like b5 he was just
scared of the attack and the reason he
didn't castle short is because that
would have left the h6 pawn tremendously
weak so he decided
first to play rook d1 in order to
prepare c4
and then the other rook came out
in just a couple of moves queen c3 b3
g3 and then he played rook h5 trying his
best to whip up counter play against
black's weaknesses but to no avail that
rook alone is just not going to be
enough and fabi very calmly
repositioning his queen
then his knight and blasting through
with that four five minutes for duda he
is in dire straits here he's lost on the
board and on the clock very impressive
play by fabiano dania we're gonna go on
just a very very quick break we will be
back with all the action here as the
first uh time control is looming don't
go anywhere we'll be right back
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
jordan went for raised will he defend
his title
while he still has a very interesting
position on the board against david
gujarati those two players
are getting closer to the time control
but still five moves to make do we start
there magnus is pressing yes panko is
pressing but that looks like it's gonna
be an end game now where do we start
dania man there's so many interesting
games well magnus has taken on e4 vidid
is playing simply on increment i mean
he's got zero minutes and zero seconds
um and now he's got one minute he's made
two moves very quickly so let's check in
on his game and
yeah this is kind of what we expected so
jordan taking the opportunity to
preserve his bishop because bishop f4 he
provokes a weakness and then swings the
bishop to c7 where he can be anchored by
the pawn on d6
and it going king g7 solidifying his own
pawns
jordan swinging the rook to f1 queen e7
and then boom bishop h5 forcing the rook
out of ea and now the queen is going to
be the only piece that guards the knight
this is really dangerous vidit has five
more moves to make simply on increment
it's so easy to blunder in a position
like this the engine doesn't think that
he's in big trouble but man oh man is he
in trouble practically speaking
for sure and this is such a big test for
our co-leader vidit here um
it's not an easy i mean people at home
might think five moves that's not so
many but in this position
this position first of all where does
the work go
f8
i would say a f8 but he's probably
tempted by rook c8 to to attack the
bishop
so that's another example he's gone
rogue c8 and is that a decent move
well let's see if the engine i mean it
oh it loses d6
queen e6
and now
oh bishop f3 bishop f3 is devastating
and why is it devastating because the
knight has to move back or why does it
have to move back because the flag plays
bishop c6 white takes on e4 and then
goes d7 but if the knight moves back
bishop comes to d5 and black can resign
queen e5 is absolutely forced and after
the trade the rook swings into f7 rook
takes d7 and bishop e6 and the game is
over jordan van forest can win the game
on the spot if he finds the move d6
followed by bishop f3 2d5 that is not an
easy maneuver but guess what fiona his
time management has been amazing and i
think this is where it's going to come
in i mean i have to admit danya the
speed at which you were
running to all these winning lines my
brain was exploding here it's a good
thing we're off camera because my face
kept anchoring closer and closer to the
board like what what and you're against
jordan oh my goodness d6 is already on
the board queen e6
appearing instantly
but
and bishop f3 there it is look at that
he's a beast i mean he didn't even take
and and you know you might ask well why
is he rushing first of all it has a
minute but this is an easy line to
calculate once you see bishop f3 that's
it that's the hard part there are
different types of tactics some are easy
to see and hard to calculate some are
hard to see and easy to calculate this
is
the second type of tactic once you see
it it's all over vidit is going to play
knight c5 bishop d5 and he's going to
resign
i think at the end of that sequence i
think we're going to see rook takes d7
on the board and vidit will resign
and this is such a tough spot because
clearly didn't see this coming when
playing rook c8 and it all happened so
quickly now he only has 30 seconds on
the clock and only
bad moves unfortunately there is no good
move in this position knight c4 is the
move he has choice and and jordan's just
blitzing everything out she's blitzing
it out and here's the thing if the rook
had been on f8 in this position black
would have been able to to tuck the
queen back on e8 that's the whole point
here the queen has to
anchor itself to the pawn
and and so queen e5 is forced
and we're seeing all of that on the
board
queen e5 is going to be played jordan's
going to take that immediately and then
play rook f7 and rook takes d7 and end
the game
i mean that was uh what a what a
turnaround and for vidit he started
brilliantly received and just studying
his nerves before the final the final
assault here i think he's already seen
the winning continuation but he has
plenty of time on the clock and there he
goes the queens are off the board
and this is 40 but it's not gonna help
with it
nope you can have all the time in the
worlds but if jordan plays yeah rook f7
check
and
it's all over and this rook takes d7
idea fiona without that idea black would
have been fine here but it's not a
coincidence white is so active and has
been not really the whole game that
it's
totally natural that a tactic like that
exists rook takes d7 and i can guarantee
you that it is going to resign after
that yeah and what a well what a
comeback first of all uh from jordan
after losing a tough game yesterday to
sergey karjakin
for witted it's a tough loss he's been
doing so well here undefeated but the
first loss is coming up here as jordan
has captured on d7 and uh there is just
nothing no tricks here for black and we
see
that they're shaking his head and he
knows this one is gone
yeah and definitely the time situation
hurt him tremendously it hurt him in
terms of making a proper decision after
f4 before f4
you know he took a lot of time and he
found a way to worm out of that trouble
that he was in in the opening that was
really impressive but that's what often
happens you do that
and guess what then you have a whole
middle game to play and you've got 15
minutes on your clock
yeah and well
we see here the finishing touches bishop
e6 has just
appeared on the on the board and there
was just nothing i think you predicted
the resignation at the end of the
sequence and there was just simply no
move here for video no but the knight
can't move
rook takes c7
pawn takes and the pawn will promote
otherwise the bishop takes the knight
moves away from d7 and the red carpet is
unrolled you can just play d7 and d8
vid it thinking about where it is that
he went wrong the decisive mistake was
rick fade
uh was playing rook c8 but i think that
practically speaking the position was
tremendously difficult to defend yeah
and well i'm curious i'm sure we'll hear
from jordan after uh the game but with
mamidyarov having drawn his game vidit
about to lose a certain magnus carlsen i
will have to go back to his game but he
might just and there is the resignation
there it is um and well a great job uh
by jordan van ferece provided a tough
loss as we see the players here uh
discussing
uh the game
yeah nvidia probably admitting to some
sort of
mistake and you just never know what
they're discussing but it's definitely
composed of chess moves
that we know
and as they chat about their game very
impressive performance by jordan a big
win
uh always important to to get that
little push in the middle of the
tournament for sure given how packed the
field is
indeed we have brought up the bird's eye
view so only three games uh remain now
we i think we should go back to magnus
carlsen yes prague was so low on time
they have not reached the time control
yeah that's far from it
in fact we should just stick on this
game because they are playing a blitz
game ladies and gentlemen magnus now the
one with two minutes he took a long time
prague i love what he just did he didn't
take on d7 he went h3 that's the top
move at least he keeps the tension and
here's the thing yes it's minus four
because the threat of c4 is ultimately
inevitable but look at how many pieces
are on the board black's queen on e4 is
kind of caught in the middle of things
the game is not over and prague is
defending very resiliently here doing
everything he can magnus might very well
get nervous here and make a mistake in
time pressure he's got less than two
minutes less than two minutes incredible
stuff i guess what you want to do is
there the first question is is there an
immediate threat in the position for
white after queen d2
no and that's why magnus brought the
queen back to g6 he was tired of the
queen
constantly getting caught on the crime i
mean rook oh actually rookie one was a
threat no there was a threat rookie won
so that's why he played queen g6 but how
prague might want to go knight h4 knight
f5
yeah maybe we can finally see that king
side assault that we missed out on
earlier
too late for knight g5 but not too late
to try to activate that knight i think
prague's going to go knight h4
i think you kind of have to
you have magnus you know that you're
worse in the position you're down upon
but with the time ticking down even the
world champion he is only human we all
make mistakes and i think you want to
throw your pieces uh forward now and ask
magnus some questions here before mu 40
is reached
he's partially human i wouldn't call him
you know fully human just just just half
human now there are other moves there's
queen f4 but what concerns me about
knight h4 is black can swing the queen
around to see c6
and after knight f5 i was thinking the
black could go knight f6
oh but here there's bishop takes f6 and
if queen takes f6 the knight worms its
way into d6 forcing a trade and black
will be left with a very weak pawn on c5
so black's decisive advantage could very
well evaporate
even with a couple of normal moves it's
not like that line featured an obvious
blunder black has to go that h5 that's a
key move we shouldn't write prague up
just yet but he has got to also play a
bit faster i think he should try and
keep of course this is so much easier
said than done
but
knight h4
i hope he plays that move quickly
because the more he thinks now the more
difficult of course uh it's going to get
no but i think he should have played
this move a lot faster than he did
um and again it's so easy for me to say
that but
he knows he's losing objectively so
you've got to put the time pressure on
magnus and telly magnus is taking every
one of these seconds and he is
calculating that h4 deciding where he's
going to put his queen the engine
indicates that the queen actually
belongs on e6 in that case
i just don't see a feasible alternative
and there he goes there it is i think
he's played it
yeah i think he's playing knight h4 on
the board and now magnus needing to
decide where he wants to go to his
screen let's not uh
let's face it i mean also not an easy
situation for magnus here we are only on
move 27 so magnus still has 14 moves to
make he knows he is much better i don't
know if he realizes it's winning
but
still a lot of white pieces looking down
at the white king at the black king
white has this control over the defile
so it's not like a simple
winning position for magnus and prague
is also a tremendous blitz player and
he's so tricky he knows how to find
these tricks uh in time pressure and at
this point they're basically playing a
bullet game with increment magnus
another thing you want to do in your
opponent's time pressure force your
opponent to make decisions this is a
classic example of that guess what
there's no that's not a legal move but
there's queen e4 there's queen e6
there's queen c6 there's queen h7
there's four different feasible queen
moves you've got a minute on your clock
you know you feel the pressure magnus
knows that he has to play accurately
here he knows the knight's coming to f5
everybody's going to get nervous human
or not and magnus hesitating and he's
also dropping under a minute and he
decides on queen e6
and that seems to be the most precise
move
if i'm prague i'm going knight f5 in two
seconds insane
instantly i'm going not a five instantly
even though apparently
knight f5 allows this move bishop b7 my
goodness oh my god
you take the knight
why does the desperado knight takes h6
like this is an example how can you
calculate this in a minute let's see
what prague did
he's still thinking uh prague about to
drop under a minute again
um i like your suggestion of rook knight
f5 i think we need to at least bring all
the pieces into the game and try and
create uh some threats
he's about to make a move he's got 50
seconds
having said a you kind of have to say b
then there he goes
on the board
big moment here will magnus find the
move bishop b7 exploiting the fact that
the knight is only defended by the rook
but i would be deter i would be
disturbed by this knight takes h6 move
yeah i think really i think this game
here it's easy to be misled as the
spectator by the evaluation bar but if
we try and not look at the bar i mean
yes black is a pawn up but the position
looks so messy still
playing purely on increments sorry dania
no and just to your point i was gonna
say here's the thing
not all winning advantages are the same
some of them
you can play three four moves and it
doesn't change the evil because white is
so active black has to play with
tremendous accuracy and that's not easy
to do and magnus i think he's gone c4
and wait a second is there not a tactic
connected with the rook being hanging
isn't there bishop takes g7 here
so bishop g7 bishop g7 knight g7 trade
everything then go queen d4 check black
will cover with the knight and
simultaneously hit white circle this is
really exciting prague has to has to try
it that's the only move because black is
threatening c3
imagine being in this
position with less than a minute on the
clock you really got a feel for prague
uh he's gonna be tempted because i think
the the rook on a7 being undefended
jumps into the eye but so tough i think
here you just have to rely uh on
instinct and danny i guess your instinct
is telling you i should just take
g7
i can guarantee you prague is
calculating that with 24 seconds he's
got to make a move maybe he's going to
play knight takes g7 both captures are
possible
either case his only chance right now is
to exploit that undefended rook on a7
maybe he'll play queen d4 straight away
10 seconds for prague and no
queen d4 so queen d4 not sacrificing but
just attacking the rook on a7
and now there's an incredibly powerful
move for black knight f6 covering the
threat against g7 and counter-attacking
the rook that move seems to win the game
on the spot
do you think knight f6 is an an obvious
move
yes well it's not obvious and i think
magnus might be tempted by rook takes a
four or c3 no knight f6 no there he is
the world champion he's the world
champion for a very good reason fiona
and prague had to take on g7 that was a
big chance for him there was indeed a
chance now after knight f6 the black
king suddenly is safe
are there no more sacrifices here at all
possible
you can play knight takes h6 and then
queen takes f6 but the end game is going
to be completely lost because black is
going to shove this pawn down to c3 and
then he's going to win the pawn on b3
and is going to have connected passers
and unfortunately prague knows all about
facing connecting passers
he made his move there with two seconds
on the clock
dania but uh knight
b6
c3 is going to come shut down that
bishop and c3 resigns
yeah
c3 resigns because after the bishop
moves you'll be able to take the rook
and there you go c3 is on the board
we're on move 30
but that doesn't matter any longer
because magnus has found a couple of
precise moves now prague may be missing
a small chance objectively the position
was still bad but at least there was a
fighting chance after
sacrificing on g7 but now magnus has
everything under control and this is
that's the thing there were several
moments in this game where prague didn't
pull the trigger knight g5 and at the
end bishop takes g7 i can guarantee you
is a move fiona that he would have made
against the vast majority of players and
i know i'm repeating that but it's just
important to recognize
how insane of an effect magnus has on
people
playing magnus changes you and here
magnus has to play knight takes d5
and after knight takes a7 c takes b2
magnus has decided to take instead with
the queen
um which
is also going to be equally good yes
everything wins i mean white white has
more hanging pieces than black and at
the end black's going to take the bishop
on b2 and that pawn's going to promote
so it's over
that's also good
queen d5 uh prague
what he tooks he exchanged
he's going to resign here because knight
takes a7 c takes b2 and knight c3 is
unstoppable
yeah i think we are seeing the final
moments here of the game uh prague took
on a7 magnus taking on b2
and
yeah rugby one rookie two is might be
thrown in rugby one rookie two and then
knight c3 is over
yeah rookie two
yeah and there he goes rookie two is on
the board and will probably uh see a
handshake now
yeah i mean white can also try knight t4
and
magnus could even go knight c3 in this
position just showcasing total
domination knight takes e2 knight takes
b1 then the knight calmly steps back and
promotes the pawn
what a time scramble what a play by
magnus so accurate
magnus is such a beast you let him back
in and there is the resignation by
pragnanda and some visible relief on the
face of magnus carlsen relief but also
we see this quite often i think magnus
is not completely satisfied with the
game he played
was he maybe apologizing for
pressing the clock i don't know or like
i don't know what that means but i've
seen magnus do that before
yeah i think very often it's a little
bit of frustration of him not being
too satisfied maybe with the way he
handled the opening or i don't know
maybe he's pointing out knight g5
but uh well
the game wasn't smooth enough i mean
maybe he's worried the game wasn't
smooth enough and what do you want me to
do
and uh
yeah but but at the end of the day you
know it always seems like magnus emerges
on top in these kinds of games let's go
to do that against uh fabiano carolina
we are we haven't made the time control
yet so we're on move 38. how is dudas
king on c1 of duda is
is dude just fine here did fabi blow
this advantage
do we have time to quickly go back a few
moves fabiano three minutes on the clock
for three moves let's very quickly catch
up
okay so bishop f5 rook h2 dc bc it's
winning
but dude i'm playing very accurately
before this is all correct according to
the engine and here fabi playing really
slowly he had to go e5 and blast open
the center blasted open e5 d takes e5
queen swings to c6 targeting the rook
the c file gets opened this is so scary
with the queen on b2 looking down
but the point is that black can always
put a knight on c3 and black has this
anchor point to shut the queen down but
fabi understandably he misses it he
tries to play slowly that allows doing a
time to tuck his king away on c1
this is still scary for white but now
the evo bar swings in white's favor
because the king on c1 is safe white has
built up a pawn chain and if white
simply takes on f5 and goes rookie one
it's anybody's game but duda 30 seconds
for two more moves can he continue his
accurate play can he make a comeback
he's really kept his cool until now as
you say almost no time on the clock and
he hasn't taken on b5 on f5
what is the move
covering his king even further
and essentially he's preparing bishop
takes f5 in which case black is going to
have to recapture with the pawn giving
white connected passer so fabi might be
the one
uh to have to take the bishop on d3
and for fab it's a tough spot it's his
second time scramble
in a row yesterday of course hopefully
can put that out of his mind he he
fought so valiantly yesterday finding so
many uh only moves and then just to
throw away the whole game on mu 40 here
it is moved 39 so two moves to make for
fabiano you said maybe he just has to
exchange the bishops can we try and
keep the bishop or are we worried about
giving that pawn on on h7 well we can we
can play bishop g4 but then white is 95
and then rook takes d4 with total
pandemonium that's so hard to calculate
in time but you know this reminds first
of all fabi in so frustrating he was
overwhelmingly better at one point
yesterday same today he's playing really
well but in certain critical moments
just seems like he's faltering but this
does remind me of a game that he had
with duda i think in the candidates
tournament although don't quote me on
that where fabi played this incredible
petrov he was up in exchange and young
christoph duda is such a multi-faceted
player he's got so many strengths and
we're not just talking he's well-rounded
he's incredibly resilient he's
incredibly well prepared and there's no
doubt in my mind about why he seems to
be the only one who can give magnus a
run for his money at the moment
and fabi while we see him looking at the
the clock he's looking a little bit
nervous uh because he probably feels
that the grip on the position that he
had has somewhat escaped him and it's
also frustrating when your opponent just
keeps finding uh the best moves you feel
like you're better you're better but you
just
don't you're not getting anywhere and
all kudos to young krishna who's really
done a brilliant job anything can still
happen fabiano now down to only 30
seconds danya
yeah for two incredibly important moves
that have to be played and he does take
on d3
duda recapturing immediately with the
rook
and now fabi's king slowly but surely is
going to end up in quite a bit of danger
i mean you can imagine ideas like rook
g1 knight e5 there's gonna be checkmates
on f7 this rook from d3 can swing over
to f3 later and somehow the fact that
white's king
is as stable as it is fiona is just a
miracle
indeed and well we saw duda get off the
board because rook takes d3 was his move
number 40 but for fabiano still
one tough move uh to make and only 20
seconds he's gonna have to make up his
mind and the rook
went somewhere rook to d5 that was a
good move that's a good move
that's a very good move
and we see fabiano just i think such a
relief always when you make muforti i
don't know how relieved he will be about
the position he's gotten to get here
because it's still so double-edged here
but
at least he hasn't lost on time so there
is a certain relief associated with that
now the engine is proposing a pretty
crazy idea just giving away the exchange
on c3 and using this pawn as an umbrella
what you don't want to do is play queen
takes c3 because of
rook takes c5 and the queen is lost
but you want to keep the spawn on c3 as
protection and instead of taking the
pawn you actually centralize the queen
and then you go after the e6 pawn with
the mover key one and any end game is
going to be nasty for black because of
these connected passers fiona so
lots of options here for duda and this
is going to be a really really
interesting
next five seven moves i think they're
going to decide a
lot i'm very curious to see when do that
comes back i think he's going to invest
a lot of time will we see the exchange
sacrifice we see the results here under
the camera so two decisive results one
game which wasn't played
with duboff still awaiting the result of
his pcr tesso and niche winning that
game by forfeit um but the two other
games that were played as magnus carlsen
in his first classical encounter beating
pragnanda
and jordan with a huge baron spike
victory and we are going to an interview
with magnus carlson magnus golson you
just beat pragananda with the black
pieces um it looked like a very uh
smooth win
oh no
um i think i
i think i really really messed up uh
towards the end
at least practically speaking i mean i
allowed this knight g7 stuff um
but maybe that was only one moment but i
was i was struggling to find a way to
sort of consolidate properly um
and um
uh yeah i had to say i didn't really
didn't really manage
and um yeah i gave him way too many
counter chances there
okay what's surprising to me because i
could basically like in the first 25
moves like you develop your pieces and
everything goes to the right squares and
everything looks so good for you yeah i
felt like i had a very good sequence
there with where i found a lot of uh
very nice positional moves and it was
all going according to plan and then
there was like
a little bit of a wild face there but
i guess overall i was better for for
most of the game yeah um
one non tournament related question like
um
how do you keep your mind fresh during
the tournament do you um
do you do puzzles or do you play online
or like what type of things do you do
ah
no not too much i just
try and eat and
eat and sleep and play okay so we cannot
expect you at the title arena as like
miss
as doctor vikon zerstein
um yeah
acios told me about it
i don't think it's very likely no okay
thank you
carlsen uh looking exhausted there i
have to say danny after his win against
pragnanda and mentioning that moment
with not being happy allowing some
chances uh with the sacrifice on g7
yeah and i'm a little bit bummed that uh
night chief knight g5 was not mentioned
but
that's definitely something that will be
analyzed and re-analyzed many many times
over
and well we are we're going to take a
quick look at the the current position
in the essipanko again shankland i see
that jordan is also getting ready for
his interview he's looking a lot fresher
than magnus well we'll see that live i
think there we go so let's go to jordan
you're the front for race you just beat
uh feed it
um with the white pieces um we just
spoke briefly before the interview you
told me like i cannot play a normal game
at all
yeah no it seems like
i'm playing a rollercoaster event here
whereas i finally thought i
i grew up a bit and became a bit more
solid but nothing
of that seems to be true at all
so i lost three games and well i also
won three games um actually today i
wanted to play solidly i didn't
i didn't want to go crazy lose possibly
third game in a row but the game got
kind of crazy so that was not planned
but
fortunately things
went well for me
um what were the key moments in the in
the game today oh there were a lot um i
think the first move is when he played
95 instead of rook d5 rook t5 should be
uh
like a repetition
uh then i made a lot of mistakes but i
was very happy when i got this bishop
pair because my bishop on g3 was
not doing a whole lot for the most part
of the game but finally when when i got
it active i was pretty optimistic about
my chances
before this game you you actually lost
two games in a row
how hard is it mentally to to recover
from uh from two losses yeah it
didn't happen to me in quite a long time
that i lost two games in a row i cannot
really recall whenever it happened but
uh so it was definitely a very tough um
usually i just try to
focus on the next game and forget forget
about the loss but uh of course it's uh
it's it's not not easy but yeah i mean
when you play this tournament you you
kind of
expect to have tough moments
from here here or there
and yesterday i talked with anish giri
uh and he mentioned something very
interesting he said like well
always like after the world championship
match there's always a couple of players
who are so much more prepared than i am
because they were part of the world
championship team
what's your take on that
um
yeah well that's interesting because
anish is usually definitely
one of the best players in the world if
not the best prepared player in the
world so but definitely uh when you
prepare for something like the world
championship match um you have a whole
group of people who work
on chess intensively for months so uh
there is a lot of work going into that
so
i mean i can understand when he says
that
we're just over halfway
yeah
anything to gain for i just hope to to
not lose as many games in the second
half
you're you're afraid
yeah very afraid
okay
oh good sleep okay yeah thank you
jordan van furiste uh looking a lot more
cheerful there than magnus carlsen he
has had certainly a roller coaster event
he thought he might have you know his
chest might have calmed down a little
but no and as jaspens dania i think
we're very happy uh to see the the kind
of fire branches that jordan is playing
indeed we are and uh it's not a
coincidence that he won last year's
edition he is so full of ideas
uh and he he really played a nice game
today i mean maybe with
the exception of just one move but he
kept his foot on the gas pedal and even
when he squandered that initial
advantage he found f4 he played quickly
his time management is excellent that's
not often talked about it's just not
something which
uh is really talked about as his
strength but uh for jordan he rarely
gets into severe time pressure and i
think that really bodes well for his for
his practical chances
for sure and well speaking of not taking
your your foot off the gas pedal we are
back in this one came here between yes
panko and uh shankland and sam is
actually doing a great job defending
this game
well i want to rewind to what i think
really set the tone here
uh in in a bad way for for andre
uh it was so let me so we we saw this
moment
exquisite play to win the a6 pawn and
get a winning position
and this was all good this was all good
the rook swings back to e2
and and this is the moment queen b5
instead of queen b6 looks like such a
subtlety but that's you know welcome to
2700 chess he had to go for this pawn
rather than going for the rook because
he allowed sam to reposition his rook to
c3 and now estepanko swings his queen to
e4 but sam using his king fearlessly to
defend the pawn and after queen takes h7
queen g won and i think this move might
have been overlooked by andre from a
distance because now if you play rookie
rookie 2
sam has the very powerful rookie 3 using
the pin
if you trade you allow a huge passer if
you don't trade and after rookie 1 black
is simply winning and so this forces
esopenko
to
to trade
and now sam is just in time yeah just in
time to get behind the pawn and look at
that pawn up before fiona it is
together with a pawn on d4 they're
freezing all of white's queen side pawns
and the rook can swing to h8 in order to
freeze the kingside pods let me tell you
all three results are possible here if
andre is not careful if he loses the
pawn on f3 he could very well end up
being worse here i know that sounds
crazy but i don't think it is
yeah what an exciting end game and you
can clearly see from the camera on ese
pankos face that things
have gone
wrong here for him not wrong maybe in a
sense that he's worse but he felt
surely that he must have been winning
with that black king in the center of
the board
now the time control has been made and
he's down again half an hour on the
clock and as you said danya he he might
even have to be careful here
yeah and and again how
why let me let me give an illustrative
line so first of all it's not easy to
even make a move here you might say okay
let me target the five pawn or the
rookie two
but that's very easily defended either
by bishop d6 or by bishop f well not
bishop f6 i guess that drops the pawn so
bishop d6 is important here
and if if white returns to g2 in order
to defend g6 black is already winning
rook h8
and no matter what you do the rook
swings to h3 and this is deadly i mean
the rook attacks f3 you have to go here
then the king takes the pawn and you can
just see visually white is totally
entombed so for that reason
uh i think it's actually crucial for
white to play this move h4
now this uses the fact that the bishop
is anchored to the before pawn after
rook h8 you can set up kind of a
fortress along the h file with the move
rook g4 and here i think white still
preserves an advantage but this is the
only way that he can do it
well we'll see if andre
can find this continuation we will come
back to this game as well as a karana or
dudacarana after a short break so don't
go anywhere and we'll be back here with
the remainder of the action of round
seven
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to round seven here at the
tata steel uh chess tournament
and well two games are still ongoing but
already dania with the results we've had
we see the standings at the top have
been shaken up
they have indeed and the world champion
on top with five out of seven he is
guaranteed to be in clear first after
this round even though two people are
still playing but we see a big peloton
right behind him four and a half at a
seven for chakriar
uh who held a very nice draw today
and uh plenty of people on plus one as
well and if andreas panko manages to
pull it out uh he will also have four
and a half out of seven although that's
looking increasingly less likely yeah um
assam has done a great job here to
stabilize the position absolutely i
think we're gonna go
um back either there or do that well
there isn't too much of an option but i
think part of the reason why yes panko
when we left this one off he was looking
quite frustrated uh
it is
always gonna be tough to not win what
was very close to being a winning
position but especially when he could
have shared second place with a win but
we'll see maybe there are still some
chances which of the two games do you
want to start with
let's go to car i have a feeling that
andre offered a try i feel like he
accompanied the move rookie 2 with the
drawer and the reason i say that
is because sam has no moves other than
bishop d6 bishop d6 is absolutely forced
um bishop d6 is absolutely forced
because bishop f6 gives up the pawn up
before rook c5
i mean this stair gives up
ten different pawns there's no other
moves so
i feel like andre might have offered to
draw i feel like andre might be getting
a little bit concerned as i said about
and truly being worse but we'll see um i
agree let's move to the caruana game
because we've had a couple of moves
there i believe
actually i think well
up until a moment ago only one move had
been played
oh yeah do that taking his time on move
41 and coming up with a knight to
to e5
okay so
the immediate thing that occurs to me
this part on d4 you always want to think
in terms of drawbacks you know there's a
move that looks impressive you want to
see if you can detect hidden drawbacks
of that move and one thing that 95 does
is it leaves the pawn on d4
uh as a little bit of a weakness and so
black can dial the knight back to b5 and
hit it where it hurts
and you get really interesting
complications here so if white defends
the pawn with the rook then there's a
tactic there's knight takes d4 anyway
and after rook takes d4 rook c takes c5
how does this work well if white covers
with the rook then black takes the
knight if white covers with the knight
then the rook on d4 becomes exposed and
black wins
so
in the event of knight p5 it looks like
white has to defend the pawn in a better
way white has to defend it while also
moving the queen away from the c file so
that there's no pin but after knight
takes d4 anyway rook takes d4
here black can take the c pawn with the
other rook
after king b1 queen takes e5 fiona this
is actually a tremendously sharp
position because of this pawn on h6
white's got
major major attacking chances the engine
seems to think that black is better
after king g8 but it's anybody's game so
this is one possibility i mean i feel
you gotta feel sorry for the players
this
position this game is giving me
headaches it's been so tremendously
complicated throughout and the players
uh i think both of them
for both of them it was a very tense
time scramble situation uh with the
players being down to the last seconds
just before mu 40 and then finally you
make the time control but life doesn't
get any easier and i think uh daniel
very likely here that we can already
start being into into territory of a
second time scramble
oh absolutely and and i was going to say
something exactly to that point which is
that you often get lulled into this
false sense of security when you hit
time control yeah i've got 15 minutes i
can take a deep breath i can relax i can
drink some water and i can calculate at
my leisure you blink and you've got 15
minutes again and that happens so very
often because mu 41 is often a
tremendously committal decision as it is
here i have a feeling that fabi's going
to go for an ip5 i think he's going to
see it
yeah fabi looking very focused there
um
at the board and i mean this game if you
had to predict the result from here
dania what what would your prediction be
i i'm going to make a rather cynical
prediction and call for a draw
i feel like it's going to fizzle out
somehow in fact i think both of the
remaining games are going to end in
draws but we'll see i probably get this
probably is not going to age well
well we'll see i guess for sure it is
the most likely result but all three was
all still possible especially if the
time continues ticking down
uh towards
um
towards that second time control fabiano
his clock will be updated after his make
after he makes his next
move but let's go back because you've
piqued my interest let's go back to the
end game between
yasipanko and shankland we don't know if
there was a draw for i agree with you is
very likely
look he took yeah and and again the
reason i say that he took eight minutes
on bishop d6 maybe he was just catching
his breath and you know calculating
something afterward
but
i mean if so but if he there was a draw
for then he's declined it and uh sam
might believe that he's the one playing
for a win now i don't know if that's the
case so sepenko's idea is to go bishop
e1 and he says i don't need the g pawn
i'm giving that one away but i'm keeping
the h1 so that the rook is unable to
infiltrate to h3
and this is
probably some sort of a mutual fortress
like it might be a situation where
neither side is able to make any kind of
significant progress
yeah there were a couple of things here
i was wondering about i was dreaming of
getting the white king
maybe all the way to to e4 but i guess
the problem with that if i start running
with king c1 and try to go to d2 i will
have a problem with the pawn on a2
which is very easy for black to attack
and maybe i just have to go back and
defend
you might even you might be able to
sacrifice if king d2 rook takes a2 king
d3 might be a feasible option because
black spawns are also tremendously weak
this leads to a very sharp end game but
yeah of course white can also repeat
with king b1
so uh well plenty here uh to consider
four yes panko after
after black's last move rook h8 it is
the young russian
uh
to play
bishop
he won uh if he is thinking then what
are the alternatives can we go for rock
h2 i think he has just gone bishop e1
yeah it makes more sense to leave the
rook uh to to move to the g file at the
right time
and ma and uh i was going to say magnus
magnus shankland
sam
is very likely going to take on g6 he is
already reaching out and i think there
he goes king takes g6
is on the board
and um i mean i'm starting to to like
black uh
i understand the position still looks
equally equal but
black just seems a bit more active
somehow yeah i mean white is of course
up upon so
uh that that is white's main advantage
here the fact that he's got the h1 and
black doesn't but yeah in terms of peace
activity there's no question that black
is more active and black is the better
structure this pawn on b4 as i said is
totally freezing all of white's queen
side pawns the king is more active the
rook is better placed and white's bishop
is now saddled
with this defensive task of guarding h4
so
it is really hard to say who's playing
for a win here and i love your idea i
think andre might try
to get this king up toward the center or
if he's kind of decided not to burn any
bridges then he might give a check on g2
and just sort of bide his time no he's
gone he's gone
he's gone king c1
king c1 is
indeed on the board and i'm i'm curious
first of all will sam go rook a8 if he
does will
andre just go back
or will he go forward
um and
decide i can't tell any longer what's
the joke what's reality
the stroke has become too meta for me
optical illusion
it would actually be really cool if this
truly was a straight line
that would have blown my mind
them has different concerns he is not uh
being distracted by any name tags
uh he is
deep in thought we looked at um we
looked at rook a8 can some also maybe
bring his king simply
yeah he can
and in this position again you can go
rook eight you can also go with g8
but i'm not sure and then you could try
to infiltrate via g1
and and try to go to f1 and just target
that pawn and f that pawn on f3 is is
really the key to the kingdom for black
if black can win that pawn
immediately he gets a set of connected
passers and that's just totally
unthinkable for black for white i think
sam's going to go rook a8 though it just
seems like the simplest
and andre probably hasn't decided
whether he's going to make a draw or
whether he's going to go for the win i
think he's going to decide he's going to
cross that bridge when he gets there if
sam plays rka yeah but an an end game
that definitely has a lot of life in it
still
let's go back to uh duda and karana see
if fabiano has made up his mind and
dania 95 is on the board wow
yeah and it's it's a hard move to make
because the knight on c3 was so so
pretty but it's very important you know
for pieces to actually play a role and
and a piece that doesn't look as
glamorous but accomplishes a lot more is
incomparably more valuable and that's
exactly the case here the knight isn't
on an outpost anymore but what it is
doing
is hitting where it hurts that pawn on
d4 is now a weakness it is possible
fiona that dude just overlooked this
move
i mean
night retreating night moves are the
hardest moves to see
indeed and well yesterday fabiano he was
on the receiving end of a retreating
nightmare exactly this time he's on the
what what do you call the other side the
inflicting
right he's the victimizer
yeah he's cruel yeah it's funny he
missed knight b6 yesterday and today he
plays knight c3 to b5 quite symbolic
yeah knight c4 to b6 or was gary's night
on a4
oh wait no fabi was white sorry where
was gary's knight
wasn't the knight on i think it was on
c4
c4 yeah so knight c4 to b6 and here
knight c3 to b5
there's uh
some sort of some
justice
time to bring out the yeah
bring out the conspiracy theories and
then tomorrow it's going to be knight c2
to b4
but yeah dude i mean uh
in a in a tough position i'm still i
mean this is still a position that i'm
struggling we've been looking at it for
so long but i'm still struggling to to
wrap my head around
uh what's happening here
i think that it's important to break
this down into like who what are white
and blacks advantages white's main
advantage very clearly is the spawn on
h6 why because this pawn limits the king
and it creates a massive back rank
weakness it means that any check on the
eighth rank is likely to be checkmate
but from black's perspective these pawns
on d4 and c5 that used to be a strength
but now it's white's main white's main
weakness
and the other big weakness is the fact
that the queen and the king are aligned
which creates the constant possibility
of knight takes d4 followed by rook
takes c5 pinning the queen and so that
is why in order to defend this pawn
effectively white should do it with the
move queen b2 at least this moves the
queen away from the alignment
and uh
how does this line go so as i was
showing takes takes
now if you take the knight immediately
that leads to an end game white plays
rook takes d5 well you can't take the
rook because you blunder your queen so
you have to take white's queen first
then you take the rook the problem is
that black's king is so so far away from
white's passer whereas white's king is
essentially ready to start eating up
black spawns and so for that reason if
we rewind back to
this moment it's important for black to
snap this pawn off first which rook
should he do it with well if you do it
with this rook you can do it with either
rook and that's going to lead to another
type of end game so let's say black does
it with disrupt in this position you
have to notice that the queen is
x-raying black's king and that allows
rook takes f4
forcing a queen trade and leading to
this endgame where black is up upon but
still has to reckon with the mate threat
according to the engine this is closer
to a draw than to anything else but
black is essentially not risking if he's
careful
so we have seen
some of these lines you were saying the
most likely is that this peter's out
into a draw one way or another we're
still a long way away from that
happening and
it feels like uh duda is the one who has
to to find the more accurate moves here
to steer the
at the game into such a territory
without without question and and it
starts here
i i just don't see another move i mean
i was thinking about something crazy
like rook g1
and the idea here is takes takes
and if you
just naively take on d4 then white has
rook g7 but the funny thing is that even
in this position black is still better
because black has queen takes h6
and even though there's a fork black
eats up all of white's pieces and like
as you know a kingdom and a horse for
for the queen so
very concerning situation for duda as he
drops to 30 minutes i was just gonna say
that is another danger looming here
remember this is only the first move
that both sides have made after the time
control dude as knight e5 and fabiano's
knight b5 which means that the players
still have to make 19 moves and maybe we
can for one second bring up the
tournament uh format and time control so
remember the players get 100 minutes for
the first 40 moves then they get an
extra 50 minutes and then an extra 15 on
move 60 with a 30 second increment from
move one but
so often you were talking about it this
sense of security you know you make it
to
move 40 there is such a relief you get
an extra 15 minutes 50 minutes at that
moment when you've been playing on a
minute feels like all the time in the
world and suddenly
you
think about one move and half of that 50
minutes is already gone that's exactly
what's happened i mean basically half of
it is gone
and i'm a little bit
yeah duda i'm 99 sure that he blundered
knight b5
and it's crucial for him not to lose his
goal because one more mistake in this
position
and why could end up being lost so queen
b2 this is the key move that he has to
find
to keep things relatively stable
and well we'll come back to this one
shall we see if there has been an update
uh in the end game between yasipanko
and
shankland where we were curious
rk8 has indeed been played and now
yasipanko with the decision to make king
b1 could potentially lead to a
repetition after rook h8 king c1 rook a8
so the question is do you go forward to
d2 instead
yeah king d2 looks very tempting i mean
at first this just looks good for white
it looks like white's going to go up to
c4 and you know win the b4 pawn
but the reality is is probably the black
should be able to say to hold the draw
here so rook a1
for instance is the engine preferred
move and after king c4 king h5
okay well what happens after bishop
takes b4 it turns out and this is a
really cool idea that black just goes
king takes h4 and again everything seems
to come down to this f pawn
and as soon as black is able to win this
pawn
i mean this is just a drawback he's
going to take on f3 and if anything
maybe white has to be careful here
because this pawn is going to be very
far advanced
something tells me though that escepenko
is going to go king d2
he's probably going to especially gonna
have to take the other
the other side of the bat just to
contradict you daniel
fair enough no i i i wouldn't be like
shocked if he goes for a draw here
because you also don't want to overpress
and lose i mean there's nothing more
painful than losing a game like this
yeah i mean this last uh line you showed
on the board in the final position uh
well you said it yourself the engine
just says should be a draw but i would
be way more scared to to play with white
and extra pawn but the the black king on
f3 the black pawn only three squares
away so
i think unless andre finds something
more convincing than that because if he
gets to that position i don't think
that's a position he thinks he can win
so if he plays on i think he'll have to
find something more than that
yeah and by his it's hard to tell by his
body language but it just
seems like he's a little bit
disappointed in what he's finding after
king d2
now of course after king b1 sam might
decline the repetition not because he's
playing for a win but because he thinks
there's a better let's say a better
placement for the rook
um just to avoid
just
just to avoid the situation occurring
again but yeah first things first let's
see if andre
let's see what andre decides on he's got
27 minutes plenty of time of course
i think he's gonna make a decision
within the next couple of minutes yeah
and andre really looks um very
disappointed i think it's not so much
the state of the current position but he
knows that he had some very serious
winning chances today
yeah and i i think more deep computer
analysis will
clarify whether in fact he was
completely winning or
you know a little bit winning but i i
think again that moment queen b5
uh this computer was giving something
like plus four and
that seemed to check out so it's going
to be
very very very frustrating evening
if andre doesn't find a way to win
this position which is looking very
unlikely sam's also got a lot of time
yeah
uh i wouldn't i wouldn't be shocked if
he goes back i hope of course from a fan
perspective that hero goes forward right
and that the fight continues but we
still have these two uh interesting
games going on we're gonna go on a quick
break and then we'll be back here with
the conclusion of round seven so don't
go anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome again in vikrance a strike
stands for forbidding for bending here
in the door
fans over the hillside
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the chess.com rapid chess championship
is a brand new world-class online rapid
event series for the top 100 players top
10 women and top 10 juniors in the world
watch as the very best compete for their
share of twenty thousand dollars each
week culminating with a 150k prize final
it all starts at nine a.m pacific noon
eastern
on saturday february 12th right here on
chess.com for more info head on over to
go.chess.com
rcc the rapid chess championship
very exciting event on the horizon there
i very much look forward to dania but
for now we've still got plenty of
excitement here in round seven and my
eye
immediately goes to the
game we talked about this position at
length you thought
that queen b2 was necessary
um but instead duda played rook to d1
and we see the bar not liking what it's
seeing
no and i'm i'm shocked i mean we were
contemplating knight takes d4
okay where rook takes d4 is forced and
now rook c takes c5
now
why not with the other rook because here
white has the move rook d8 check this is
a deflection tactic forcing black to
take twice
and then at the end of it why plays
queen takes c5 and lights up a piece
but so for that reason it's important to
keep one of the rooks as a stopper on
the d file
now you might get excited about queen
takes d5 and say well this is going to
be mate but no rook takes e5 is check
that's very important
for that reason white has to go rooks d4
or wait maybe aha maybe doodle wants to
play rook takes d5
but after rook takes c2 king takes c2
maybe duda is going for this position
fiona where he is threatening rook d8
followed by knight f7 but against the
simple king g8
i think white's initiative fizzles out
and black is up a queen i mean black's
going to take the spawn on h6 i mean the
black queen on f6 doing all the
important jobs especially covering the
the check on
uh on d8 now that the king is not on h8
any longer that's not a threat actually
we can go back maybe and see well if the
queen was covering the eight what was
the big uh trouble here sorry uh yeah
forward in in that position before king
g8 uh why did the king even have to move
oh yeah yeah i'll show the tactics so so
at the end of that line yeah what would
have happened if let's say queen e7 so
yeah white plays rook d8 anyway and puts
the queen and king in a forkable spot
and then knight f7 it's a nice little
tactic
so king g8 is actually the only way to
stop it otherwise against all other
moves rook d8 is possible
so yeah king g8 is the only move but
it's probably
good enough instead of yeah instead of
queen e7 good enough
to win this position with h6 as you
mentioned going
to drop and fabiano do you think he is
already sensing his chance
oh absolutely i can guarantee you he's
he's betraying it with his fa of course
he's not betraying it with his facial
expression because it's fabian uh he's a
professional but i can guarantee he's
very excited right now he's calculating
i take c4 and he's asking himself is
this too good to be true what am i
missing
uh and the answer and of course we have
the
uh the luxury of having the engine at
our disposal the answer is that he's not
missing anything and just to show one
more line after 94 rook d4
rook takes c5
um
if
uh rook c4 happens
then black simply plays queen takes e5
and what's one detail that duda might
have missed he might have been going for
this position and basically saying well
if you take with the rook i mate you if
you take with the queen or the pawn i
take on c5 but there's this deadly inter
mezzo on a one
forcing the king up to d2 and now black
is able to take this work with check and
the rest is history black is up a
million pawns and the attack against
white's king rages on so
it's kind of a toss-up as to what
exactly duda missed but
first things first fabi has to take on
d4 and you have to believe it and he has
to believe in himself and and believe
that duda in fact did blunder what is
your personal experience daniel magnus
famously said in an interview sometimes
the longer he thinks
and the worse the move becomes i think
he once said that very often when he
spends more than 10 minutes the move
tends to not be the best we saw duda
spend a very long time before playing
the move rook d1
so what's your experience with that
yeah and i've heard this kind of
paraphrased by grandmaster john nunn i
think
where he even said something like
every time you think for longer than 15
minutes it's very likely to be a mistake
and
yeah i mean i think where what does that
come from i think that comes from the
idea that if you're thinking for 30
minutes chances are you're gonna you're
doing a very heavy volume of calculation
and when you're doing a heavy volume of
calculation no matter who you are uh
you're likely to get something wrong and
for many players just sticking to their
intuition and saving that time for a
later point and just embracing the fact
that
you know the position is too complicated
to figure out entirely might be the best
approach
but here i don't know what he missed i
knight takes d4 just seems very
straightforward yeah i think and i think
fabiano he is looking sort of in that
general direction and uh of course he's
not gonna play knight d4 without having
checked all the lines
but
i think he sees it i think he's double
checking
and well we we mentioned the times the
situation a couple of times already but
uh duda down to only 22 minutes already
we're on move 42 only two moves past the
time control which means still 18 moves
to go
yeah 18 moves to go and fabio with
plenty of time over half an hour and
look at the discipline he's sitting
there he's hammering it out he knows
that this is his golden opportunity and
fabio also realizes that
he had a dominant position earlier in
the game he knows that
so he certainly does not want to
squander another opportunity that duda
has given him here or that he's created
of course with his good play
yeah and for fabian will be a huge
bounce back when he started with five
draws before losing the game we all
remembered in dramatic fashion two and
ishgiri yesterday
and um it would be great to see him
bounce back of course fabiano and
youngstow duda are both players who will
be playing in the candidates tournament
later this year that is of course the
main focus
but it wouldn't uh i'm sure they would
be happy to go there coming off a good
performance here in vain
without question
and in the meantime fiona updates in the
sam shanklin game entree has indeed
decided to go for the win with the move
king d2
i it's not what i predicted but i'm
happy to see it so andre not just uh
defending passively but going forward so
let's just go back to that moment after
rook a8 we were discussing is he gonna
go defend upon is he gonna go for it he
decided to step forward
sam of course took the pawn on a2 and
now the king landing on d3
we were discussing the king going to h5
in order to tie down white's bishop but
sam deciding to go to f5 andre
immediately taking the opportunity and
pushing that pawn very understandable
and sam stopping it with the move bishop
f8
so there's a couple of tries here for
white i mean white could
play h6 but that's very bad i mean
trading this one for that one
is is not a particularly good idea i
think black is not risking your rook a1
and the rook comes to f1 this is not
what andre went for a win to do
i think the best move here is to build a
little force field with bishop h1 let's
see what he did
what did he just play
h6 no he did play h6 okay well i guess i
guess this is kind of a
an admission that that uh he doesn't
have to see too serious of winning ah
one idea is bishop h6 bishop before
rook a1 and then maybe rook e1
but sam could simply go back to a2 i
don't think blackstone's family for the
draw sorry danielle which was instantly
accepted by yeah
makes perfect sense i mean neither side
can really make progress
kudos to andre for trying every chance
he had but
hats off to sam i mean great preparation
he knew he screwed up and then to hunker
down and and figure out hammer out the
best way to get that game into an end
game and then to defend it that takes a
lot of grit
and and that takes just a lot of
emotional maturity it's it's not easy to
do
and and sam will definitely be feeling
proud of himself for that for sure for
sepenko on the other hand he will be
disappointed he already knows or at
least he can sense he missed something
that will be confirmed when he goes back
to his room and
looks through the game
but it's nice to see the players as soon
as the drawers agreed some smiles were
exchanged and certainly plenty to
discuss here about this game
absolutely a very
rich very full game in fact all of the
draws today have been you know no
complaints at all about the the the
fighting chess index today uh all of the
games have been very very interesting
and that leaves us with
only one and indeed fabi has taken on d4
fiona he's gone for it and now all he
has to do is take the c5 pawn with the
correct rook
and he's going to be
very very close to winning this game
and just as we come back to fabi's
camera if i be making some big eyes
there and maybe struggling to believe
what's happening here and there was a
lot of back and forth and well as you
said now the decision how to capture the
pawn on c5
yeah and and it's important for him not
to be misled by queen takes e5 this is
the most the simplest move but it's a
big blunder after ed
uh there's rook takes d5 and this pawn
on h6 strikes yet again because if you
take the rook a very elegant checkmating
sequence and if you don't take the rook
then
uh black's king is going to end up under
under massive attack and of course there
isn't even a material advantage no
fabby's going to play rook c5 there's
simply no other moves
and this is one of those things where
fabi is helped by the fact that his
moves are quite literally forced
everything else is easy to refute and
and that's what what makes dude's
chances to me so slim here it's just
hard to make a mistake i also think
maybe fabi today double and triple
checking things even more because i
think
even when you're fabiano carrana you're
one of the best players in the world uh
i think a blunder like the one we saw
yesterday is always gonna throw you off
a little bit as it happens so rarely um
and i think something that's not so easy
to to shake off so even more credit to
fabiano for bouncing back here straight
away
absolutely and i think you're right on
the money i think perhaps you would play
a little bit faster under normal
circumstances but
doing that extra check here
uh just just to make sure that he's not
hallucinating and you can see duda i
mean the body language kind of tells it
all he's just waiting for fabi to take
on c5 and it's one of the worst feelings
you're just waiting for your opponent to
make the winning move
yeah and well both players here they
came into the tournament duda one of the
hottest players
of 2021 he won the world cup he came
second in the world blitz he won the
european blitz
he had so many uh great performance he
didn't do great he didn't start the year
great in vicenzedo and this year again
there was some mischances um and today
looks like it's going to be another
tough day for him with
uh who still has to find his uh
his best form
indeed yeah no and he he got off to a
good start this game i thought he had a
very nice position out of the opening
and then somewhere around the time that
he burned all his bridges with his rooks
i think he underestimated fabi's that
that move f5 when fatty pushed that f on
i think that was the turnaround point
you know because before duda was having
all the fauna he went h4
and and after fabio went f5 things
shifted and even though duda kind of
climbed back
in the end his position was always very
difficult no doubt about that
yeah for sure and um it almost looks
like to me like duda is just waiting for
fabiano
to play
uh the move that he knows i think both
players know the move that is going to
appear on the board momentarily but of
course the onus is on fabi to
uh
to make triple sure that the lines work
out in his favor
yeah i mean usually i would
yeah i think fabie should make the move
any second because there's really
nothing else that he can do at this
point
and it's essentially resignable after
rook takes c5 probably the lesser evil
for white
is to go for that line
where where he sacks the queen let's
have a look at that line again so rook
c5
rook d5
um of course black has to take the queen
first
okay takes take stakes and now very
important move king g which fabby has to
factor in
after rook takes a5 there is one
important detail which is that queen
takes h6
actually allows white to draw with a
very interesting mechanism white just
keeps checking
and if you try to zigzag your way out of
it you're gonna run into a problem where
you can't go in any direction because of
either the the skewer or the fork on f7
so
perhaps bobby is thinking about this
position and trying to find
the correct approach the correct
approach is to give a check on f5
and if the king steps to b2 swinging the
queen back to see it and there it is
he's taken stopping raqqa eight and
preparing queen c3 fabby should be able
to win this game
yeah and he's had plenty of time he did
invest
a lot of his remaining clock time here
at this moment and no doubt that uh his
calculations have gone uh
as deeply as the lines that you were
just showing
and i like that uh little trap with the
perpetual check but favi uh
very unlikely to fall for it
very unlikely and yeah given how much
time he's just spent
i can almost guarantee you that he was
he was focusing on that position and
making sure that there is a way that he
can worm his way out of
you know these various ideas and dude
indeed going down this line so we're
gonna see
very likely
uh this we're definitely gonna see the
position after king g8 on the board
and you know the last major pitfall for
fabi is is he has to find queen f5 queen
c8 and there it is rook takes d5
so here is the moment where we expect
a king g8 as once again let's remind
everyone if it were white to move rook
d8 would be the end of the game and you
might be thinking but that rook is just
hanging there
but that would force the fork on f7
so that's why king g8 here
um again we see fabi double checking but
he's just looking looking to the side
there yeah and
our producer is ready wow what a great
camera that's really cool king g8 there
it is dude is going to take on a5 within
a couple of seconds i think
and
yeah and and basically a lot of these
positions where there's a rook and
knight or rooker bishop versus the queen
they're determined by
who has the weaker pawns
the rook and the knight are just not
very good in comparison to the queen at
defending weaknesses and it's funny how
the pawn on h6 is slowly turning from a
strength to a weakness as soon as black
is able to win that pawn under the right
circumstances the position is going to
be resignable because black is going to
have a pass spawn in f7 but the other
problem for white
is that f2 is also weak yeah f2 is weak
uh do that well he didn't have much of a
choice he took on a5
and uh well now the move we've been
talking about for the last few minutes
queen f5
uh check
daniel from a perspective and i know
it's difficult for us here because we
constantly have the bar and the top
engine line sort of shown to us but if
you put yourself in fabiano's shoes um
what do you think how easy is that move
uh queen f5 to to see
well it's made easier by by the lack of
alternatives you know and and again it's
it's one of those things where the more
tempting alternatives there are the
harder the correct move is to find and
he's played it very very quickly there's
a mate threat you have to defend against
it and there's only one check in this
position so
process of elimination leads you to this
to this maneuver quite quickly i think
and duda has to decide where to put his
king i think
after king d2 probably the same idea
prevails queen queen c8 and then you
know and then basically either queen c3
white's pieces are also not anchored
which of course raises the possibility
of forks and really adds insult to
injury queen d8 check
is a threat and that's a case in point
yeah this position just looks horrible
um with the white pieces not
being coordinated well at all
and uh
the sign maybe tomorrow it will be fixed
i think it's a little bit better at
least we don't see that velcro part on
the right hand side but
anyway
do the um yeah dude they're not happy of
course he knows he will try and put up
uh
as much of a fight as he can but
bobby for sure he had already before
seen this position when investing a lot
of his time
before taking on c5 and this one i don't
think he's gonna let it slip
i think king b3 might be white's best
practical chance this does allow the
check on b1
and then i was thinking about going king
king c4 but here what black does is goes
queenie fortran
and the point is that aaa
is now protected by the queen which
means you have time to improve your
position well how can you improve your
position one thing you can do is go f3
pushing this pawn forward and preparing
for a scenario where you win the f2 pawn
white is kind of a zoo zong here i mean
white can barely move a piece and at
some point the king can evacuate from g8
at the right moment maybe even on the
previous move king f8 is
a fully viable
alternative i mean this is just so
dejecting for white
yeah and really the the rook and the
knight um
not working well
together here at all the night being
currently pinned to the
uh to the rook and
um
a tough spot for ian kristof duda i
think dania we're going to take a quick
break uh we will keep these guys on the
camera with their live positions so we
don't miss anything
and we will return to this game uh in a
few minutes so we'll see you then
i just want to say i know it's early
yeah it's early for all of us but fabi
you're looking fresh no thanks danny
chad likes it man looking good
what about me
all right guys let's go run a show back
here we go
and fabi this video series was great by
the way people love it
really do
by the way again dude you're
you're just looking fresh man i love
your new haircut makes me good
[Music]
hey how's it going
[Music]
i don't even recognize myself and i was
like
the whole new me
[Music]
hey fob hey dan how's it going hey
robert hey man
you know i'm just trying out a few new
things here and there the day's
beautiful sun is out
cool
hey danny yeah forgot to mention that
haircut's looking real fresh on you yeah
thanks man
cool
appreciate it you [ __ ] serious
what does a guy guy do around here to
get noticed
what are you talking about
i
seems a little out of line a little
uncalled for
you know you already can't spell chess
without what more does he want
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i was watching this tournament when i
was a kid
when i wasn't a strong player and i was
just watching all the best players in
the world come here
and
i remember the first time i played here
back then it was there were three groups
along with the open section and i was
playing in the c group that was in 2008
but i was already watching this
tournament many years before that
usually there's there's a huge amount of
people
uh who love to to play and to watch
chess here uh now it's of course a bit
different times have changed a bit
but hopefully uh someday we'll go back
to that
yeah i grew up analyzing with the board
but things are very different now most
of the analysis is done on on the
computer but still it's nice to go back
to that sometimes and i think it's also
useful to
analyze over the board because
it helps your understanding of the
position
even if you have the best analysis in
the world it might not help you
over the board if you're not if you
don't fully understand exactly what's
going on and it also helps your
memorization
if you see it over the board rather than
seeing it on the computer so i think
it's still very helpful to
to work over the board so it's also up
to the
the guys who are you know who have been
there a bit longer to to adapt because
all the younger players are improving so
quickly
uh yeah my goal is to is to win the
tournament
[Music]
welcome back to round seven here at the
tata steel jazz fest uh not festival
tournament uh although there is a
festival happening this weekend we'll
tell you about more about that uh in a
few minutes but for now uh dania
the
white king has indeed stepped forward
let's just go back a couple of moves and
see where we left us off
sure so we that they're going down a
line that we did talk about
duda
decided in this position to make a run
for it king b3
queen b1 check king c4 and fabi
correctly finding the first important
move of the sequence going queen e4
forcing the king back to b3 but the
crucial move that he has to find in this
position is f3 why
well there's two things
black has two items on the priority list
the first is to eventually get this king
out of g8 and to f8 so that the queen
can collect the f-pawn otherwise of
course you're going to get mated
currently the queen defends a8 so you
can afford to play f3 but why do you
play f3 play f3 in order to fix the pawn
on f2 if you didn't do that if you
played king f8 in this position this
would be quite a bit less accurate
because now white would be the one to
play f3 and this pawn is essentially
unassailable and white is pretty close
to building a fortress here this
position is still probably losing black
can go queen e1 and then eventually
bring the king out of the eighth rank
and probably target the h6 pawn but f3
is
uh to my eyes a a the only
straightforward win if fabby plays f3
i don't think the win is gonna be in any
doubt
so let's have a look at that if he goes
f3
um first question is what is the most
resistant and just as we talked about it
there he goes f3 is
on the board and uh fabiano really
playing with uh perfect precision here
after the first time control
yeah and i mean
the the engine gives well i think the
obvious move is rook b5 to threaten
checkmate
that forces king f8 unfortunately white
has no
not even an inkling of counter play i
mean he can try knight d7 check
obviously hoping for king e7 but black's
gonna sidestep it with king f7
and if you go back you there's no
perpetual to speak of the board is way
too wide open white's pieces again are
not anchored to anything which means
forks are constantly going to be on the
horizon queen b1 is a threat
i wouldn't say that this is
totally resignable but i wouldn't be
shocked if deuter resigned in the next
couple of moves
yeah the position very difficult not
helped of course by the the time
situation i think
he will try and fight on i always feel
as long as there is a night there is
some
some hope but
yeah it seems impossible for now to
engineer any play against the the black
king
yeah
he's running out of time too
he is yeah rook b5 the move you are
suggesting i think it makes sense to try
and uh activate the work but if we look
at the the do that come
um it makes me more likely to agree with
you that this game isn't gonna
go on for too much longer
no there's too many threats and of
course black's ultimate approach here is
to play king f8 and then to go after the
f1 and if black wins the f on the game
is over immediately
in some of these positions
white can
white should definitely consider a move
like knight takes f3 the problem here is
that the h6 pawn cannot be defended and
black goes after it and once you have a
pass pawn in these types of situations
the game is over so
this is unsustainable and not feasible
you can see duda
sitting there
all alone yeah this is like the ultimate
you know we can all relate to that
you're the last the last game standing
you know you're going to lose it and
fabi
taking a walk around the playing hall
watching do the suffer
a little stretching
right a fabby is fabi's in a good place
right now he knows he's winning
yeah definitely um
he will be
so happy with that bounce back victory
young christoph duda
we need to start
all right all right all right
okay
i feel like we're being assaulted here
every time danya we really are i mean i
think we need a different producer
petition petition to get a new producer
sign sign it now
just kidding just kidding you see now i
feel bad we love you
i like hardani it's your first day here
in the in the
commentary and already you're trying to
get our producer fire i'm already
agitated i'm already agitating for a new
producer right that's just what i do i i
come to a place and i and i all i do is
just i wreak havoc i i destroy how can
you
look at this man
um
no i i have to relent actually big i
guess
he's safe
and meanwhile someone who's not having
nearly as much fun as we are here is
a duda who is
shaking his head um
in disgust he is of course looking for
some i think what happens in those spots
is uh you look after rook b5 what can i
do after the check where does the king
go and none of the lines you're looking
at really lead anywhere and he's going
to have to make a decision
within a couple of minutes because he's
down to 11 minutes on the clock there's
10 moves to play until the second time
control
and no amount of time is going to help
him here
no so what if i think i agree with you
that rook b5
can the rook go
elsewhere is
yeah but we can go to c5 also but uh
this doesn't change the nature of the
position and black still goes king f8
and
okay the computer likes this move a4
which is
i don't see a human playing okay dude is
about to make a move let's see what he
does
but i guess even if black on croissants
see the thing is black doesn't even need
to hurry with queenie too black can just
casually get get the king up and
uh introduce further
you know discoordination in among
white's ranks so it's lost no matter how
you slice it no matter how you look at
it and black has multiple approaches
yeah and it's so frustrating for young
sister of duda like how the
the night and the rook just really don't
work well together here it looks like he
was hovering over the night
oh i guess he wants knight c4
which is obviously desperation
but uh yeah i mean
he is he's really upset and you can't
really blame him i think he's gonna play
knight c4 if he's something over the
night it's the only feasible square that
i see
yeah and so
knight uh c4 maybe we can have a quick
look at that
while uh duda drops under 10 minutes so
knight c4 at least now the pieces are
protected but uh are we just gonna go
after the f pawn what are we
this also looks i mean we're gonna give
a check
if king a4
then queen takes a2 and queen takes f2
his game over
so white is forced to play i mean that
this presumably is the idea of
knight c4 but among other things there's
the winning move queen c one worming
the way to c3 chiseling
at white's position here and there's
just no way to stop queen c3 i guess you
can play knight a4 but then
uh queen a3 track and again queen takes
and this always happens right when you
have a queen and multiple anchor points
that are formed by pawns you can see how
bad the rook and the knight is at
covering all of those squares there's
just no chance
uh for the rook and the knight to cover
all of the queen's entry points and i
think all of these lines that we are
showing on the board that's exactly
what's going on in yanshi of duda's mind
and why we see him repeatedly you know
shake his head because
you're so desperate to find
something to at least keep some hopes
even if you know the position is lost
you want to find some lines you think i
still got a rook and the night my
knights are such tricky pieces how can i
engineer some kind of threat the king is
not looking great on g8
but somehow
just nothing nothing is working the
pieces are not well placed the king is
too much out in the open and it looks
like every line uh duda is looking at is
just leading nowhere
yeah you can i mean the frustration is
palpable he's sort of talking to himself
and i think that he's
what he's probably most frustrated about
is
you know probably getting a good
position out of the opening then
kind of ruining that but then he came
back like there was a moment at which we
thought fabi would blow him off the
board
then duda got his king to c1 he seemed
to stabilize and i think what's getting
to him is blundering ip5 i think
i think missing knight b5 also caused
them to tilt and that in turn lets a
rupty one because after queen b2 he was
still
very much in the game and in fact the
likeliest result there would have been a
draw yeah so it was still still fine for
him an uncharacteristic series of
blunders
by jan kristoff in this game especially
so because the players had just received
the additional time so it'll be
i'd be curious to know what him is i
don't think we'll be hearing
from do that tonight but
i'm also looking forward to what fabiano
will have to say and yeah duda we see
him there dropping uh under
seven minutes we are on move 50 so still
10 moves to go but i think very unlikely
we'll even make it there yeah i don't
think we're going to make it to mc50 i
mean he's he
he keeps hesitating on a move and then
grabbing his head again and repeating
that routine for the last 10 minutes so
he's gonna have to make a decision at
some point but he
there's there's no moves i mean there is
no way to create even
a single opportunity for black to go
wrong and dania well we see the results
of the round so far they're under the
camera and what a first day it's been
for you just joining me here in round
seven and you're gonna get four decisive
results on your uh first commentary day
well they were you know they were saving
their fighting spirit of course for
for uh me joining and they and you know
they kept all the boring draws for hess
that's how i arranged it
but yeah what a a lot of blood was
spilled today and uh
definitely the pride game against magnus
is going to eat at prague for a long
time because
man he was very close to causing extreme
problems for magnus
yeah for sure but uh instead magnus
beat him after prague maybe missed a
couple of chances a couple of
interesting chances not necessarily for
a big advantage but for
something very promising we'll never
know you will tell us tomorrow i'm sure
you will take a
deep dive on on knight g5
but magnus winning the game in the end
and uh
surprise surprise suddenly he is in the
sole lead after seven rounds
yeah he just finds a way to do that you
know he he seems it's always like ah he
starts with a couple of draws he kind of
starts slow and then before you know it
isn't clear first and that's how magnus
wins tournaments and duda by the way
still has not made a move he's down down
to five minutes
he might resign in this position i mean
with every ticking second
it's less and less likely that he's
going to put up
any resistance past a couple moves there
he's finally made a move
i think it's knight c4 yeah it's knight
c4 so knight c4
i think we're expecting a check on b1
yeah i mean queen b1 and queen c1 is
extremely straightforward you're going
after c3
black and white can give a couple of
checks i suppose
oh white doesn't even have the check on
g5 because the queen guards that square
so
check here
check and the simplest pathway i think
for the king
is to just hide away on on h5
and now it's the gate it's just all over
queen c3
and i think if fabi makes these two
moves duda will be very likely to resign
um dania while we wait here for the next
move we're quickly gonna show uh an
interview
that was recorded a short while ago with
yes epanko so let's hear his thoughts
after the draw against sam shankland
andres benko just played a draw with sam
shankland it looked like you had some
some chances today
yeah i think so um
i think i could play uh queen d5 instead
of queen for and
i saw i saw some
some lines
like
queen d5
king f6
queen g queen g8 and uh
he probably has to play
d3 rook g2 with idea to checkmate on
g6
dc king b2 and bishop c5 and
his idea to play queen c1 and bishop e3
and i wasn't sure
how to win this position and
of course
where
when i played
queen e4 i think queenie four yeah i
miss this his move for
queen g1 of course and after this it's
probably just just a draw
um
in your tournament you're at plus one
you beat uh
sergey karjakin are you happy with your
results so far
yeah probably i'm happy
but
i had some chances against my mediarav
and widget as well
but last two rounds i was
completely
losing
uh
against caroline and duboff so yeah
probably i'm happy
um
also like i look at your schedule you're
you're playing anish geary with white
tomorrow yeah
but apart from that you got most of the
top guns
yeah but um and i'm looking at jordan
for racist tournament he also played he
played five draws at the start against
the top guys and then manage to win the
tournament yeah but i remember last year
i played against
top guys but then i lost to tarry and
yes
so
i'm not sure that it's
uh
too good for me
okay um
when i check the rating list you're
sixth now among the russians
um
with like this olympiad coming up in
moscow in august it's the goal for you
to to be part of the team and to be like
in a top five or top four russia
i would love to of course to be there
but we will see how it
how it goes how is your experience so
far in in this tournament compared to
last year in fact i say
i think it's
almost the same
like usually i have a bad position but
somehow i managed to save to save them
yes probably
probably like this
and what do you do like after the rounds
or before the runs
um
after the rounds
i i'm just trying to
you know to relax some somehow to watch
some football matches uh movies like
this and uh before the game i usually
trying to
prepare
so i'm actually holding you up right now
yeah like the spring really going on
yeah yeah okay sorry in that case i will
let you go
thank you okay thanks thanks
dania i have to say i'm a big yasi panko
fan um and it's funny to hear him not
even certain about his answer to the
question is he happy with his tournament
so far probably yes
but still plenty to play for six rounds
still to come and uh what do we have to
look forward to in tomorrow's round
eight
well we've got some really interesting
matchups shanklin against magnus i'm
really really excited for that one we've
got fabi against jordan
uh zepenko against geary so mom and yara
with a big chance of course prague will
be reeling after his loss today uh and
mom and daraf i wouldn't say that's a
must win for him but with the white
pieces he's going to be pushing hard
karyakin report
and then dubois against duda duda who's
definitely going to lose today
is going to have to
make a comeback
and vid it against grandelias vidit also
has some coming back to do after today's
very painful loss against jordan for
sure with the white pieces
he will try to balance straight back in
his game against niels gwandelus who
after a
bad start he has at least recuperated a
little bit today a very interesting draw
against sergey karjakin so it's been
more solid after this first rest day
plenty of interesting games to look
forward to meanwhile we see here the
queen has landed on b1 duda is down
under three minutes
um i think it's a toss-up between making
a move and resignation here well yeah i
really don't unders don't quite
understand what he's
i mean i usually don't like to say that
like
these players know what to think about a
lot better than i do but i mean i think
knight b2 is essentially forced if
you're blaking a4 he's probably thinking
about whether to resign here or in a
couple of moves but at the end of this
line oops queen takes f2 and
i mean that that's it the queen moves
aside and the pawn promotes that's all
she wrote so
duda now with two minutes one way or
another he's gonna have to decide
in the next couple of moments and if you
play knight b2 then as we discussed i
can guarantee you that fabi is aware of
the move queen c1 just watching due to
seconds tick down
yeah i think it's just a very
frustrating very often uh like this and
we see him make another move
king a4 has appeared on the board and
bobby instantly reaching out for that
pawn on a2
so a2 is now gone f2 will drop
on the next move
and
suddenly that f pawn is only two squares
away from from queening
right and any kind of
what i was thinking about is an end game
where white
eliminates the f pawn
puts his rook on a6 to defend h6 is that
going to be a fortress and it occurred
to me that no it's not uh because black
can use always use zooxvong in those
kinds of positions to dislodge the rook
from wherever it is and duda just keeps
repeating that routine he's shaking his
head looking to the side
yeah it's painful it's painful to look
at it we see they're not completely
alone in the playing hall one of our
challenges there on camera max varmadam
his game uh well must still be going but
yeah
it's it's painful i think as fellow
chess players we can all
relate to to the pain and the motions
that duda is going through he has just
stepped out
on five v5 not even taking the pawn on
b4 i i think this gives black an extra
win um the engine is not indicating this
but i think
oh i guess b3 there might be king b4
um and then you can still take on f2 of
course but
there's really no need to do that you
can also take on f2 straight away but
fabia fabi goes for b3
and we're going to probably see king
before
queen takes f2 or we'll see resignation
here
yeah um
[Music]
i think this of course getting closer
and just such a tough game for jan
schistov
he
gave an interview yesterday where he
said you know and there is the
resignation so fabiano getting the full
point here and i was saying yeah jan
scherstaff he had missed a few chances
already in the tournament things are not
going his way and hopefully he can
bounce back soon but fabio fabio fabiano
what a comeback victory for him
incredible i mean with the black pieces
against judah and
there's nothing more dejecting than
having black against duda after you've
blundered a rook with the white pieces
uh but that's what makes fabi so
incredible and so consistent at this top
level i mean he's just
he's affected just like everybody by
disappointing results but he doesn't let
it get to him and he maintains his
objectivity he keeps the legs churning
and he converted that today into a very
hard fought it wasn't flawless uh but it
was a working man's win and uh this is a
very big result for him as he gets back
onto 50 and puts himself in a great
position
for the second half of the tournament
absolutely all to play for
still as we see the players there um
getting ready to leave
the playing hall we'll see if we still
get an
interview with fabiano what's definitely
still to come is your rapid
recap of the day i think we're going to
go
on a short break in a second but first
we will show
the results from today
with four games ending decisively one of
them wasn't actually played anish giri
against daniel dubov um
with daniel still expecting the result
from his pcr test so that was a walk
over win for anish but three decisive uh
results on the board magnus carlsen in
his first ever classical encounter
against pragnanda uh winning that game
with the black pieces maybe we'll talk
about it in a sec prank maybe missing
some chances we just saw the longest
game of the round fabiano carrana
beating duda with black and jordan van
forest he got a big victory over one of
the joint leaders vidit gujarati
absolutely it was an incredible day and
even the draws were very hard fought him
in report mahmud yarov
is a very interesting game asapanko
shanklin andre was very very close to
winning he's going to be kicking himself
for that but uh all credit to sam and of
course grandelias
putting together an amazing resistance
with almost no time on the clock against
none other than sergey koryakin so great
results great games all around fiona it
was such a fun round absolutely after
that round we have a new soul leader
we'll show you at the standings a little
bit later but we're going to go to an
interview with fabiano you just beat
young chris of duda with the black
pieces um that must be like a very big
relief for you
yeah i mean it wasn't a good game i'm
sure
um
because i
my position was very comfortable the
whole game
and um
at some point i was clearly like
starting to win and then
uh things went wrong in
in the
run up to move 40 because i'm sure that
i had something much much better than
what i did i i
i don't really know exactly what and it
was all it's all a bit of a blur now but
i'm sure that after move 40 that he has
he shouldn't lose this position um i
don't know what the evaluation is it's a
bit messy and in fact it
what worried me more was even that um
i do take a lot of risk as well because
my king is always in a matey nut
and i was kind of happy to see 95
because at least here it gets very
concrete i was kind of worried he'll
play some move like rookie one
and he might slide the exchange on c3 at
some moment and we get some
sort of very messy position that will go
on and on
um
and after knight b5 it was just like
very straightforward calculation
which i'm sure there were some mistakes
but um kind of once i saw that my king
escapes in this queen against rook and
knight
i knew i wasn't sure if i was winning
but i knew at least i'm i'm better
and uh and then when we got there
suddenly i couldn't see any moves for
him and also i guess he couldn't because
after that it was pretty simple
so you said like you you had to take a
lot of risks um in the opening
which also looked very risky for you do
you think you were in any trouble in the
opening
yeah it's possible um i i kind of didn't
expect him to play london i was
improvising a bit i knew that this line
with g6 and b6 is
playable it black accepts a slightly
worse position
but i you know after yesterday i didn't
really feel like
um
you know going into his preparation
accepting a slightly worse position and
trying to equalize it i thought this
will be more of a fight
and he played ambitiously 95 h4 but it
didn't concern me so much because i
thought that um
i'm trading all the knights off
and after queen d6 i i didn't think i
was any worse maybe he had something
uh better before that i thought maybe
knight df-3 instead of h4
and then try to prepare h4 more slowly
but i didn't feel like i should be in
huge danger um which could could be
wrong and after
after the train on g7 h5 queen d6 i
wasn't worried because his attack is
well he's only attacking with a pawn and
like the rest of his pieces are not very
active
um
and
yeah i
i wasn't too worried
um and i even started to get a little
bit ambitious when he
um
started to make some strange moves queen
b3 rook d1 these moves uh i thought he
would try to cast it along
start some play on the king side and i
would start some play on the queen side
and we would have a typical
um double-edged position but he
he played queen bee through rook d1
suddenly his king was kind of in the
center for the rest of the game
um i i don't i understood he was trying
to get c4 but it didn't feel like c4 is
a huge concern for me
and um
yeah i thought things were going well
and then at some point in time trouble
things got out of hand
and then sorry but i have to ask you of
course about yesterday's game
um
this rook b6 what
what what happened there
i mean it's not uh not really a secret i
just
didn't realize the work was hanging on
b6 um
i mean i i've been kind of i don't want
to make excuses but i've been
emotionally and physically drained
basically the entire trip here and uh
and yesterday was
uh you know
it really showed my play in previous
games it was sort of showing a bit and
also today i think the quality wasn't
there but yesterday was really the
culmination
because anish played horribly
and i think he'll also say that you know
it's i don't mean it as an insult or
anything
um but i played even even worse like
from the opening i mean it wasn't just
that blunder but like the whole game was
was terrible and i think you know you
would expect to see that game
not between two grand masters or even
two international masters but between
two far
far weaker players
thank you yeah i will play that game
and
vikanze is of course a very long
tournament 13 rounds this is only around
seven uh you said that you are kind of
like mentally and physically trained is
the good thing that you have like a win
now and we have like six more runs to go
or do you want to finish the tournament
as soon as possible
i mean yeah i'm
it's not like i'm hoping for very much
at this point you know
um
it's not really even the score but the
my the quality of play is not really
there
um
i mean theoretically of course it's a
long tournament and uh and it's possible
to to rack up some wins but i i don't
know i'm not really thinking about it
i'm just kind of relieved um
and uh yeah i'm honestly i've i've just
been kind of more or less completely
alone here because my coach
uh tested positive for covet and he's in
isolation so i'm just hoping that at
some point he'll test negative he's now
like pretty much asymptomatic
but i hope at some point he'll test
negative and i can actually
have some company because it's it's a
quite a lonely place to be for three
weeks yeah i i know he's a very social
person who likes to hang out after the
game and make walks and everything
with some good company it must be very
hard to to be alone
um
pragananda is like in the same same spot
like you you guys didn't team up
to give each other company
well
we're also competitors and i don't
really know him too well but i i
sympathize that he he's also
um you know it i mean it's
it's not like a tragedy i i think
luckily
um
even though people have uh have tested
positive i don't think that anyone has
gotten really secure
um which is the main plus
uh but yeah it is quite a
quite tough to uh because you know we're
in winter and
everything is closed here um it's not
really the ideal place to be completely
alone
um
but uh at least i i i think now that uh
that vladimir is feeling better
hopefully he can he can rejoin the world
um i mean it's even more miserable for
him because he's he's been locked in a
room for
a week now
okay well i wish both of you uh the best
in the upcoming week
thank you thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what a day it has been round seven of
tata steel is in the books a lot of
decisive results and without further ado
let's get into your rapid recap for
round seven which is going to spotlight
prague's game against the world champion
magnus carlson let's dive into the game
it was a very very interesting
topsy-turvy affair and it started in
relatively quiet fashion was the queen's
gambit declined that very quickly turned
into a queen's gamut accepted
proclaiming knight f3 which is often a
lead-up to a catalan or to a ragozan but
magnus deciding to take on c4 and they
quickly transposed into a mainstream
queen's gambit accepted e3 a6 bishop
takes c4 knight f6 this is all very
normal black counter strikes in the
center with c5 and the first really
interesting moment
of the game
uh prague playing b3 which is quite a
bit more rare than some of the uh
mainstream moves in this position the
two main moves are a4 to stop b5 and d
take c5 which leads into a very well
studied queen's gambit accepted end game
but prague going for b3
magnus responding with b6 i thought that
b5 might have been a bit more natural
but
magnus definitely still in his
preparation
going for b6 and pro going for the hyper
fiance bishop a3
this is where things really started
getting interesting this of course
threatens d take c5 which would ruin
black's pawn structure and so for that
reason
after b6 bishop a3 magnus going knight b
to d7 protecting the pawn on c5
and prague immediately pushing with d5
exploiting the fact that the queen is
now no longer
contacting that square and things very
quickly start getting concerning for
magnus so he takes on d5 bishop takes d5
and the problem here is that if black
takes on d5 with the knight then the
queen jumps out to d5
and things look very very dicey here for
for black after rook b8 there's a very
nice move bishop b2
retreating the bishop to the long
diagonal and if black tries to free
himself with knight f6
uh well among other things there's a
very nasty check on e5 and after bishop
e6 even something like nigeria 5 or the
simple developing move knight bd2 uh
leads to a nasty position for black it's
just hard to get rid of white's very
active pieces and the queen quinn can
swing to g5
as well so magnus deciding against
taking the bishop he decides to go rook
v8 prague repositions the bishop anyway
this is a very very good move uh
preparing himself for
uh the
inevitable moment where black is going
to castle short
so magnus goes bishop b7 both sides
complete their development knight c3
castles and now another very strong move
by prague queen c2 this was the point of
putting the knight on c3 yet again if
black takes the bishop then the bishop
is replaced by the knight and the knight
is no less powerful than the bishop then
white's rook comes out to d1 the queen
and the other bishop both aim at black's
king this is also very very unpleasant
and so magnus deciding to expand on the
queen side with b5
prague responding to that with rook fd1
of course black was threatening b4 and
the bishop would have been lost in that
case
and after queen c7 came a very very
important moment perhaps the most
important moment
in the game and fiona we were surprised
here that prog missed a pretty
straightforward probably didn't miss
this move but he didn't like something
about it
and uh we got very excited both of us
wanted to see knight g5 appear on the
board with some very concrete threats
already against the black king and well
maybe you can show us some of the lines
that could have happened here we had a
lot of fun uh during the game looking at
this so let's take a look
we really did and the first really cool
line happens after bishop b7 what
exactly does knight g5 threaten well
white traits
and then after
well after rook takes b7 white
swoops in with knight d5 and this wins
on on the spawn and after queen takes b7
uh there there's multiple possibilities
here but even even the simple knight d5
does the trick and black's defenses are
totally overwhelmed brook fe-8 and now
bishop takes f6 and then knight takes f6
and white takes on h7 and white is
winning here so black has to respond
pretty immediately to all of these
threats and he can do so by playing h6
but now there's a really pretty line
bishop takes f7 check replacing the
bishop with the knight well you can't
take it because of queen h7 and queen h
a that's called checkmate and after
queen c6 white plays bishop takes f6
and then white takes again black has to
take with a pawn in order to keep the h7
square protected after knight takes f7
and queen h7 check the situation is
quite dire the engine was indicating in
a crazy move king g7 in this position
which maybe keeps black in the game but
man this would not have been fun for
magnus at all and so we were quite
shocked that prague didn't seize this
opportunity to go knight g5 and i will
add that it might have been more
accurate to put the other rook on d1
precisely because of that long line
where this rook from f1 in some
variations can lift itself via f3 but in
any case prague deciding on a more
positional approach playing a4 and
trying to contest black's queen side
magnus he said i'm not letting you put
the knight on g5 twice he immediately
plays h6 and this was a subtle turning
point in the game there's a trade on b5
and here it seems like prague started
floundering just a little bit queen e2
is a natural move hitting the pawn which
magnus defends and now he sends the e
pawn forward this still looks very
intimidating for black because e5 well
that's a very serious threat but magnus
deals with it very expertly he plays
rook e8
and the point is that if white shoves
the pawn forward with e5 black doesn't
have to move the knight magnus steps
back with the bishop the rook pins the
queen and the pawn on e5 is now more of
a weakness
than a strength and this might have been
underestimated by prague who now decides
to move his queen away from
the purview of the rook another
inaccuracy allows magnus to complete the
regrouping with bishop f8 and this is
where prague kind of slides off the
ledge a little bitty place queen f4
still trying whoops still trying to
prepare
e5
apologies for that still trying to
prepare e5
and magnus again he strikes first that
was the theme of this middle game magnus
kept striking first before prague could
accomplish his plans after b4
he's forced to move the knight to a4 and
now fiona another very important moment
it's like agnes kept the tactics kept
working for him he didn't just move his
queen back
he did something a lot more impressive
than that instead deciding to capture on
d5 and things really heated up here and
the tide was starting to turn pregnant
who got such a nice position out of the
opening he missed that one shot knight
g5 magnus stopped it and suddenly he is
the one who's taking control of the
position
exactly the bishop is gone from the
board and now the queen from b6 swings
to e6 a very nifty move attacking e4
and
prague had to go for a very nasty but
defensible position with the move knight
takes c5 this leads to a mass trade on
c5 white takes on b8 and after queen
takes b3 nobody can really blame prague
for uh not wanting to play this position
but according to the engine this was the
best chance uh to to hold the draw it
turns out that the opposite colored
bishops do give white pretty decent
chances after bishop d4 but prague
trying to keep the tension goes rook 81
and magnus immediately bounces rook a8
another very very powerful move
preparing this move c4 when the pawn on
b3 is unsustainable white's entire queen
side collapses prague steps back with
the queen but in comes black queen queen
takes c4 and a very important detail is
that if white white takes twice on d8 on
d7 black goes rook 88
and at the end of the day when the smoke
clears the simple threat of queen e2
followed by rook d1 is utterly
unstoppable black white's pieces are
simply too uncoordinated and so prague
took the opportunity to make some luft
but that gave black the opportunity to
protect the knight now black is up upon
he's dominating
and uh at this point they were entering
the time pressure phase as magnus steps
back with his queen maneuvers it to e6
and
magnus did give prague one more chance
so in this position there was this very
very strong move bishop b7 but with one
minute on the clock that is so hard to
see you have to notice that white takes
the rook then black if a white takes the
knight then black takes white's knight
and black is winning but magnus going
for his
aforementioned idea and playing c4 and
at this point prague had one more chance
he could have taken on g7 with the
bishop loose pieces drop off that rook
on a7 is undefended and at the end of
this line there is a fork on d4 now it
may seem like white is winning white is
not winning because of knight f6 and
unfortunately for white after queen
takes a7 knight takes d5 uh black
emerges a piece up but if we go back in
this position white has a much more
resilient defense and that is the move
rook d6 actually going for the h6 pawn
this might have been what prague missed
in time pressure
this position is really scary for black
and black is still
probably winning white can swing the
rook back to d4 and there's this very
important defensive resource knight f8
and white black is able to make it just
in time defending all of the key squares
but this would have definitely caused
magnus a lot more trouble than the game
in the game prague he plays queen d4
immediately allows the knight to swing
to f6 counter-attacking the rook and the
rest is simple c3 driving the pawn and
all of white's pieces are hanging and
after takes takes
they trade queens and when the smoke
clears the pawn simply promotes the
knight comes into c3 the rook comes into
e2 and after rook b1 rookie 2 prague
resigned since the threat of knight c3
is completely unstoppable
what a game by the world champion and
prague with a big big chance that he got
knight g5 there but that's unfortunately
how it goes when you play magnus you get
nervous and magnus pounced absolutely
mercilessly once he got that chance
fiona
indeed their first classical encounter
magnus walking away with a win that was
your record rapid recap of the day
and now danielle well let's see their
results from round seven
one more time we just went to it magnus
cards and winning a big game with the
black pieces fabiano carrana same a huge
win for him the first of this tournament
against of duda and we've talked about
uh giri
duboff game plenty that was a walk over
with uh duboff still expecting his pcr
result we wish him all the best of
course and jordan van ferece continues
uh his very decisive tournament uh by
beating and
the joint leader going into the
round-fitted gujarati
indeed that was a very impressive game
and let's have a look at the standings
we have the world champion in clear
first he's got five out of seven putting
together a very nice performance
and uh right behind him is chakriar who
had a very nice defensive game against
rehard rapport he's got four and a half
out of seven a big big group with four
so tomorrow's
uh round is gonna be so important some
of these people who've got four out of
seven they're gonna have to win if they
want to contest magnus magnus says black
fiona against sam he's definitely gonna
be playing for a win
uh and you know people like fabi who's
now on 50 he needs to try to make a push
andrea cepenko with the white pieces
against giri and we're going to keep a
close eye on shakaryamayak he's got
white against prague he's the favorite
and he's going to make a big push for
sure
he will try and make the most out of the
white pieces tomorrow trailing magnus by
only half a point let's have a quick
look at the tournament schedule because
tomorrow is at the last game before the
next rest day so tomorrow we'll be back
same place same time 2 p.m central
european time that's 5 a.m
pacific for round 8 and the day after
that january 24th will be a rest day
but for today that is all it's been such
an eventful day dania thank you so much
uh what are your final words here to end
uh at the end of your first day
fiona this was i could not have asked
for a better first day the action was
incredible the games were so so much fun
and these six hours went by in an
absolute flash uh largely because i have
a great co-commentator so fiona this was
so much fun thank you to you thank you
thank you to the producer bick whom i
made feel bad throughout the entire
stream i'll apologize afterwards
and of course thank you to everybody
watching on twitch and on youtube and
supporting your favorite player this was
so much fun i can't wait for tomorrow's
round eight
absolutely the pleasure is all mine
thank you for watching us what a great
day of chess it's been we'll see you
tomorrow for round eight have a good one
bye-bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
you